GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON WOULD LIKE
TO GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED ON
OUR HEALTH COMMITTEE HEARING-
AFTER OUR FIFTEEN MINUTES OF
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS SO- HAVE A
SEAT MISTER GRAY WILL GET RIGHT
TO YOU- BEFORE WE BEGIN TODAY
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A STATEMENT ON
ON PROVIDING TESTIMONY AT THIS
HEARING. AND THAT DOESN'T THE
THREE OKAY. I WE HAVE A FULL
AGENDA TODAY AND WE'RE ASKING
THAT MAIN WITNESSES PLEASE KEEP
THEIR- OF TESTIMONY IN THE TIME
LIMITS OF THREE MINUTES EACH.
ANY WITNESS WHO DOES WHO DID
NOT REQUEST. MAKE THE REQUEST
IN ADVANCE AND ARE NOT ON THE
WITNESS LIST WILL BE LIMITED TO
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ONLY AND NO EXCEPTIONS WILL BE
MADE. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COOPERATION WE HOPE AUTHORS
MYSTICAL IS A RESPECT FOR THIS
PROCESS. WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
HEARING AND DUE TO THE
CONTINUED STAY HOME ORDER WE'RE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SORIA ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. ROSS
REQUIREMENT MASS B. WARNING
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE- IN THE ROOM OR THE
VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. TODAY HERE
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE US A MINIMAL
MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND
THE LIMITED NUMBER THE PUBLIC
AND MEDIA SO WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF SPACING. RUSSELL
STRICT PHYSICAL DISTANCING
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTERED LEAVE THE CAPITOL. FOR
THOSE HERE IN THE ROOM I WOULD
ASK THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON. LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE AT A TIME.
TODAY'S AGENDA WILL BE TAKEN UP
IN THE ORDER LISTED ON THE
AGENDA- AND IN THE DAILY FILE.
IN ADDITION WE TO BE ABLE
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM. WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES. MAKING USE OF OUR
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN
THE CAPITAL. AND OUR REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION LOCATED ON
THE CAPITOL GROUNDS. HE'S
WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON THE
SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH THE
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE THE
HEARING ROOM AND ALSO ASK THEM
QUESTIONS. WILL BE USING A
MODERATE TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY MET ANYONE IS
CONTESTED BY ON A BILL. THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO FOUR
TWO. SIX TWO THREE SEVEN YOU
CAN FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IN THE DAILY FILE. AND
ON YOUR TV SCREEN. FOR CALLING
IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO WELL
BEFORE THE AUTHOR. OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. FOR
CALLING IN PLEASE LEMONADE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE AND MUTE YOUR
LIVE STREAM AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. IF YOUR WITNESS
PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR OR
AGAINST THE BILL YOU WILL BE.
YOU WILL REMAIN ON THE LINE
ALIVE LINE IT WILL NEED TO MEET
YOURSELF AND. YOU'RE CALLED
UPON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE MODERATE
TELEPHONE SERVICE. CALL
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE. TWO ZERO NINE SEVEN.
AND MY STAFF WILL BE THERE TO
TRY TO HELP. ALSO WANT TO KNOW
WE ARE ACCEPTING TESTIMONY-
THROUGH THE POPE- EXCUSE A
WRITTEN TEST MONEY THROUGH THE
POSITION. LETTER PORTAL WITH
INSTRUCTIONS ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. AND YOU CAN FIND THE
EMAIL FOR THE COMMITTEE THERE
AS WELL. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT.
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PUBLIC. THE PEOPLE OF THE
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
STILL FACE. IN FAIRNESS TO
EVERYONE WE WILL NEED TO BE
ESPECIALLY STRICT ON THE TIME
LIMITS TODAY WE'LL HEAR FROM
TWO WITNESSES. UP TO TWO
WITNESSES FOR THREE MINUTES
EACH PER SIDE. AFTER THE MAIN
TO ME WITNESSES FOR EACH SIDE
TESTIFIED IF THERE ARE ANY. WE
WILL GET TO GO TO THE PHONES
COMBINE THE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY FOR BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WILL BE LIMITED TO
THEIR NAME AN ORGANIZATION THAT
THEY REPRESENT ONE AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. WE WILL LIMIT
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ON ANY
BILL TO TWENTY MINUTES- THE
PARTING PROBABLY BILLS ARE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. ANY MEMBER THE
COMMITTEE MAY REMOVE A BILL
FROM CONSENT. THE FOLLOWING
ITEMS ARE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
ELEVEN SIXTY NINE EDUARDO
GARCIA WITH AMENDMENTS. I AM
NUMBER FOUR AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES WITH AMENDMENTS. ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB NINETY EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER WITH
AMENDMENTS ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
AB TWELVE EIGHTY SIX. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS- BILL IS.
A BEAST EIGHT AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
FOUR HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S CALENDAR AT THE REQUEST
OF THE AUTHOR. WE HAVE A
SUBSTITUTE MEMBER TODAY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LISA CALDERON.
FOR SUB FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
VACANCY. FOR TODAY'S HEARING- A
LETTER FROM THE SPEAKER. AS WE
LOST MR BONTA TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE SO WITH THAT
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN. I
BELIEVE MR ARAMBULA DR REGULARS
HERE. I SEE YOU SEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRACE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. AB THIRTEEN
OH SIX THE HEALTH PROFESSIONS
CAREER OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM THE
WHOLE. WHICH WILL HELP US WITH
THE INCREASED DEMAND CREATED BY
THE COAL THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
CALIFORNIANS CURRENTLY FACING
SEVERE AND GROWING SHORTAGES
AND PUBLIC HEALTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND MANY ALLIED HEALTH
PROFESSIONS. GIVEN THAT
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES ARE SUFFERING
DISPROPORTIONATE ADVERSE
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC THE
ECONOMIC CRISES AND PER SYSTEM
PERSISTENT SYSTEMIC IN
EQUITIES. IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
THE FUTURE HEALTH WORKFORCE IS
REPRESENTATIVE OF THESE
POPULATIONS. LARGE SCALE
EXPANSION OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COLLEGE STUDENTS FROM MINORITY
AND UNDER RESOURCE POPULATIONS
TO GRADUATE SECURE JOBS ENTER
HEALTH PROFESSION SCHOOLS AND
SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES WILL
ACCELERATE THE CODED RECOVERY
AND ADVANCE CRITICAL HOLD
WORKFORCE AND HELP EQUITY. WE
NOW PRIORITIZE TERM HEALTH
OUTCOMES IN OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES BY SUPPORTING
DIVERSITY IN OUR HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE. LACK OF ACCESS TO
CARE AN AGING POPULATION AND A
SHORTAGE OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS STATEWIDE- ARE
BRINGING TO THE FOREFRONT THE
CHALLENGES THAT COBIT NINETEEN
REPRESENTS FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. MANY OF WHOM CHOSE
NOT TO SEEK MEDICAL CARE
BECAUSE OF FEAR AND DISTRUST IN
SYSTEMS THAT DO NOT ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS THEIR CULTURAL AND
LINGUISTIC NEEDS. AB THIRTEEN
OH SIX AIMS TO UPDATE EXISTING
HEALTH PROFESSION CAREER
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM CODE TO
ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE OF
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL
PROVIDES KEY ACTION
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS BARRIERS
TO THOSE WHO ARE ENTERING
HEALTH PROFESSIONS FOR UNDER
REPRESENTED LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
THE CIVIC WEEK AB THIRTEEN OH
SIX RECOMMENDS THE FOLLOWING
ACTIONS TO THE LEGISLATURE. ONE
THE FUNDING OF TWENTY PILOT
PROGRAMS ONE ON FIVE CAMPUSES
IN EACH OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY AND THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SYSTEM AND UP TO FIVE PROGRAMS
AT PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES. THE
CREATION OF A PUBLIC PRIVATE
HEALTH CAREER OPPORTUNITY
PROGRAM OFFICE TO SECURE ON
GOING FUNDING AND TO ESTABLISH
THE STATEWIDE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
DEVELOP IMPLEMENT AND MANAGE
THIS PROGRAM. TO INVEST IN
INTERNSHIP AND FELLOWSHIPS TO
ALLOW STUDENTS TO COMPETE FOR
ADMISSION TO GRADUATE HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL PROGRAMS. OR TO
GAIN EMPLOYMENT AND THE
CREATION OF ONE HUNDRED POST
BACCALAUREATE RE APPLICANTS
LOCKS ANNUALLY AT EXISTING UC
CSU AND PRIVATE CALIFORNIA
pROOM DOCTOR WHO HAS PRACTICED
IN UNDERSERVED AREAS I KNOW THE
ADVANTAGES OF HIRING DOCTORS
WITH KNOWLEDGE OF THE LANGUAGE
AND CULTURAL BACKGROUND OF THE
POPULATION THEY WILL SERVE.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
JEFF OXEN DINE DIRECTOR OF
HEALTH WORKFORCE AND DIVERSITY
WITH THE UC BERKELEY SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. THANKS VERY MUCH
DOCTOR REGULARLY TO OUR
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR OUR PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. HELLO OP OPTION
NINETEEN BEGINNING YES PLEASE
GO- HI NINE AFTERNOON- I AM AND
A DOCTOR EMILY SAID UNDERGRAD
OF WORK FOR UNIVERSE OF
BERKELEY SCHOOL PUMP HEALTH I
SERVED AS A CODA OF THE COW.
FUTURE HEALTH WORKFORCE
COMMISSION THAT WAS CO CHAIRED
JANET POLLOCK THE FIGURE OF
THAT YOU SYSTEM IN LLOYD CEO
DIGGING HEALTH THE COMMISSION
FOCUS WAS THE BILL A ROAD
DEBATE HEALTHCARE FORCE TO MEET
TO HELP NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS
YOUR HONOR PORTION ASSEMBLY
WOULD. WHAT THE MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE. ASIAN ISSUED ITS
REPORT IN FEBRUARY OF TWENTY
NINE. WHICH INCLUDED TEN TOP
RECOMMEND- THE TWO SEVEN IN THE
PERCENT ONE WORK YOU SHOULD.
ESTABLISHED OF THE HEALTHCARE
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM. AND TWENTY
WE PILOT COPPER- EXTREMELY. IN
A THIRTY OF SIX WAS AMONG THE
TEN. RECOMMENDATIONS COMMISSION
PRIOR IT AND URGE IMPORT.
SOLUTION SHOULD THE SHORT OF
TODAY. MENTAL CLUB HEALTH AND
PROVIDE CAL. TO ADDRESS THE
UNDER. OF OUR MERGING MINOR AND
MAJORITY. AND WORKFORCE.
IMPLEMENTED FROM H. GRANT NOW
ADDRESS THESE IS MORE CRITICAL
THAN EVER AS WE'VE ALL.
UNFORTUNATELY IN. DISTRICT IN
OF. ON OF COLOR AND THE UNDER.
ROOT CAUSE INEQUITY THAT IS MAD.
MORE MINOR PROVIDE IN THE TO
HELP THE GAPS IN THE- THIS.
DISABILITIES COPPER IS A KEY
STRETCH FOR A- THE- OF. DIVERSE
CANDIDATES YOU CAN. ENTER
PROJECT FROM HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL SHORTAGE AREAS LIE
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN EMPIRE.
AND RURAL AREAS. EACH COP
RECRUIT UNDER OF FOR AND CALL
STUDENTS THESE CAN BE. AND
PROVIDE PROOF ACTED CAREERS SO
AND THEN. SUPPORT TO HELP
PEOPLE GET IN BECOME GET INTO
AND PAY FOR HELP. SCHOOL WE'RE
FORTUNATE THERE THOUSAND OF CAN
CALL. CSU SEE AN STUDIO IN OUR
WHO WORE TO BECOME. A LEADER TO
OR FROM YOU CAN YOU. AND WHO
NEEDED COOPER GRANTS AND WELL
IN CHOICE. GRADUATE GET JOBS
AND RELY THEIR TO OF THE HEALTH
AND SO THEIR- AND PROVIDE YOU
SIXTY PRO. NOW IT'S PART OF H.
AGE THAT. KAI CAN'T HELPING IN
UP. AND IMPACT ANALYSIS OF.
PROPOSED IS THAT FORTY EIGHT
THREE. STUDENTS. UNITS FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED BACKGROUNDS TO
SUCCEEDING IN COLLEGE BECOME.
THAT KENNEDY TO HELP
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS AND JOIN
THE HEALTH WORKFORCE. I'M A
NATIVE AMERICAN I MYSELF WAS
FORTUNATE TO BE A PRODUCT OF AN
H. COP PROGRAM WHEN I WAS IN
COLLEGE. NAY LAUNCHED MY CAREER
I WENT ON TO BECOME A PUBLIC
HEALTH LEADER AND LEADINGAGE
COP PROGRAM AT UC BERKELEY. IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH STANFORD AND
UCSF AND STAMPED HIS CASTING
FOR FIVE YEARS SO I KNOW THE
IMPACT. AND THERE'S BEEN MANY
OTHER SUCCESSFUL EACH COP
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING FRESNO STATE UC SAN
DIEGO EXTENSION FOR TEN. THIS
OP CONCLUDED BY SAYING THAT AN
EXAMPLE OF. THE BENEFITS OF H.
COPIES TO FRESNO STATE H. COP
PROGRAM WHICH IS PRODUCED.
DOCTRINAIRE MERITSHE WORKS IN
THE EMERGENCY ROOM A COMMUNAL
MEDICAL CENTER DR PATRICK WITH.
AMERICAN SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT
OF THAT MEDICAL CENTER DR
ADRIANA VIDEO WITH A FAMILY
PHYSICIAN AND ALL THESE PEOPLE.
ARE PROVIDING CARE FOR
UNDERSERVED IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND ALL ARE FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENTS.
IMPACTED BY BY THIS PROGRAM SO
THAT THIS TIME IT'S MORE
CRITICAL THAN EVER DIVERSIFYING
SHRINK DOWN HEALTH WORKFORCE
AND TO PROVIDE. ECONOMIC CAREER
AND EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
FROM PEOPLE FROM MOST IMPACTED
BY KOBE. I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
YOU TO SUPPORT. THIS PROVEN
EACH COP SOLUTION. THANK VERY
MUCH THANK. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO- OTHERS IN SOME. OR A- WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY REGISTERED
OPPOSITION- SO THEY WILL JUST
GO TO THE LINE. PLEASE OPEN OUR
PHONE LINES FOR- OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR
NAME. ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE IN YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL PLEASE. WHENEVER
YOU'RE PREPARED FOR OPPOSITION
OF AB THIRTEEN AFFECT MY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE WILL GO
TO LINE UP FOR SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
RESIDENTS ON BEHALF OF CG
BEHAVIORAL SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK I GOT WIND OF A FOUR
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU TERM MEMBER SERVERS
ON THE HELP OF THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICT SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
NEXT OVER TO LINE UP FOR EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IF THE
BARBARA PLAYED TO WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU. AND
ONE MOMENT WHERE THEY GET THEIR
MY NUMBER THEY JUST ALL QUEUED
UP. AND AGAIN WE ARE ON AB.
THIRTEEN OH SIX. CORRECT ONE
MOMENT ONE MOMENT.
WHERE WE
WILL GO TO A LINE OF FOUR FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HE SAID MY
NAME I LESLIE TORRENT FROM
DISTRICT SEVEN OF CALIFORNIA
AND I SUPPORT- THIRTEEN OF THE
STE THANK YOU NEXT CALLER THANK
YOU. AND WE WILL GO TO ONE
MOMENT. OKAY WE BOUGHT A PRESS
ONE AND ZERO ONE TIME. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE.
AND WE'RE GONNA
GO TO A LINE OF FOUR TWENTY SIX
pON FOREVER THE NATIONAL COUNCIL
FOR DIVERSITY IN HEALTH
PROFESSIONS AND WE SUPPORT AB
THIRTEEN OH SIX. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SCHOLAR PLEASE. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE ONE MORE IN Q.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO A LINE OF FOUR
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE ASIAN OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ON COLLEGES AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT. YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU AND I SEE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
OR OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. C. NINE THE
BILL DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION HOWEVER WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM YET DOCTOR
REGULAR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
AND THE TIME IS APPROPRIATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I SEE NO
OTHER AUTHORS PRESENT MR GREY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR
BILL. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. AB TEN FIFTY PROTECTS
ONE OF THE VERY FEW REVENUE
STREAMS THAT FEDERAL QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS HAVE TO INVEST
IN THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO
IMPROVE HEALTH CARE OUTCOMES-
AS TRUE SAFETY NET PROVIDERS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES IS UNDERTAKING THE
MEDICARE ARE EX TRANSITION TO
UTILIZE CALIFORNIA'S MASSIVE
PURCHASING POWER. TO SECURE
BETTER PRICES ON EVER MORE
EXPENSIVE PHARMACEUTICAL DRUGS.
UNFORTUNATELY ONE OF THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
TRANSITION PLAN IS TO DISRUPT
THE THREE FORTY B. DISCOUNT
DRUG PURCHASING PROGRAM. WHICH
ALREADY REQUIRES DRUG
MANUFACTURERS TO GIVE
DISCOUNTED PRICING TO MEDICAID
F. Q. H. SIX. THESE REBATES AND
SAVINGS ARE CRITICAL SOURCE OF
REVENUE FOR FQHCS WERE REQUIRED
TO ADDRESS THE FUNDS RIGHT BACK
INTO THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE.
WELL I AGREE WITH THE OVER
ARCHING GOALS OF SECURING
BETTER DRUG PRICES USING OUR
STATE PURCHASING POWER. WE'VE
YET TO STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE
TO MITIGATE THE ADVERSE IMPACTS
THIS CHANGE WILL HAVE ON THE
SECURITIES. I APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PREVIOUS
DECISION TO DELAY THE
TRANSITION TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TIME. HOWEVER THE
ONE TIME FUNDING INCLUDING THIS
BUDGET LAST YEAR DOES NOT DOES
LITTLE TO COMPENSATE FQHCS FOR
THIS ONGOING PROBLEM. WHILE
THESE IMPACTS MAY BE EASILY
DISMISSED AS UNFORTUNATE
DETAILS AT THE STATE LEVEL
CUTTING THE FUNDING AFTER WHICH
IS HAVE TO BENEFIT THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IS INCREDIBLY
CONCERNING IN RURAL CALIFORNIA.
WHERE WE ALREADY SUFFERS FROM A
LACK OF MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS
AND INFRASTRUCTURE. RFQ AGE SHE
IS ONE OF THE VERY FEW GOOD
THINGS MY DISTRICT HAS GOING ON
FOR IN THE HEALTH CARE AROUND.
AND ONE OF THE LAST RESOURCES I
WANT TO SEE CUTS AS A BY
PRODUCT OF MEDICARE ARE EX. AB
TEN FIFTY PROHIBITS DH CS
REGARDING CHANGES TO THE THREE
FORTY B. WHICH HAS AN ADVERSE
IMPACT ON THOSE FQHCS. THIS
PROHIBITION IS NARROW. IT
INTENDED TO ALLOW OTHER MEDIC
CAL OUR EXCHANGES WHICH DO NOT
IMPACT FQHCS ADVERSELY. WELL
THIS BILL- IN PLACE- AFFECTS
ANY ADVERSE IMPACTS TO EVACUATE
SEES IT WILL REQUIRE STATUTORY
CHANGES WHICH LEGISLATURE MUST
CONSENT TO AND I THINK THAT'S A
GOOD THING MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THAT DIFFERS FROM THE STATUS
QUO OVER WE HAS LEGISLATIVE
BODY HAVE NO DIRECT SAY OVER
THE POLICY EXCEPT THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS- I THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE A DIRECT SEAT AT
THE TABLE TO ENSURE ANY ADVERSE
IMPACTS TO ALMOST MORAL
COMMUNITIES ARE IN FACT FULLY
MEDICAID. AB TEN FIFTY A
SUPPORT BY HEALTH CENTERS
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE THERE
IS NO OPPOSITION. I HAVE WITH
ME MISTER CHAIRMAN ON THE PHONE
TODAY- TORY STAR WITH OPEN DOOR
COMMITTEE HEALTH CENTER AND
ANDREW WHITE WITH THE COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTER ALLIANCE FOR
PATIENT ACCESS- TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT TESTING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR GREY WILL HAVE OUR
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
YOUR LINES ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN WOULD END
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS STORY STAR I AM THE CEO
OF OPEN DOOR COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS OPEN DOORS THE LARGEST
PROVIDER OF PRIMARY CARE IN THE
FAR NORTHWESTERN COMMUNITY AND
HUMBOLDT AND DEL NORTE
COUNTIES. LAST YEAR WE PROVIDED
CARE SERVICE TO MORE THAN SIXTY
THOUSAND PATIENTS ACROSS THE
GEOGRPHIC AREA THE SIZE OF THE
CONNECTICUT. WE HAVE TWELVE
CLINICAL SITE SERVING THE
COMPLETE SPECTRUM OF PATIENTS
FROM BIRTH TO DEATH WE ARE ALSO
THE LARGEST FOR WRITER
PREGNANCY SERVICES IN OUR
COMMUNITY DELIVERING ALMOST
SEVEN HUNDRED BABIES LAST YEAR
WE HAVE BEEN SERVING THE NORTH
COAST FOR ALMOST FIFTY YEARS
AND NOW EMPLOYS A STAFF OF MORE
THAN SEVEN HUNDRED PEOPLE. ALL
HEALTH CENTERS INCLUDING OPEN
DOOR HAVE LEVERAGE THEIR
SAVINGS FROM THE THREE FORTY B.
PROGRAM TO EXPAND CARE AND
SERVICES TO THE STATE'S MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. THE
RURAL AREAS OF THE STATE HAVE
CONSIDERABLE CHALLENGES AND
DISPARITIES RELATED TO THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH.
WHICH NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR
HEALTH CENTERS ABILITY TO
DELIVER HIGH QUALITY COST
EFFECTIVE CARE. THE THREE FORTY
B. PROGRAM HAS HELPED OUR
HEALTH CENTERS OVERCOME MANY OF
THESE BARRIERS TO CARE. WE
UTILIZE THE SAVINGS TO EXTEND
OUR OUTREACH TO ISOLATED IN
HARD TO REACH POPULATIONS.
IMPROVE THE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION OF STAFF. FACILITATE
OUR WORKFORCE COMPETITIVENESS
WITHIN THE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PATIENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
TAKE CONTROL OF IMPROVING THEIR
HEALTH AND TO INCREASE
BEHAVIORAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES. SO VITAL TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES OF DEPRESSION AND
ANXIETY COMMON IN OUR
POPULATION. WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS GRAY FOR
INTRODUCING THIS IMPORTANT
PIECE OF LEGISLATION. THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT MILLIONS OF MEDICAL
PATIENTS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
NOT HARMED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
PLAN TO MOVE THE MEDICAL
PHARMACY BENEFIT OUT OF MANAGED
CARE. AND INTO FREE FOR SERVICE
BENEFITS. WE ALL AGREE WITH THE
GOALS OF THE GOVERNOR'S INTENT
AS A MEDIC CAL ARE EX PROGRAM.
IN ITS CURRENT FORM HOWEVER THE
IMPLEMENTATION WILL ACTUALLY
CAUSE HARM TO CALIFORNIA'S
SAFETY NET PROVIDERS. THE
CURRENT SOLUTION PROPOSED BY
THE STATE CAN MITIGATE THE
KNOWN NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF THE
MEDICAL OUR ACTS. ON THE SAFETY
NET IS INADEQUATE. IN EQUITABLE
IN TRANSIENT BEING DEPENDENT ON
FUNDING PRIORITIES EACH YEAR.
IT WILL RESULT IN A SIGNIFICANT
AND MEASURABLE DECREASE IN THE
CARE AND SERVICE WE ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE TO OUR PATIENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. IT WILL HAVE A
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE OVERALL.
HEALTH OF THE COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE. THE LEGISLATION BY
FORWARD BY SOME GRAY IS. AND
IT'S UP. THAT NEEDS- THE USER
HAS BETTER. TO ENSURE THAT
HEALTH CENTERS WITHIN THE
SAFETY NET ARE NOT HARMED. AND
ARE ABLE TO CONTINUE THEIR CARE
SERVICES TO THE STATE OF
HONORABLE POPULATIONS WE
STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT THE
COMMITTEE SUPPORTS THE PASSAGE
OF AB TEN FIFTY TO ENSURE THAT
THE MEDICAL PHARMACY
TRANSITION. DOES NOT CAUSE
IRREPARABLE DAMAGE TO
CALIFORNIA'S SAFETY NET
INCLUDING OUR OWN COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS. THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
CONCERNS AND A PATH FORWARD TO
MUTUAL SUCCESS. THANK YOU
BEFORE WE GO TO THE NEXT
WITNESS WHICH IS WE HAVE A
QUORUM AND ASK. OUR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT
MAYES HERE AGUIAR-CURRY BIGELOW.
BURKE CARILLO LARA MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY NAZARIAN. RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO WALDRON
CALDERON. REFORM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO NOW WE'LL GO BACK TO
OUR IN HERE OUR SECOND WITNESS-
PLEASE GO AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
WOULD MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS ANTHONY WHITE AND I
SPEAK TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER
ALLIANCE FOR PATIENT ACCESS.
DELIGHTED IN ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING THIRTY ONE
CALIFORNIA DEFINITELY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS OUR MEMBERS ARE
LOCATED ACROSS THE STATE FROM
SAN DIEGO IN THE SOUTH. THE
GREATER LOS ANGELES ON THE M.
INLAND EMPIRE AND CENTRAL
VALLEY SAN FRANCISCO SACRAMENTO
AND NORTH THE SHAFT AND
HUMBOLDT COUNTY'S. WE CARE FOR
OVER TWO POINT ONE MILLION
PATIENTS ANNUALLY AND THE VAST
MAJORITY OF WHICH- ARE INSURED
BY MEDICAID THROUGH MANAGED
CARE PLANS. WE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GREAT FOR INTRODUCING
THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT MILLIONS OF MEDIC HELP
PATIENT ACROSS THE STATE WHO
CURRENTLY BENEFIT FROM THE
THREE FORTY B. PROGRAM ARE NOT
HARMED BY THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN
TO MOVE THE MEDICAL PHARMACY
BENEFIT OUT OF MANAGED CARE IN
INTO A FEE FOR SERVICE BENEFIT.
WITH THE GOAL OF THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT BEGAN THE
PHARMACY TRANSITION ARE
LAUDABLE. CANNOT HAPPEN AT THE
EXPENSE OF CALIFORNIA'S SAFETY
NET. MCCARTY NAKED THE THREE
FORTY B. DOT COM PROGRAM I
COULD NOT EVEN CLEARER AND IT
TENDS. TO ENABLE COVERED
ENTITIES AND I QUOTE TO STRETCH
SCARCE FEDERAL RESOURCES AS FAR
AS POSSIBLE REACHING MORE
ELIGIBLE PATIENTS AND PROVIDING
MORE COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES.
WITHOUT ACTION BY THIS
COMMITTEE IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE WE SEEKTO
EXTREMELY GOVERNMENT
DETRIMENTAL HARMS THAT WOULD
BEFALL OUR SAFETY NET
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. FIRST OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO BE
RIPPED FROM HEALTH CENTERS THE
FUND INTENDED BY CONGRESS TO GO
TO HELP CENTER DISTRICT
RESOURCES AND PROVIDE HEALTH
CARE ACCESS. WILL NOT BE
DIVERTED BY THE STATE INTO THE
STATE TREASURY. HAS
RIDICULOUSLY CONCERNING GIVING
THAT HEALTH CENTERS HAVE BEEN
ON THE FRONT LINES OF THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC FOR
MORE THAN A YEAR AND ARE NOW
BEING RELIED UPON BY THE STATE
TO ENSURE VACCINE EQUITY
STATEWIDE. FURTHER UNDERCUTTING
THE SAFETY NET IN THIS WAY WITH
ME CAP HEALTH CENTERS AND
RESULT IN PROGRAM CUTS. AND
SIGNIFICANT EMPLOYEE LAY OFFS.
THE SECOND MOST SIGNIFICANT
HARM WOULD BE A MEDICARE
RECIPIENTS THEMSELVES. THESE
ARE THE LOWEST INCOME AND MOST
VULNERABLE FAMILIES IN OUR
STATE. NOT ONLY WILL THE
EXPERIENCE DECREASED ACCESS TO
CARE TO THE PROGRAM AND
EMPLOYEE CUTS AT COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS. THEY WILL HAVE
DECREASED ACCESS TO QUALITY
CARE AT THEIR HEALTH CENTER
CLINICAL PROVIDERS WILL NO
LONGER HAVE ACCESS. TO THE
IMPORTANT INFORMATION ABOUT
PHARMACEUTICAL THERAPEUTICS
THAT ARE USED AS A PART OF
THEIR TREATMENT. ADDITIONALLY
MEDICARE RECIPIENTS BENEFITING
FROM THE THREE FORTY B. PROGRAM
WILL BE FORCED TO HAVE TO
HEALTH PLANS OF SEXUALLY ONE
FURTHER MEDICAL CARE. AND AND
ONE FOR ANY MEDICATIONS THAT
THEY'RE SUBSCRIBER IS FURTHER
COMPLICATED CARE FOR MEDICARE
RECIPIENTS WHO OFTEN ALREADY
STRUGGLE WITH THE COMPLEX
MEDICAL SYSTEM. WITH HER STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TEN FIFTY TO
ENSURE THAT THE MEDICAL
PHARMACY TRANSITION INCLUDES
PROTECTION OF THE CONGRESSIONAL
INTENDED RESOURCES FOR HEALTH
CENTERS PROVIDE THE BEST CARE
POSSIBLE FOR OUR STATE'S MOST.
VULNERABLE FAMILIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY- WE NOT HAVE ANY
REGISTERED OPPOSITION SO WE'LL
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES NOW
FOR- TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL AND WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY- OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES. GIVE. IF YOU ARE IN
ODER OPPOSITION OF AB TEN
FIFTY. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO NOW. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE UP FOR SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRED MEMBER MEGAN
BURKE ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLUS ADVOCATE IN SUPPORT
OF AB TEN FIFTY. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU. AND
NEXT WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF
THE FOUR SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. JOHN BLAINE CEO OF
AVENAL COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER
WE CALL IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
FIFTY THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE THANK YOU. I ONE MOMENT
WE DO HAVE QUITE A FEW IN Q. WE
JUST HAVE TO GET THEIR LINE
NUMBER. AND WE WILL GO TO A-
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI NINE FOUR EIGHT EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE FIVE OH
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES HI
MY NAME IS I MEAN IF I HAVE A
LEAD I AM CALLING ON BEHALF OF
GOLDEN VALLEY HEALTH CENTER AND
I'M CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TEN FIFTY. THANK YOU THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE THANK YOU. BUT
TRY FOUR EIGHT EIGHT AGAIN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BEN AV FROM
ALLSTATE HELP IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE THANK
YOUR NEXT RECORD. BOGART FIVE
OH SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU
CAN BANK ON BEHALF OF CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP FOR HELP
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL
GO TO A LINE OF FIVE FOURTEEN
HERE ALLIANCE OPEN. THIS YEAR
ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS OF THE TEKAPO AND I
SUPPORT A. B. THANK. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE
NUMBER FIVE OH EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CAMMY FRASER SHINGLE
TOWN MEDICAL CENTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THANK YOU. AND ONE MOMENT WE
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. ONE MOMENT.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE UP FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS KANIKA MIND FROM
INTERIOR OF EACH COMMUNITY
CLINIC PHYSICIANS DO AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ALSO%
CAN. FIFTY THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE TWO MORE IN Q. ONE MOMENT.
HE BUT I GET THEIR LINE NUMBER
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I WILL GO TO
THE LINE OF FIVE TWENTY FIVE.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HE THAT
WORKS WITH A LOT MASTER FAMILY
CLINIC AND WE SUPPORT AB TEN
FIFTY. Q. NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
ACCESSIBLE TO LINE UP FIVE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIVE SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DO YOU HAVE A TIME YOU.
NEXT OVER THE LINE OF FIVE
TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI SCOTT MCFARLANE CEO M. CHL
CENTERS I SUPPORT AB TEN FIFTY.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO MARK
YOU AT THE TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. I HAVE A COUPLE
COMMENTS- MISTER GRAY- I
RECOGNIZE A PROBLEM THIS BILLS
TRYING TO SOLVE I'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT THIS FOR QUITE A
WHILE QUITE- THE THREE FORTY B.
TOPIC HAS BEEN THE TOPIC OF
DISCUSSION FOR WELL OVER A
YEAR- POSSIBLY LONGER- I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT VOTE FOR THE
BILL TODAY IT'S ARE DEADLINE
HEARING AND I WANT TO DISCUSS
ON THIS TOPIC TO CONTINUE. BUT
I DON'T THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT
SOLUTION TO ADDRESSING THE
PROBLEM I DO WANT TO GIVE YOU
AN CLINICS- THE PROPONENTS TIME
TO COME UP WITH ANOTHER
SOLUTION I THINK WOULD BE
ACCEPTABLE TO THE
ADMINISTRATION. YOU HAVE A
TIMING PROBLEM IF MEDICAL R. X.
IS IMPLEMENTED THIS YEAR. MY
READ OF THE BILLS IS THAT. IF
THIS BILL- IS- TAKES EFFECT- MY
READ OF THE BILL IS UNLESS THIS
BILL TAKES EFFECT BEFORE
MEDICARE ARE EX IS IMPLEMENTED-
I DON'T. THINK THAT YOU SOLVE
THE PROBLEM- IT'S ALSO GOING TO
HAVE A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT PRICE
TAG- BECAUSE OF THE ASSUMPTION
BEHIND MEDICO OR REX IS THAT
THE STATE. IS GOING TO HAVE
INCREASE REACHED A REBATES AND
DECREASE- AND REDUCED
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AND THOSE
DON'T OCCUR IN THIS IN THIS
BILL BUT I WANT TO VOTE FOR THE
BILL TODAY- AND ALLOW THE
CONSTRUED- DISCUSSIONS TO
CONTINUE. TO TRY TO FIND A
SOLUTION- WITH IF AND IF THE
BILL DOES SO DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WITH WHICH I
CLOSE. MODES OF MOTION BY
MISTER MAYES AND A SECOND BY
MISTAKE YOUR CURRY. THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIRMAN. YOUR COMMENTS
ARE WELL RECEIVED- I CERTAINLY-
LOOK FORWARD TO FINDING OR
ADOPTING OUR SOLUTION I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'VE CHOSEN
TO FOCUS HERE TODAY ON THE- THE
OBJECTIVE OR THE INTENT. OF THE
EFFORT RIGHT WHICH IS IN FACT
IF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
MOVES US BACKWARDS IN THE SENSE
OF AFFORDABILITY AND INVESTMENT
IN RURAL COMMUNITIES THEN-
THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE BY
PRODUCT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THAT AND WHAT THAT MEANS WE
NEED TO YOU KNOW IN CORPORATE-
SEE BECAUSE OF THIS BILL OR
TAKE OTHER STEPS TO YOUR POINT
TO GET AHEAD OF THE-
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE PROGRAM-
BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF AS WE
ALWAYS DO I KNOW YOU AND I
SHARE VERY SIMILAR
CONSTITUENCIES- AND DISTRICTS
AND- THAT YOU KNOW THESE ISSUES
AS WELL AS I AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING TO RESOLVE IT WITH
YOU- AND WITH THE BODY SO.
THANK YOU FOR THE- DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU
MEMBERS FROM THE- DIALOGUE ON
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER GRAY- THERE IS A
RECOMMENDED ARRAY OF MOTION BY
MISTER MAYES A SECOND BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS AND WEST
MEADOW SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WHAT I WOULD AYE
MAYES MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BURKE. BURKE I
CARILLO. I FLOOR. MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY NAZARIAN RIVAS RIVAS
AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ FIVE
SANTIAGO WLDRON WALDRON AYE
CALDERON CALDERON AYE. STENNIS
ZERO CHIEF TENHO SOME BILLS OUT
OF COMMITTEE AND WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS THAT ON
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU MEMBERS. THANK YOU MISTER
GRAY. SIX WE WERE MOTION ON- AB
THIRTEEN OH SIX BY MISTER MAYES.
PART OF ITEM NUMBER TWO. A
SECOND BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WOOD HI WHAT I MAYES MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE BURKE
BURKE I CARILLO. CARILLO AYE
FLORA MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY
NAZARIAN RIVAS RIVERSIDE
RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO WALDRON
WALDRON AYE CALDERON CALDERON
HIGH. NINE ZERO NINE ZERO THAT
THAT BILL IS OUT OF THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS WE HAVE A
CONSENT CALENDAR. MOTION BY
MISTER MAYES. OF THE SECOND BY
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY- MABEL JUST
USE THAT ALL DAY- SO NOW WE
PROBABLY WON'T- SO- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
INCLUDES ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
ELEVEN SIXTY NINE EDUARDO
GARCIA ITEM NUMBER FOUR EIGHTY
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN EIGHTY NINETY EIGHT MR
FRAZIER- AND ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN AB TWELVE EIGHTY SIX
MISS PTRIE-NORRIS- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WOOD HI WOULD I MAYES
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
CONSENT CONSENT CONSENT.
BIGELOW AYE BURKE BURKE HI
CARILLO CORREO I LARA
MAIENSCHEIN THIS AREA I'M SORRY
MCCARTY NAZARIAN RIVAS. RIVAS
AYE RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO WALDRON
WALDRON HI CALDERON CALDERON
AYE. NINE ZERO NINE ZERO SO THE
CONSENT CALENDARS APPROVED AND
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS TO ADD ON MISTER
CUNNINGHAM WHICH LIKE TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
CURRENTLY HEALTH PLAN SOMETIMES
IS AUTOMATED SYSTEMS AND
ALGORITHMS TO DETERMINE
TREATMENT OFTEN THESE PROGRAMS
ARE REVIEWED AT VERY EARLY
STAGES AND TREATMENT. AND CAN
BE CONTRARY TO DIAGNOSIS
REFERRALS OR EVALUATIONS THAT
CLEARLY INDICATE MEDICAL
NECESSITY UNDER ANY REASONABLE
COMMUNITY STANDARD OF CARE. FOR
PATIENTS THIS CAN CAUSE A DELAY
IN THEIR CARE. RISK AND
PROVIDERS ARE FACED SOMETIMES
WITH AN ADMINISTRATIVE HASSLE
TO ENSURE CONTINUING VISITS AND
CARE. THE SYSTEM RESULTS IN
DELAYS OR STOPPAGE AND ALL
RESEARCH INDICATES POOR
OUTCOMES IN HEALTH AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT. WHAT A DRESS THIS
ISSUE IN THREE WAYS. ONE BY
REQUIRING THESE AUTOMATED
SYSTEMS BE PROGRAMS USING
EVIDENCE BASED GUIDELINES.
NUMBER TWO REQUIRING THAT AN
APPROPRIATELY QUALIFIED
PHYSICIAN OR LICENSED HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONAL HAVE THE
OFFENSE TO SAY IN THE
TREATMENT. AND NUMBER THREE IT
WOULD DISCONTINUE THE
REQUIREMENT FOR PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION FOR CERTAIN
HEALTH SERVICES. FOR THE FIRST
TWELVE VISITS AND THAT I SHOULD
KNOW IT IS LIMITED TO
CHIROPRACTIC CARE PHYSICAL
THERAPY SPEECH AND AUDIO
PATHOLOGY. AND A COUPLE OTHER-
LINES OF CARE- HERE WITH ME TO
PRESENT THIS BILL IS CHRIS REID
WITH THE CALIFORNIA. PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS ASSOCIATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MOVE TO OUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. YES
ECONOMIC THAT RECAP ANOTHER
DOCTOR BECAUSE WHAT THEY'RE
BEING THE PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION WHICH REPRESENTS
MORE THAN NINE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED PHYSICAL THERAPISTS
PHYSICAL THERAPY ASSISTANTS AND
STUDENTS. EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY
EIGHT WILL IMPROVE ACCESS AND
REDUCE DELAYS IN CARE TO
PATIENTS RECEIVING PHYSICAL
THERAPY AND OTHER IMPORTANT
SERVICES CAN ACTUALLY UPDATE
FROM STATUTES ORIGINALLY
ADOPTED IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE. IN RECENT YEARS WE'VE
SEEN INCREASING THAT HEALTHCARE
REVIEW DECISIONS THAN TO BE A
COMPUTER ALGORITHM THAT COULD
NOT PROPERLY RECOGNIZE THE
TRAINING AN OPINION AT THE
VISION AND OTHER HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO ASSESS THE
NEEDS FOR THE DURATION OF
CANADA BASED UPON INITIAL
EVALUATION THE PROFESSIONALS.
IN FACT DATA REVIEW FROM THE
ONE POINT TWO MILLION CASES
FROM THE NATION'S LARGEST
PHYSICAL THERAPY MEDICAL
RECORDS PROVIDER WHEN HE- SHOWS
THAT THE STANDARD APPROVAL
THREE POINT EIGHT BUSINESS DAYS
WHEN DONE BE A COMPUTER
PROGRAM. WELL THOSE ARE
STANDARD APPROVAL OVER TEN
BUSINESSMEN. REVIEWS CONDUCTED
BY HEALTH PROFESSIONALS. THIS
BILL ALLOWS THE USE OF. PROGRAM
BUT STILL. THAT THOSE. USE NOT
BE BAY ON TRADE. EVIDENCE BASED
CLINICAL BY. IN ADDITION THE
BILL STIPULATES THAT. CANNOT BE
OUT AND REQUIRES A REVIEW OF
THE HEALTH PROFESSIONAL LICENSE
CALIFORNIA. RETAIN YELLS MEDIC
DOORKEEPER PROVING OR DENYING
CARE. THIS BILL DOES NOT
PROHIBIT EXISTING PRACTICE OF
DEPARTMENT RETROSPECTIVE
REDISTRIBUTED POSSIBLE OF
UTILIZATION I SPECIFIED
PROVIDERS. THIS BILL ALSO
ALLOWS CARE TO BE DELIVERED
WITHOUT UNNECESSARY DELAY. AND
PUBLISH THAT IS THE NATIONAL
SELF OF MEDICINE SHOW THAT
COSTS CAN BE AS MUCH AS 75%
HIGHER. WHEN ACCESS TO PHYSICAL
THERAPY GIVE DELAY. IT AND
APOSS ARE REALLY COMMITTED TO
INCREASE THE USE OF OPIOIDS.
DIAGNOSTIC TESTS AND SURGERIES.
AND RECENT CAP WILL ALLOW OF
ONE OF FOR LITTLE NATIONAL PRO
FOR PHYSICAL PAYER IN. RESULT
IN FIFTH ONE. TO DEPARTMENT
MANAGE HEALTHCARE BEFORE THE
SHARE HAD A PULL BACK VEHICLES.
OF THE PROGRAM. THIS OCCURRED
WITHIN A SHORT PERIOD OF TWO
WEEKS THEN DESPITE THAT THE
PAIR HAS ANNOUNCED PLANS TO RE
IMPLEMENT THIS PROGRAM AGAIN
THIS YEAR. THE PROGRAM IS
FRAUGHT WITH ISSUES IN OTHER
STATES. EPA HAD. THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE TO HELP ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT EXIST WITH PLANNED
USING COMPUTER REVIEWS. BUT
THEY'RE BUILT WITH THESE
RESOLVE THESE ISSUES ARE
LIMITED BASED UPON CURRENT LAW.
THIS BILL BOLSTERS THE
DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY TO OVERSEE
HEALTH PLAN. GETS RID OF THE
LAID BACK THE SEMESTER CARE AND
DOES NOT ADD COST TO THE
SYSTEM. I HEARD YOUR SUPPORT
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT IN THE
PACKAGE ARE CUTTING AFTER.
BRINGING THE SUPPORT BILL FOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES LISTED IN
OPPOSITION- PLEASE GO AHEAD
WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE GET HAMPTON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH PLANS WE'RE GOING TO
BE WE ARE HERE IN OPPOSITION
EIGHTY FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT.
ALTHOUGH WE APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION WE'VE HAD THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE SPONSORS TO
DATE. A PRIMARY ALL RIGHT TO BE
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION FOR THE
CRITICAL FUNCTIONS AND
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AS A LOT OF
PLAN USERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EVALUATE SPECIFIC SERVICES. AND
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE NOT ONLY
MEDICALLY NECESSARY BUT
CONSISTENT WITH THE APPROPRIATE
CLINICAL CARE GUIDELINES. WE
BELIEVE EIGHTY FORTY SIXTY
EIGHT WHAT UNDERMINE THE
PROCESS BY ALLOWING PROVIDERS
CHIROPRACTIC SERVICES PHYSICAL
THERAPY OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY.
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY. M.
F. THEN ON A TRIP OF GREATER TO
PROVIDE THEIR PATIENTS. WITH
THE TWELVE DIGIT IN EACH
DISCIPLINE WITHOUT PROVIDING
ANY OVERSIGHT REVIEW BY THE
PATIENT PLAN A PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIAN. IN ATHENS IF A
PATIENT WHERE YOU LIVE THE
MAXIMUM ALLOWABLE CERTAIN EACH
THAT THE PLAN. UNDER THE BILL-
THIS POLICY CHANGE GRANTED
PATIENT UP TO SEVENTY TWO VISIT
FORTY SERVICE YOU FOR THE
HEALTH PLAN COULD ENSURE THE
MEDICAL THAT THE. O THE
CARRIBEAN PROVIDED. WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED THIS- UP THE FOR THE
FOR WASTE ABUSE NOT HELPED
DELIVERY. AND MAY RESULT IN
RECEIVING ANOTHER. IN ORDER A
CARE. REGRETTABLY EIGHTY FORTY
FIFTY EIGHT WILL LEAD TO HIGHER
COSTS IN HEALTHCARE IT DELIVERY
SYSTEM AT TIME WHEN WE SHOULD
BE FOCUSING ON MAKING
HEALTHCARE MORE AFFORDABLE- WE
BELIEVE THIS BILL ONE
FORTUNATELY A CREEPY MINISTRY
TO COP. YOU CREEK AFFORDABILITY
AND AGAIN ACTUALLY LEAD TO
UNNECESSARY CARE DELIVERY. FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. BUT YOU
WERE MAKING THAT IT IS WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS AS
OF THEM. LISTED LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH FOR HAVE ONE MORE
WITNESS AND OPPOSITION. MISTER
CHAIR NUMBER THIRTY WALKING BY
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
SHARE WITH YOU SOME OF OUR
THOUGHTS AND CONCERNS WITH
RESPECT EIGHTY FOURTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT AND JUST A TIME I'D LIKE
TO ECHO MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS AND HIGHLIGHTS FOR YOU
SOME ADDITIONAL CONCERNS WE
HAVE WITH THE BILL. FIRST I'D
LIKE TO REITERATE THAT PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION SERVES AN
IMPORTANT ROLE WITHIN THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND IS NOT
INTENDED IN ANY LEVEL TO BE
PUNITIVE IN NATURE BUT INSTEAD
ALLOWS HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EVALUATE SPECIFIC SERVICES. AND
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE NOT ONLY
MEDICALLY NECESSARY BUT
CONSISTENT WITH APPROPRIATE
CLINICAL GUIDELINE. THAT BEING
SAID WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
EIGHTY FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
WILL NOT GOING TO LIMIT OUR
ABILITY TO MONITOR THE THIRD
ENUMERATED AND THE THOUGHT OF.
THE COULD INADVERTENTLY DELAY
THE PROPER THING A PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION REQUEST AS IT
APPEARS. AT THAT PLACE THE
SECOND LAYER REVIEW FOR THOSE
PLANS INSURANCE UTILIZED IN
AUTOMATED PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
SYSTEM. SHOULD BE NOTED THAT
CURRENT LAW LIMITS THE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION REVIEW PROCESS
ONLY THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
EITHER MIGHT POSITION OR LIKE
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL. THE
COMPETENCY EVALUATE THE
SPECIFIC CLINICAL ISSUES
INVOLVED IN HEALTHCARE SERVICE
REQUESTED BY THE PROVIDER.
UNDERSTANDING THAT UNCLEAR WHAT
SECTION KATIENA IN THE BILL AND
KEPT A COMPLEX OTHER THAN
CREATING A SECONDARY REVIEW
PROCESS ALL PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
REQUESTS THAT HAVE EITHER BEEN
DENIED OR MODIFIED. BURKE
BRADLEY ADMITS KIND OF
ADDITIONAL LAYER OF COMPLEXITY
THE CURRENT SYSTEM WOULD BE
NOTHING I NECESSARILY DELAYED
THE CURRENT PROCESS AND FURTHER
EXACERBATE THE ISSUE PROVIDERS
CONTINUE TO RAISE WITH RESPECT
TO CARE BEING DELAYED. FOR THE
RENEWAL CARE POSTED EIGHT
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT BUT REMAIN
COMMITTED TO WORK TO BE
AUTHORED MONSTER POTOMAC PARK.
THANK. YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELL NOW TO THE PHONE LINES.
THE TESTIMONY OF- TEST ONCE A-
OR- JUST YOUR NAME. IF YOU-REPRESENT AND YOUR- ON BILL. SO
PLEASE- OPEN THE LINE. MADAM
OPERATE WHENEVER YOU READY.
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE TO OR- OF
AB FORTY. SIXTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. THEN ZERO. ONE THEN
ZERO FOR WORKED FOR OPPOSITION.
AND WEWILL GO TO LINE UP FOR
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FOUR NINE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN DO YOU HAVE A THE NEW. YES
THIS IS THERESA LOCK FROM
DISTRICT FIVE I SUPPORT A. B.
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT I'M A
PHYSICAL THERAPIST THANK YOU
BYE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE GIVE. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE UP OF FOUR THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ONE OF
THE GOAL HORN WITH OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE AT THE
PARK. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE UP A FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT
WITH THE- AND PHYSICAL THERAPY
I'M FROM OUR ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FORTY FIVE NINE SUPPORT AB ONE
FOUR SIX EIGHT. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE THANK YOU. WHAT
LINE UP AT. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
THIS IS STEVE COULD TALUKA
REPRESENTING THE INDEPENDENT
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS OF
CALIFORNIA SIX HUNDRED PRIVATE
BUSINESSMEN PROVIDING- PHYSICAL
THERAPY IN WEREN'T STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL GO TO A
LINE OF FIVE HUNDRED YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE FIVE HUNDRED YOUR
LINE IS OPEN DO YOU HAVE A
SUNNIEST. EXTROVERT LINE OF
FOUR SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MARLA THREE
I AM A PHYSICAL THERAPIST FROM
THE SEVENTH DISTRICT OF
CALIFORNIA AND I AM SUPPORT HE
HAD. EIGHTY FOURTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT LINE OF FOUR SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
DOCTOR CHRIS THREE DR DENTAL
THERAPY CHAIRED THE GOVERNANCE
CARE THE CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL
THERAPY ASSOCIATION'S
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS COMMITTEE-
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER. PLEASE THANK YOU WHAT
CUT LINE UP FOR THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS DAVID JACKSON- OF
PHYSICAL THERAPY STUDENTS FROM
THE TWENTY SEVENTH DISTRICT AND
I HIGHLY SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COUNTIES.
BUT A LOT OF FIVE TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DR KAREN BEING ALLOWED
BACK ON MY LIFE THANK YOU YOURS
AND REGISTERED NURSE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE- AND WINTER PARK
AB. ONE FOUR SIX EIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE UP A FIVE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRANDON
MARCHING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION CURRENTLY
IN THE SUPPORT OF THE
MEDITATIONS WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH US AND LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THE BILL
I DON'T KNOW. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ABOUT THE LINE OF FIVE
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU FOR THREE O'CLOCK
DOCTOR OF PHYSICAL THERAPY I'M
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT I AM AND DISTRICTS OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER PLEASE THANK THANK YOU
AND ACCESSIBLE TO LINE OF FIVE
OR FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KELLY KUBOTA AND I'M A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST FROM THE W. COMPANY
AT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I'M
ALSO THE VICE PRESIDENT AND THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR ARGUED THAT
THE OFFENDER. AND I AM STRONG
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M NOT SURE
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THE
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
BEFORE WE DO OR YOU'RE
ACCEPTING OR AMENDMENTS MISTER
CUNNINGHAM. YES I WOULD ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
THANK YOU FOR THE HARD WORK.
THANK YOU- BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEE ANOTHER BILL DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION HAS A
MOTION BY MISTER MASON I
BELIEVE THE SECOND MY WAS WAS
BY MISS WALDRON- THE- MOTION.
TO PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE WITH YOUR CUNNINGHAM
YEAH I THINK IT JUST BRIEFLY
ADDRESS SOME OF THE- ISSUES
RAISED BY OPPOSITION. I DIDN'T
HEAR MUCH OPPOSITION TO THE
FIRST PART OF THE BILL WHICH
SIMPLY ALIGNS THE ALGORITHMS
WITH EVIDENCE BASED CARE AND I
THINK THAT'S- FAIRLY SELF
EVIDENT AND PROBABLY LEAD TO
COST SAVINGS IN THE LONG RUN-
AS TO THE TWELVE VISITS. I
THINK THE ARGUMENT THAT PEOPLE
ARE GONNA. SORT OF GO SEE SIX
DIFFERENT TYPES OF CARE
PROVIDERS TWELVE TIMES EACH IS
A LITTLE BIT OF A RED HERRING
RESPECTFULLY. I MEAN THIS IS
LIMITED TO CHIROPACTIC
SERVICES PHYSICAL THERAPY
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY SPEECH.
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY ASIAN
MEDICINE AN AUDITORY THERAPIES.
SO IF YOU HAVE AN ISSUE WITH
YOUR HEARING OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT YOU'RE PROBABLY UNLIKELY
TO GO TO A PHYSICAL THERAPIST.
THEY PROBABLY GOT A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST IF YOU HAD A PROBLEM
WITH YOUR NEAR YOUR BACK OR SO
FOR SO I DON'T THINK THESE-
THAT THAT RISK I THINK IT'S
PROBABLY A LITTLE BIT.
OVERBLOWN AND AGAIN. AT THE END
OF THE DAY THE CONTENT OF THIS
IS TO PUT. EVIDENCE IN CHARGE
AND PUT THE- PRACTITIONERS AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE PROVIDING THE
CARE IN CHARGE OF. OF THE
TREATMENT. AND MOVE MOVE AWAY
FROM ALGORITHMS THAT MAY LEAD
TO. SORT OF ARBITRARY DECISIONS
AND CARE- THE TWELVE VISITS BY
THE WAY IS SOMETHING THAT IS
ADOPTED. I DON'T HAVE A LIST OF
STATES TODAY BUT A LOT OF OTHER
STATES HAVE THAT TWELVE IS THE
THING. THAT'S THREE YOU KNOW
THAT'S WEEKLY VISITS FOR THREE
MONTHS BASICALLY- AT THAT POINT
THEY NEED. ADDITIONAL
AUTHORIZATION FROM THAT POINT
ON SO THANK YOU WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AYE
BUT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CUNNINGHAM- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOOD HI WHAT I
MAYES. MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW. BURKE
BURKE HIGH CARILLOCARRILLO AYE
FLORA MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA. RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
WALDRON WALDRON AYE CALDERON
CALDERON AYE. NINE ZERO NINE
ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CUNNINGHAM. THIS IRWIN. YOU
HAVE AB TWELVE EIGHTY WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- AB TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT IS A BILL THAT
WILL ENSURE THAT PATIENTS
ENTERING HOSPICE CARE NOT
SUBJECT TO ILLEGAL RECRUITMENT
SCHEMES THAT THEY RECEIVE
INFORMATION AND LANGUAGE AND
MATTER THE PATIENT OR CAREGIVER
UNDERSTANDS AND SPECIFIES THAT
ONLY AN RN LPN. MEDICAL SOCIAL
WORKER CHAPLAIN OR COUNSELORS
BOARD BY THE HOSPITAL CAN
ENROLL PATIENTS IN HOSPICE
PROGRAMS HOSPICE CARE IS
INTENDED TO MAKE TERMINALLY ILL
PATIENTS AS PHYSICALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY COMFORTABLE AS
POSSIBLE SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
THREE HOSPICE HAS BEEN A
GUARANTEED MEDICARE BENEFITS
AND IS ALSO INCLUDED IN MANY
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
HOSPICE CARE UNDER THE MEDICARE
HOSPICE BENEFIT REQUIRES
DOCUMENTATION FROM TWO
PHYSICIANS ESTIMATING THAT A
PERSON HAS LESS THAN SIX MONTHS
TO LIVE. IF THE DISEASE FOLLOWS
ITS USUAL COURSE ACCORDING TO A
TWENTY EIGHT. TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REPORT BY THE US DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES OF
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
CALIFORNIA LEADS THE NATION IN
THE NUMBER OF POORLY PERFORMING
HOSPICES INCLUDING THE FAILURE
TO ADEQUATELY AS ACCESS AND-
ACCESS ASSESS INCOMING HOSPICE
PATIENTS THE O. I. G. REPORT
FOUND THAT HOT- CALIFORNIA
HOSPICES LEAD THE NATION FOR
ENROLLING PATIENTS WERE NOT
TERMINALLY ILL. AND CLAIMING
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THOSE
PATIENTS PREDATORY RECRUITING
WHEN HOSPICE PROVIDERS OR THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES TARGET AND
ENROLL PATIENTS BY USING
DECEITFUL AND AGGRESSIVE
TACTICS SUCH AS OFFERING CASH
GIFT CARDS OR OTHER ITEMS OF
VALUE IS A ROWING PROBLEM.
MEDICARE AND THE- I. O. I. G.
REPORTS THAT PATIENTS SOMETIMES
DO NOT RECEIVE THE REQUIRED
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT THEY'RE
AND ROLLING AND WHAT THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO AND WHAT THEY
SHOULD EXPECT TO RECEIVE UNDER
THE HOSPICE MEDICARE BENEFITS.
AB TWELVE EIGHTY TAKES
IMPORTANT STEPS TO ENSURE THAT
PATIENTS ENROLLING IN HOSPICE
CARE ARE NOT SUBJECT TO ILLEGAL
INDUCEMENTS THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND WHAT HOSPICE CARE IS
AND THAT THEIR ALEXION OF THE
HOSPICE INFORMED CONSENT AND
COUNSELING ON THE ELECTION. OF
HOSPICE IS COMPLETED BY THE
APPROACH. PROFESSIONAL AB
TWELVE EIGHTY REQUIRES THE
WRITTEN AND VERBAL NOTICE OF
THE PATIENT'S RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES IN A LANGUAGE
AND MANNER THAT THE PATIENT
UNDERSTANDS. WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
PATIENTS AT THE END OF LIFE
RECEIVE THE APPROPRIATE CARE
THAT ADDRESSES. THE PATIENT'S
AND THE FAMILY'S NEEDS AB
TWELVE EIGHTY WILL REDUCE
NEGLIGENCE AND FRAUD THAT
TARGET THE TERMINALLY ILL AND
THEIR FAMILIES. TODAY I HAVE-
PETER CALLISON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL. HOSPICE
HOSPICE AND PALLIATIVE CARE
ASSOCIATION AS PRIMARY
WITNESSES SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR OUR PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. MEMBERS THANK. PLEASE
GO AHEAD MR JERRY MEMBERS.
PETER CALLAHAN WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPICE AND
PALLIATIVE CARE ASSOCIATION
WHICH IS A SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
EIGHTY. FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU YOUR STAFF THE AUTHOR AND
THE AUTHOR STAFF RECEPTION TO
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING THE
ISSUE OF AND SCRIPT AND
TRIBULUS AND DEFICIENT PROBLEM
HOSPICECARE IT HAS BEEN WELL
HIGHLIGHTED NUMEROUS.
PUBLICATIONS IN THE PAST TWO
YEARS. NEED TO SUPPORT AB
TWELVE EIGHTY OTHER GET TO ONE
OF THE CORE ISSUES OF ONE OF
THE ASPECTS OF THE PATIENT'S
CARE WHICH IS FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES THAT ARE BEING-
POTENTIALLY EXPLOITED BY SOME
UNSCRUPULOUS PROVIDERS. THERE'S
THREE PRINCIPAL COMPONENTS OF
THE BILL. THAT MY CLIENT TO
SUPPORT OF UP AND WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THE FIRST IS REFERRAL
SOURCE PAYMENT. WHICH CLOSE THE
LOOP LOU PAUL BY PROHIBITING
THE HOSPICE PROGRAM ITS
EMPLOYEE OR ANY AGENT TO
PROVIDE PAYMENT IN ANY FORM FOR
THE REFERRAL OF PATIENTS TO
THEIR- PROGRAM. SECOND VISIT
PROVIDED. BETWEEN CONSULTATIONS
FOR HOSPICE REFERRAL AND%
COMPENSATION. AND THEN LASTLY
SPECIFIED EXACTLY WHO MAY
ENROLL INDIVIDUALS INTO
HOSPICE. AND ON THIS NOTE I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT- THE
PATIENT FAMILY CHOCOLATES
INTERDISCIPLINARY CLINICAL TEAM
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK AS THE PLAN
OF CARE FOR PATIENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHO ARE ENROLLED THE
PASTA PASTA. ARE BETTER SUITED
TO EXPLAIN HOSPICE INFORMED
CONSENT AND HOSPITALIZATION FOR
PATIENTS AND FAMILIES. WE
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A SENSITIVE
ISSUE AND THE OVERALL WE'RE
PLEASED TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE
AUTHOR AND ANYBODY ELSE WHO IS
INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS. OF THE BILL
PROCEEDS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE PHONE LINES FOR OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR
NAME- ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE AND POSITION ON
THE BILL SO WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MADAM OPERATOR. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB TWELVE EIGHTY MY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE SEVEN
ZERO IF IN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT. MATURE I'D BE NO
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT IF YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
OFFERED TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY S. OR A
MOTION BY MISS BURKE OR MISSED-
YEAH. THIS AGUIAR-CURRY FOR A
SECOND BY MISS BURKE- MOTION IS
DUE PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WHICH LIKE CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CALL THE ROLL WHAT I WHAT
I MAYES MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY HI BIGELOW. BURKE
BURKE HI CARILLO CARILLO AYE
FLORA MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HI NAZARIAN. I REQUEST.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ AYE
SANTIAGO WALDRON WALDRON HI
CALDERON CALDERON HIGH. NINE
ZERO NINE ZERO YOUR BILLS OUT
IF AYE AYES WON SAID I
APOLOGIZE ISSUES SAID THIS
BEFORE THE VOTE BUT UNLIKE YOUR
BILL A LOT AND I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
AND I WOULD LOVE TO BE I'VE HAD
AS A CO AUTHOR IF YOU HAVE.
THANK YOU. SO WE DON'T HAVE ANY
MEMBER. BURKE HAS A BILL WHICH
I DID YOUR BILL NESPER. PLEASE
DO YES YOU CAN DO FROM THERE
GOT TO STAND UP THE- YEAH
THANKS WE CAN ALL SEE THAT WAY.
ALL RIGHT LET ME SEE MONTEREY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VERSUS THE FORTINOS SEVEN
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND IT'S A
MATTER MEASURE DESIGNED TO
EDUCATE OUR HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE. PACK OF IMPLICIT
BIAS IN OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
IN ORDER TO BRING. DISPARITIES
AND NEGATIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES TO
AND- EVIDENCE EXISTSTHAT
SUGGESTS THAT THE FIRST THAT
THE PRESENCE OF IMPLICIT BIAS
IN HEALTHCARE SYSTEM LEADS TO
DIFFERENCES IN THE QUALITY OF
CARE GIVEN TO PATIENTS AND
OVERALL HEALTH OUTCOMES WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS BURKE YOU HAVE WITNESSES.
LOOKING TO SEE. FIVE MILLION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION SHOULD BE ON THE
LINE PERFECT SO- MEMECREATOR IF
THE WITNESSES ON THE LINE
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR THE
WITNESS AND SUPPORT. NO NO
WE'RE WAY OUT OF ORDER SO THAT.
GO AHEAD. I'M HERE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN WOULDN'T MEMBERS I'M
CURSED PLAYING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
PROF WANTED THE BABY PORTANTINO
SEVEN WHEN I THINK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN INTRODUCING THIS
BILL WHICH IT REQUIRES IMPLICIT
BIAS EDUCATION FOR NURSING
STUDENTS AND YOU ARE IN LIKE
THE JEANS NOT SURPRISINGLY
IMPLICIT BIAS EXISTS AMONG
PEOPLE OF ALL PROFESSIONS
HOWEVER WHEN YOU GO TO BUY
PROCESS IN HEALTHCARE SETTINGS
YOU MAY CONTRIBUTE TO HEALTH
CARE DISPARITIES EXPERIENCED BY
MEMBERS OF RACIAL ETHNIC OR
RELIGIOUS MINORITIES AND OTHER
GROUPS. THE PREFERENCE OF
IMPLICIT BIAS IN THE HEALTHCARE
SETTING IS REFLECTIVE OF
INACTION INACCURACIES WITHIN
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM STRUCTURE
TOO OFTEN FAIL TO LOOK AT THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE THOSE
COMMUNITIES AND RESOURCES FOR
CERTAIN TO TAP TO FILL WILL BE
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES
MEDICARE'S MUST DEMONSTRATE
THEIR COMMITMENT TO ENDING
RACIAL HEALTH DISPARITIES AND
WORKING TOWARD HEALTH EQUITY BY
AGGRESSIVELY PURSUING
STRATEGIES THAT WOMEN YOU PUT
THE BY WITHIN THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. AB FORTINO SEVEN
RECOGNIZES THAT AWARENESS AND
EDUCATION IS THE FIRST STEP
TOWARD ELIMINATING BUDGET
BIETEN HEALTHCARE SETTINGS
EDUCATION THE FUTURE HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE BUT THAT THEIR
COMMENTED ABOUT THE IMPACT
IMPLICIT BIAS THE PATIENTS THEY
SERVE IS PARAMOUNT TO BRING
THIS ONE ON AND ON UNTIL IN THE
END ACCORDINGLY RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE EIGHTY
FOURTEEN OH SEVEN ALSO MOBILE
TO ANSWERING TECHNICAL.
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL GO TO THE LINE
AND FOR OTHER WITH IN. OR JUST
YOUR NAY. ORGAN FOR. ONE IN
YOUR POSITION THE BILL SO
YOU'RE MADAM OPERATOR. GIVE ME
A PART OR UP OF AB. FORTINO
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE UP FIVE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY
BROOK ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU ABOUT THE LINE OF
FIVE SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
JENNIFER MERRIMENT THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU SO MUCH A
LINE OF FIVE SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON
HEARING MEMBERS WILLIAM UP TO
BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE BLACK
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE- FOR THE AUTHOR.
FIFTEEN NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE NO I YEAH- YOU KNOW
BRINGING AWARENESS TO IMPLICIT
BIAS IT SOMETHING I DID LAST
YEAR I'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
TO ME SORRY I AM AND IT REQUIRE
IMPLICIT BIAS EDUCATION
PRINTERS IS INTERSTATE JUST
ANOTHER WHITE STATUS STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS BURKE
THE BILL DOES TO ENJOY A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATIONS- THAT
RECOMMENDATION- THE RECORD THE
MOTION CAME FROM MR RODRIGUEZ
AND WAS SECONDED BY MR MAYES-
MOTION TO PASS TWO PROBES AGAIN.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WOOD I WOULD AYE MAYES.
MAYES HI I'M HERE. AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE BIGELOW. BURKE BURKE HI
CORREO CARILLO HI LAURA
MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY. THIS
RECORD. MISTER RECORDED. MR
MCCARTY THANK YOU MCCARTY AYE
NAZARIAN REQUEST RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO WALDRON.
CALDERON CALDERON HI. IT'S
EIGHT ZERO EIGHT ZERO YOUR BILL
IS OUT WITH THE ROPE AND FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON AT THIS POINT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO SPUR GONNA
GO TO MR RODRIGUEZ. WE HAVE
THREE BILLS BEFORE US AND I
WILL WARN YOU THAT- IF WE DON'T
GET ALL THREE OF YOUR GIRLS IF.
ANOTHER PRODUCT COMES IN WITH
UNPAYABLE COSTS WILL GO THREE
OR SIX THIRTY ONE GOLF BALL
ITEM ORDER. THIRTY ONE WILL
FILE ITEM ORDER YES I DID ITEM
NUMBER. TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE PROJECT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
LOVING PERCENT EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY FOUR TODAY THIS FOR
LOOKING BILL BUILT ON EXISTING
AUTHORITY BY ALLOWING INSURANCE
REGULATORS TO SUPPORT DENTAL
AND MEDICAL PROVIDER NETWORKS
DURING FUTURE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES. ENJOYS ALL THE
BILL WOULD HELP ENSURE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE DURING TIMES OF
EMERGENCIES AB FOUR BEFORE
WITHOUT THE RISE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER OR THE DIRECTOR OF
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE REQUIRE. A SERVICE
PLAN OR INSURER TO FINANCIALLY
ASSIST THE PROVIDER DURING AN
EMERGENCY. ON AMENDMENTS TO
FOCUS THE BILL ON UNDERSERVED
AREAS AND PROVIDERS WHO HAVE
BEEN SEVERELY IMPACTED EXCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
CALLING THEM TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS DR- AND SHAUN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION AND DR ERIC
HANSON REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
ALSO JOINING US VIA REMOTE
HEARING ROOM ARE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE SPONSORS
BRIANNA PITTMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DINNER SOCIAL ASIAN
AND EMILY HUGE IS WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
HOW CAN ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
RODRIGUEZ- MADAM OPERATOR
PLEASE MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
AND WE'LL TAKE OUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. CAN YOU HEAR. OKAY
GOOD AFTERNOON FOR NUMBER MY
NAME IS ERIN SIGN WITH THE A
CANDLE DENTAL OF THE- AND I AM
A HE DENTIST IN TAMPA. LIKE
MANY OTHER PROPOSED- AND
INDUSTRY IN THE SECRETARY WITH
HIS HARD BY COVERT NINE. I'M
PRACTICE TOP HEALTH EMERGENCY
LIGHTS HAPPEN NINETY FIRST OF
CALIFORNIA DENTAL OFFICES
CLOSING COMPLETELY OR ONLY
THING I'M PATIENTS AND ONE
UNLESS THEM I'M TO BE IN AND
FOR CONTROL REQUIRED WELCOME
MANDATE AND STACKING SHORTAGES
FURTHER BY THE PAN. CONTINUE
JUST PRACTICE ACCESS AND RETURN
TO CARE AGRIMENSOR CENTER I
WANT TO KNOW LONG OF INCOME
BECAUSE PRACTICES I WORKED FOR
AND THE OWNER DOCTOR BE A CAN'T
OKAY AT THE THREE OPENED MY
PRODUCTIVELY RICH SOME DOWN
EIGHT HOURS A WEEK. AS AN
EMPLOYEE I WOULD NOT ALLOW FOR
YOUR EMAIL AND FIND ONE THAT
ASPECT OKAY. STATE AND
UNEMPLOYMENT WOULD NOT ENOUGH
COVER MY MAIN PAYMENT I'M KERN
WORKING AT FIVE DIFFERENT
OPPOSITE EACH REPORTER TO BRING
ON OVER ACT. YOUR PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCIES INSURANCE
REGULATORS ARE YOU HAPPY IT'S
ALREADY REQUIRE PLAN SURE APPLE
MEDICALLY SERVICES DURING AN
EMERGENCY. BUILT ON THAT
AUTHORITY BY LAW RIGHT TO
PROTECT AND- IN PROVIDER NOT.
IN THE FUTURE DATE OF AMERICAN
ARE HEALTH. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I EFFORTS ARE EITHER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- OUR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN WE GO AHEAD. I'M HERE I'M
SORRY- HELLO THIS IS DR
CAMPAIGN- I AM CALLING ALSO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF AB FOUR FIVE
FOUR I'M AN INDEPENDENT TIME TO
SYNC- FAMILY PRACTICE PHYSICIAN
SAN BENITO COUNTY PROVIDING
AND APPROXIMATELY A YEAR ALL WE
WILL ALSO THE REALITY TO
PROVIDE CARE TO OUR PATIENTS WE
WERE GOING TO HAVE A NEW
VERSION OF- HOW WE DO THAT. AND
DRAMATICALLY IN FALL THE USUAL
OF PETE BUT OF MY DENTIST
COLLEAGUE WAS TALKING ABOUT ON
THE OTHER CALL WE- FOR TRACK
BECAUSE I'M IN AND IN THIS-
POCKET I'M A CHANGE WITH THE
REALITY THE COST OF PETE WOULD
GOING TO BE FOR BY MYSELF AND I
ORDERED SUPPLY. BIT ACTUALLY
NEVER CAME IT HAD A NOT BEEN
THE MEDICAL SO. I WOULD NOT OF
HAD PPP AFTER THE FOR MONTH
INTO THE- AND IT WOULD HAVE
BEEN UNABLE TO PROVIDE
INPATIENT TWO OF MY PATIENTS
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW- BDA. DMH
ACTUALLY PUT SOME- FORCED THE
RECOMMENDATION WERE HEALTH
PLANS COULD ASSIST US IN THE
LAST YEAR HELP PLANT THAT MADE
RECORD PROFITS FOR THE REST OF
US HAVE BEEN- PUT OUT OF
BUSINESS OR BARELY ABLE TO
SURVIVE IN THIS WHAT AT LEAST
ENSURE THAT WE GET SOME SUPPORT
FOR COVERING TESTING SUPPLIES
PTP MATERIAL DURING A TIME OF
EITHER PANDEMIC OR OTHER CRISIS-
AND I THINK THIS IS VERY.
TIMELY WELL THOUGHT OUT AND I
REALLY HOPE THAT WE CAN COUNT
ON YOUR SUPPORT YOU CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SAFE CARE TO THE
PATIENT THE CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO- OUR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION- PLEASE GOING WE
YOU'RE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS CHRISTY
WEEKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
DENTAL PLANS IN OPPOSITION. WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ALL OF THE WORK
IS DONE ON THE BILL INCLUDING
THE VERY TOP AND OF THE MARKET
AMENDMENTS. WE DO THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS IMPROVE AT ALL IN
ORDER. RESPONSE TO THE- FOR.
AND DETRIMENTAL LANGUAGE THAT
WOULD BE IN BILL AS A- DENTAL
IMPLANTS ARE VERY COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTING THE DENTIST THEY
CONTRACT WITH. WHICH IS WHY.
OUR PLANS PROACTIVE. PROVIDE
NEARLY THIRTY SIXTEEN DOLLARS
SUPPORT. TO DENTISTS INTO
TWENTY AFTER THE SHELTER IN
PLACE ORDERS WERE ENACTED. WE
HAVE SEEN FAN THAT. THE
CONSUMER HAVE RETURN. TO THE
DONE. I THEY'RE USING THEIR
BETTER AND THEY ARE RISKY
SERVICES AND CAN TALK HAVE
BURKE. WELL WE APPRECIATE HIM
WE BELIEVE THAT THE- OF THE
BILL. REMAINS AB FOUR FIVE WERE
WOULD PLACE THE PLAN IN THE
POSITION OF INCH. A DENT
PRACTICE. WHICH IS PRIVATE. AND
DOES NOT REFLECT PLAN TO DO ALL.
TO USE THE CREAM ALL THAT ARE
PAID THEM BY EMPLOYER. TO
PROVIDE COVERAGE TO CONTINUE.
THE BILL EVEN AS AMENDED WOULD
FOR DENTAL PLANS TO EMPLOY
PREMIUMS ON. TO SUBSIDIZE PARK.
AND WOULD NOT IN BECAUSE ACCESS
TO FOR. WHILE WE VERY MUCH OF
THE A MAN FOR THE INJURY D. D.
P. OR IN OFFICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH- NECK WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. NICOLINO ON BEHALF TO
OUR ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS-
AND WE ARE OPPOSE TO THE BILL.
WE KNOW THAT WE MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ- GOOD HERE BUT
REGRETTED EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
FOUR IS WRONG. BE PROMOTED AT
THE WRONG TIME. AB FIFTY FOURTH
ST. FOR A UNIQUELY COVER FUND
PROVIDING FINANCE RELIEF- ENTER
FOR ITS THE TRANSFERS FROM ONE
SECTOR THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM TO
ANOTHER SET OF THE U. AND WE
BELIEVE THIS IN A PRO. AND
BASED ON A PRECARIOUS LEGAL
FOUNDATION I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT WE ABSOLUTELY RECOGNIZE
THAT FOR A PERIOD OF TIME LAST
YEAR PATIENT VOLUME WAS DOWN
DUE TO THE GOVERNMENT'S
RECOMMENDATION TO AVOID ELECTED
HERE. THAT IS WHY IT REALLY IN
THE PANDEMIC TO HELP PLAN
STEPPED UP TO ASSIST OUR
PROVIDER PARTNERS IN A MYRIAD
OF WAYS ON INCLUDING
RENEGOTIATING CONTRACTS
EXPEDITING CLAIMS PROCESSING
PAYMENTS PROVIDING GRANTS OR
LOANS TO PROVIDERS ON INTO
EATING CANDY OR FUNDING
PROVIDERS. FOR PP PURCHASE. FOR
THE BILL DOLLAR IN FOR AND
STATE ASSISTANCE TO PROVIDE TO
SEE THEM THROUGH THE PANDEMIC.
WE PUT OF THE EVIDENCE DOESN'T
REDUCE PROPOSED- IS. AT FEELS
RECOGNIZE HIS SUPPORT PROGRAM
IN INCREASE CLAIMS FOR ELECT
AND NON PRESS. DO TO THE PENN
UP DEMAND- OR RELIGION AND NOW.
BY HARVARD. FRIENDS DOWN THAT
CARE IS RETURNING ANY A
CLEANING PREPAY WILL.
INFORMATION THAT WE'VE ABLE TO
GET FROM A MEMBER HEALTH PLAN.
BACK UP OF MIND- ADDITIONALLY
CAL PER OR RECEIVING BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS PER MONTH FROM PLANS.
OF PATIENT. BUSINESS BECAUSE
MANY TO ARE ON A CAP BASIS
WHICH ARE VOLUNTARY CONTRACTS
UNDER WHICH PLAN TO MAKE
PERIODIC PAYMENTS TYPICALLY
MONTHLY ON A PER MEMBER PER
MONTH BASIS TO PROVIDERS THAT
INCLUDE THE COST OF PROVIDING
MEDICAL SERVICES. AND BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. IT OR NOT
RIGHT TO PAY VOLUME SO THE
CONTINUE TO FLOW FOR HEALTH
PLAN TO PROVIDE. HE DURING THAT.
ALL AND THERE WERE ABOUT TWO
FOUR FIFTY FIVE BILLION. PER
YEAR- IN OTHER POINT THREES
QUICKLY HELLO HISTORY EXPANDED
A LITTLE YEAR PLANS ARE
REQUIRED TO PAY TO HAVE PARITY
WITHIN PERSON SERVICES. SO YOU
KNOW SPEAKING TO COURSE OF THE
BILL RELATED A COMPANION ADMIN
OF THE OVERHEAD COSTS OF
PROVIDERS IN SOME CASES SHOULD
HAVE DECLINED IN THAT IS NOT
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION HERE
AS WELL. SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE- MISTER MEMBERS A
CONSUMER HARM HERE'S AT THE
BILL FORCES- PLANS TO DIVERT
CRITICAL PREMIUM DOLLARS PAID
BY CONSUMERS. AWAY FROM PATIENT
CARE TO PROVIDERS FOR NON
MEDICAL SERVICES. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT ANY RESPONSIBLE-
PROPOSAL AT THIS TIME WE DO
RECOGNIZE THE AMENDMENT AS YOU
KNOW AS AS THE PREVIOUS-
WITNESS STATED. THAT WERE
ANALYZING THOSE WE THINK THEY
COME FROM A GOOD PLACE BUT THEY
DON'T RESOLVE THE FUNDAMENTAL
FLAWS. IN THIS BILL- WE DO
REMAIN COMMITTED TO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OUR PROVIDER
PARTNERS TO DRESS STABILITY
ISSUES BUT THERE'S NO ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH. TO THIS
PROBLEM SO WE URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO. ON. EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ONE MOVE TO THE FOR LINES FOR.
OTHER SINCE. OR ON. JUST YOUR
NAME- ORGANISER IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE IN POSITION ON
THE BILL. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
MADAM OPERATOR. THANK YOU OR OR
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY FOUR FIFTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE NOW AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF FIVE TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FIVE TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT TO A
PHOTO LINE OF FIVE SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHAU THANK
YOU RECORD YOUR MEMBERS RIGHT
DOUGHERTY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU NETWORK ALIGN OF FIVE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MEMBERS CAPITAL BURGER WE HAVE
TO BOOK A LOCAL TO CALIFORNIA
AND DELTA DENTAL BOTH IN
OPPOSITION. EIGHTY FOUR FIVE
FOUR. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE UP FOUR NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. KATIE WRITTEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN
SPECIALTY CARE COALITION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MEXICO TO
LINE OF FIVE EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU TURN
NUMBERS ALLOWED LOCAL LEADERS
ON THE APPLE BLOSSOM PEOPLE
THAT ARE COMING UP IN EARLY AND
ON PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN SOME
THANK YOU THANK THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU AND THAT TOOK
A LINE UP FIVE SEVEN SEVEN YEAR
LINE OPEN. PRESS TWO YOUNG THE
CALIFORNIA TEAM OF COMMERCE
HERE TO OF THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU GO TO
LINE OF FIVE SEVEN EIGHT YOUR
LINE OPEN. SECURE MEMBERS JOHN
YOU'RE ON THE OF HEALTH PLAN
EIGHT OF- ALSO. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. THANK AND WELCOME TO
LINE UP BY EIGHT. YOUR LINE
ABOUT. MISTER CHANG NUMBER
WALKING ON BEHALF OF THE OF
CALIFORNIANS AND HEALTH
INSURANCE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO LINE OF FIVE
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ARAMBULA
BAKER I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF THE
PSYCHIATRIC POSITIONS ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ABOUT THE LINE OF FIVE
EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DONNIE
CANNELLA ON BEHALF OF UNION
THEY WHAT THE MAGIC WITHIN YOU
CAN. DO FOR AB FOUR FIFTY THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. AND
NEXT TO LINE UP FOR SEVENTY
NINE MIND OPEN. SPEAKING OF
CHAIRMAN MEGAN BURKE BEHALF OF
HEALTH CLUB AFRICAN IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU IMAGE CHAIR WE HAVE
NOT THE FOR A IN CUBA THIS TIME
THANK YOU WILL BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUEST OR FROM THE CAN
MISS FOR QUESTION COMMENT.
MACINNES I HAVE. WHAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TRADE AND I
SYMPATHIZE IN AND- WITH THIS.
I'M TRY TO FIGURE THOUGH. WHAT
IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN AND
LET'S LIKE A BUSINESS OWNERS
POLICY OR BUSINESS INTERRUPTION
COVERAGE. I MEAN THOSE ARE
POLICIES THAT EGGS TO. WHY NOT
MAYBE MAKE IT A- TO THOSE THOSE
ARE POLICIES THAT BUSINESS
OWNERS ALREADY SHOULD BE PAYING.
FOR YOU'RE NOT JUST THINK WHAT
THE PANDEMIC A LOT OF THESE
POLICIES DIDN'T HAVE THAT.
CLARIFICATION REGARDING
PANDEMICS WHAT THAT WOULD DO SO
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS JUST ONE WAY
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE- I
DON'T KNOW FIVE ANYBODY ON THE
LINE WHO'D LIKE TO ELABORATE
MORE ON THAT.
IF THEY WOULD
LIKE. AND MANY OF THE BUSINESS
INTERRUPTION INSURANCE POLICIES
HAVE A VIRUS EXEMPTION SO MOST
BUSINESSES WERE NOT ABLE TO USE
THOSE TO ADDRESS- THE
REPERCUSSIONS OF THE PUBLIC
CRISIS. WE DID INCLUDE
AMENDMENTS SPUR FOR COMMITTEE
THAT LOOKED AT THIS AND SAID
OKAY- THE ANY ASSISTANCE THAT
WOULD BE PROVIDED TO YOU ARE
GIVEN TO A PROVIDER. WOULD NEED
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT ANY STATE
OR FEDERAL ASSISTANCE OR
INSURANCE THAT WAS AVAILABLE.
WE ARE TRYING TO HAVE PROVIDERS
DOUBLE DIP WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE NEXT CALL WAS GOING TO BE I
DON'T THAT PLAGUE OF LOCUSTS
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THIS IS
REALLY JUST ABOUT PROVIDING THE
REGULATORS AND ONE MORE TOOL IN
THE TOOL BELT- AND WE DON'T
MEAN FOR THAT TO START OVERLAP
WITH ANY ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE
FROM. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
OR- BUSINESS INTERRUPTION
INSURANCE SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
IN WHATEVER THE NEXT COVERT
SITUATION IS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SO MY QUESTION IS I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE ARE GONNA
TAKE THE PATIENTS POLICY AND
THAT WILL GO. THAT POLICY THAT
THE PATIENTS OR THE EMPLOYER
PAYS. WILL THEN TURN INTO AND
INSURANCE THAT'S ALREADY IN
EXISTENCE ESSENTIALLY THAT ONLY
JUST NEED THE CAVIAR THAT SAID
THAT WE ALSO INCLUDE. ANY SORT
OF COVERT PANDEMIC I'M. JUST
NOT SURE WHY IT PATIENTS.
PREMIUM WOULD GO TO THE
BUSINESS AND THAT WAY INSTEAD
OF AN INSURANCE BUT LIKE A
TRADITIONAL INSURANCE POLICY
THAT. ALREADY BASICALLY
STRUCTURED TO PROVIDE HELP OF
BUSINESS DURING SOME SORT OF.
CRISIS THAT THEY'RE ALREADY
PAYING FOR WHY NOT JUST ADD THE
EXEMPTION LIKE BUT LIKE SEE
LIKE PRIYANKA SAID. WHY NOT ADD
THE EXEMPTION OF KOBE TO THOSE
POLICIES INSTEAD OF CREATING
THIS WHOLE NEW MECHANISM. AND
YOU DON'T HAVE TO ANSWER I'M
SURE SHE CAN ANSWER. THE MORE
OF A STATEMENT THAN A QUESTION.
A QUESTION A QUESTION I
ACTUALLY WANT TO KNOW WHY
ADJUST THE PREMIUM WHY CHANGE
THE FLOW OF THE PREMIUMS WHY
NOT JUST REQUEST THAT BUSINESS
INTERRUPTION INSURANCE. COVER
PANDEMICS. SINCE THE BUSINESS
ALREADY PROBABLY PAYS FOR THAT.
COMMENT FROM THE QUESTION THE
ANSWER TO QUESTION- I THINK
THERE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSIONS
AROUND WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR BUSINESS
INTERRUPTION INSURANCE TO COVER
PANDEMICS I THINK- MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THOSE ISSUES
IS THAT GENERALLY IT'S SO
CATASTROPHIC THAT IT IS IT'S
THEYHAVE TO HAVE THOSE KIND OF
WAIVERS IN THERE BECAUSE THE-
THE INSURANCE CAN'T REALLY
AFFORD TO COVER THAT- AS FAR AS
WHY WE DID IT THIS WAY. THE
PLANS DO HAVE A REQUIREMENT TO
HELP MAINTAIN NETWORK ADEQUACY
AND SIMILAR TO THE STORY THAT
THE REGULATORS HAVE CURRENTLY
THAT WAS PASSED IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO END IT WHEN THEY'RE
STATE OF EMERGENCY I THINK IT
WAS PASSED IN RESPONSE TO MANY
OF THE FIRES TO STEP IN AND
ENSURE THAT THE PLANS ARE
PROVIDING AND MAKING ACCESSIBLE
MEDICALLY NECESSARY SERVICES.
WE SAW THIS AS ONE ADDITIONAL
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX OF SHORE UP
THE PROVIDER NETWORKS IN THE
INSTANCE OF A CATASTROPHIC
SITUATION A PANDEMIC LIKE KOBE
NINETEEN HONESTLY WE HOPE THIS
WILL NOT EVER BE USED- BUT
SHOULD DO SOMETHING LIKE THAT
HAPPEN AGAIN IT'S JUST ONE
EXTRA LITTLE AUTHORITY. WHEN WE
WENT TO THE REGULATORS LAST
YEAR AS WE WERE IN THE THICK OF
COVED AND SAID HEY IS THERE
ANYTHING THAT YOU CAN DO WHAT
WE'RE SEEING FROM THE PLANS IS
NOT REALLY SUFFICIENT FIRMS TO
HELP OUR PROVIDERS I KNOW THAT-
THE OPPOSITION TALKED ABOUT ON
THE SOME OF THE ASSISTANCE THAT
WAS PROVIDED. WHEN WE TALK TO
THE REGULATORS THEY BASICALLY
SAID WE DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY
AUTHORITY SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS JUST
PROVIDE THEM ONE ACTUAL LITTLE
BIT OF A STORY WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE. AND AGAIN HOPE
THAT IT WOULDN'T BE NEEDED. SO
I UNDERSTAND THAT. FOR I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK AND I
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
COVERAGE I JUST. I THINK IT'S-
AN OF I THINK IT'S BETTER
PLACED IN AN INCH. TRADITIONAL
INSURANCE POLICY BUT THANK YOU
THINK. THANK YOU MISS BURKE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEN THAT- THE BILL DOES DO YOU
HAVE A DOPASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- IT HAS A MOTION
I'M SORRY. OH I'M SORRY. THAT'S
IT ABSOLUTELY OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FAMILY HIS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALSO SPONSOR OF THE BILL ALSO
HERE FOR ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
AGENCIES MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
AND I'M SORRY MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU I DO THANK YOU
YES THANK YOU- MAYBE JUST A
COMMENT- I'M SUPPORTIVE I. AM
SUPPORTIVE OF THE IDEA OF THIS-
I'M NOT QUITE SURE YET ABOUT
THE VEHICLE THAT IS APPRECIATE-
THE OPTIMIST RODRIGUEZ BRING
THIS I KNOW HE'S WORKED HARD IN
THIS. THIS AND SIMILAR AREAS-
BUT I AM STILL A LITTLE.
UNCLEAR AS TO THIS BEAN- SORT
OF THE MOST EFFICIENT VEHICLE
TO BRING THIS SORT OF INSURANCE
OR THIS SORT OF REMEDY FOR
ITSELF- I JUST WANT TO RAISE
THAT IS THIS MOVES ON- I THINK
THAT IF IT DOES MOVE ON- AND I
WON'T BE. VOTING ON IT THAT
TODAY BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE HOW
IT COMES OUT BEFORE IT GETS
SUPPORT BUT I DID WANT TO RIP
REYES THAT. AS SOMETHING THAT I
WAS STRUGGLING. WITH A LITTLE
BIT AS I REVIEWED THIS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APOLOGIZE UP
THERE- WE DON'T ET MANY
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY SO YOU
KNOW T'S LIKE AFTER RETRAIN
MYSELF SO. THANK YOU- SO WITH
THAT. ANYONE ELSE THAT I MISS
ANYBODY ELSE. THANK GOODNESS I
DIDN'T MISS ANYBODY ELSE OFF.
THAT WOULD BRING IT BACK TO THE
AUTHOR- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
MISTER RODRIGUEZ. YES I WOULD
JUST WANNA MAKE MENTION I WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON THE BILL AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN. GET A BTTER
PLACE BUT OBVIOUSLY THE ISSUE
WITH THE PANDEMIC IN THE BARS
WOULD HAVE DONE TO NOT ONLY
THESE TYPES OF BUSINESSES BUT
BUSINESS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IS SOMETHING NEW FOR ALL OF US
SO. HOPEFULLY THIS LIKE THAT
THE SPONSOR WILL NEVER HAVE TO
REVISIT THIS TYPE OF ISSUE BUT
IF THERE IS WE HAVE SOME
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO HELP OUR
STRUGGLING BUSINESSES IN THIS
CASE WITH THE DENTAL DENTAL.
FOLKS WITHOUT RESPECT ASK FOR
OUR VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER RODRIGUEZ YOU AND YOU
HAVE YOU DID SIXTY DID ACCEPT
OUR AMENDMENTS. AND THANK YOU
SO THE MOTION THERE IS A MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS TO HAVE A SECOND.
SECOND BY MISTER NAZARIAN.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WOOD I WOULD AYE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BURKE. CARILLO. FLORA
FLORA I AM MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN ARE VOTING MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN HIGH RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ SORRY. RODRIGUEZ FIVE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON.
CALDERON WALDRON HI. A
SEVENTIES ONE MORE SAID SO YOU
HAVE SEVEN VOTES MISS RODRIGUEZ
ONE MORE WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WILL NOW MOVE TO
PACKED IN FILE ORDER TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY
MISTER SANTIAGO WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ONE THE PRODUCT BEARD- THE
AUTHOR OF AB FIVE SEVENTY WHICH
WOULD BE THE PARENT HEALTH CARE
ACT IN PARTNERSHIP WITH COULD
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER LARA
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW ADULT
CHILDREN OTHER DEPENDENT
PARENTS OR STEP PARENTS. TO
THEIR HEALTHCARE PLAN. AND THIS
IS A GAME CHANGER BECAUSE BY
ALLOWING ADULT CHILDREN AND
THEIR PARENTS A HEALTHCARE PLAN
WILL HELP SAVE FAMILIES MONEY
BY ALLOWING THEM TO COMBINE.
THEIR MAXIMUM OUT OF POCKET
LIMIT FOR WHOLE FAMILIES. IT'S
ALSO A GREAT OPTION FOR MIXED
STATUS FAMILIES UNDOCUMENTED
ADULT DOT CITIZEN DOCUMENT
BUILT FOR AN ELIGIBLE FOR
COVERAGE UNDER. THE COVER
CALIFORNIA THAT'S WHAT RICK
CITED TO PRESENT THIS BILL
BEFORE YOU. AND RESPECTFULLY
WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND
I'M TO BE WILL BE BRIEFED TO
HAND OVER THE RESEARCH
COMMISSION. THANKS MR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE LINE. ENSURE CAN WITH
LARA. BLIGHTED OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEDIATOR CHAU CONNECTED
ONE MOMENT. ARE YOU REFERRING
TO ME- WE ARE OUT OF MISTER
LARA YEAH MISTER MISTER
INSURANCE TOGETHER I'M- BUT
THAT'S WHAT I'M GETTING THE
BODY COVERAGE HELLO MISTER
MEMBERS- INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
RICARDO LARA HERE A PROBLEM SIR
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY AND
FIRST WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLAGE
SANTIAGO FOR OFFERING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE- AS WE WORK
TO EXPAND HEALTH CARE. FOR ALL
AND CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
EQUALITY AND EQUAL ACTION- WE
STILL TO THE AND TEAR TO MOVE
FORWARD AS WE CONTINUE TO GET
MORE CALLS- INSURED ONE OF MY
TOP PRIORITIES- ACTION
COMMISSIONER AND FROM MY TIME
THE STATE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
TO INCREASE ACCESS TO HEALTH
INSURANCE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
A MAJOR OBSTACLE TO INCREASING
HEALTH DOCTORS HOWEVER IF YOU
TREATING COSTS OF HEALTHCARE
WHICH ARE HURTING FAMILIES
ACTUALLY DURING THAT ACADEMIC
WHEN SO MANY PEOPLE HAVE LOST
THEIR JOBS AND ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE IT'S EVEN MORE CRUCIAL. SB
FIVE SEVENTY IS NEEDED HERE
AND- NOW TO ALLOW ADULT
CHILDREN TO HAVE THEIR
DEPENDENT PARENTS TO THEIR
HOUSE INSURANCE POLICIES AND
REALLY HOW ARE ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE
ESPECIALLY FOR LOWER INCOME
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THAT STILL LACK
MEANINGFUL COVERAGE. THE
MEASURE PROVIDES FAMILIES WITH
ANOTHER OPTION FOR HEALTH
COVERAGE ONE THAT WILL BE
INDIVIDUALIZED PERSONAL
DECISION WE'LL GET
INDEPENDENT FOR THEM AND THEIR
FAMILY CONSIDERS THE HELP
OPTION THAT IS BEST SUITED. AND
CONVENIENT FOR THEM IN ADDITION
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY OPENS UP ON
THE PATHWAY TO COVERAGE FOR
FAMILIES WITH DEPENDENT PARENTS
WERE UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS
ALTHOUGH SOMETIMES MAY BE ABLE
TO OBTAIN AN INDIVIDUAL POLICY
TO COVER CALIFORNIA DIFFERENT
OPTION IS NOT AVAILABLE TO
EVERYONE ESPECIALLY
UNDOCUMENTED DEPEND OF PARENTS
WHO COULD NOT PURCHASE COVERAGE
THROUGH COVERED CALIFORNIA. DUE
TO EXISTING PROHIBITIONS UNDER
FEDERAL LAW OTHERS THAT WILL
BENEFIT FROM EIGHTY FIVE
SEVENTY WOULD INCLUDE WORKING
FAMILIES WITH DISABLED- LOOK AT
A SINGLE PARENT AT HOME WHO
DOESN'T BELONG. FOR OTHER
SPEAKING OPPOSED SIX OF
SECURITY BETTER OUT OR MEDICARE-
LOST THEIR JOB. AND OUR FINANCE
TO ON THEIR A CHILDREN- WHEN WE
YOU KNOW ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE
NEED TO CARE I CHILDREN OR
PARENTS WERE ALL THERE FOR US-
OUR PARENTS AGE A LOT OF US IN
HAVE BECAUSE THE KEY. AND IT'S
A GOTTEN EVEN TO THE PAIN. AND
THE RESULTING I CAN CRISIS
ANOTHER OUR PARENTS- YOU CAN WE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO CHARACTER
THEM AS OUR PARENTS TO ABOUT WE
WERE TO. ALTHOUGH IT TOOK TWO
DAYS FAR YOU ARE BE THERE AFTER
PART OF THAT CARE SHOULD BE
OPTION TO ADD WASH HOW COVER.
AB TWO PARTS THE BE ON THE THAT
WE CAN TAKE CARE OF I RESPECT
AFTER I THE YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MR COMMISSIONER-
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO- WE DO
HAVE A WE DO HAVE A- REGISTERED
MEMBER IN A REGISTER WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- PLEASE GO AHEAD
WHEN YOU'RE READY. EIGHT OUT OF
THE CAR. JUST MAKING SURE YOU
HEAR ME YES I CAN HEAR YOU.
OKAY THE NEW A DEPRESSING YOUNG
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS WERE HERE
TODAY AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
OF AB FIVE SEVENTY WHAT THE
BILL CERTAINLY WELL INTENTIONED
IT CARRIES CONCERNING
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
PRIMARILY FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT ARE JUST BEGINNING TO
RECOVER FROM A TREMENDOUSLY
DIFFICULT YEAR THE OVERARCHING
CONCERN THAT WE HAVE AB FIVE
SEVENTY IS THE HUGE HEALTHCARE
COSTS INCREASE THE STRUGGLING
AND RECOVERING EMPLOYERS WILL
EXPERIENCE AND THE BILL.
JEFFERSON OUT THE TWO DIFFERENT
COSTS IN AREAS CONTAIN WITH
THAT AT FIRST IN A LOW
ENROLLMENT SCENARIO UNDER
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTEEN EMPLOYER
PREMIUMS WOULD INCREASE OVER
TWO HUNDRED SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN A HI<c.cyan> ROMAN</c>
SCENARIO UNDER AB FIVE SEVENTY
PREMIUMS WOULD INCREASE NEARLY
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS AS YOU WELL
KNOW SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
STRUGGLE TREMENDOUSLY OVER THE
LAST YEAR AND A HUGE COMPONENT
OF THAT STRUGGLE HAS BEEN
PAYING FOR HEALTHCARE SO MUCH
SO THE FEDERAL PPP LANDS IN
STATE SMALL BUSINESS GRANTS FOR
EXTENDED TO EMPLOYERS TO HELP
PAY THOSE COSTS. IN TO PUT
THESE COSTS INTO PERSPECTIVE
THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY KAISER
FAMILY FOUNDATION EMPLOYER
HEALTH BENEFITS SURVEY
INDICATED THAT HER JOB BASED
COVERAGE OF THE AVERAGE ANNUAL
PREMIUM FOR FAMILY COVERAGE
ROSE 4% TO TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED FORTY TWO DOLLARS
EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY WILL
EXACERBATE THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY ISSUE IN SPRING
STRUGGLING SMALL EMPLOYERS BUT
AT THE TIME OF THE FINALLY
BEGINNING TO RECOVER.
ADDITIONALLY SMALL CLERK WILL
BE FORCED TO REASSESS HOW MUCH
THEY CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
EMPLOYEES AND THE PREMIUMS AND
THE SORT OF PAYMENT ARRANGEMENT
WILL BE DISCOURAGED IN THE BILL
HOWEVER IN THANKFULLY OF COURSE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE OFTEN DO
THIS BY AND LARGE FOR MAJORITY
OF THE INDIVIDUALS EIGHTY FIVE
SEVENTY IS FOCUSED. ON COVERING-
THEY CAN OBTAIN COVER INVEST.
CASE UNDER MET. THANK YOU UNDER
BUT- AND IN SOME STATES. THAT
ARE COVERED. ADDITIONALLY THIS
POINT EIGHTY FOUR IF HAPPEN TO
LAW WOULD ALSO ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS. TO TAKE COVERAGE
THROUGH MEDI CAL REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS IN OTHER
WORDS THEIR COVERAGE OPTIONS
REGARDLESS OF AB FIVE SEVEN.
DON'T CLOSING EIGHTY FIVE SEVEN
IS WELL INTENTIONED OF COURSE I
MENTIONED THAT EARLIER JUST
WANT TO REITERATE THAT. THIS
WILL BE A FINANCIAL BURDEN FOR
STRUGGLING SMALL EMPLOYERS THAT
ARE JUST BEGINNING TO RECOVER
NOW WILL KEEP THE SCOPE OF THE
PORTABLE CARE ACT IN THE
LARGELY UNNECESSARY. COVER
COPIES ALREADY BEST. TO PLEASE
REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED. EIGHTY
FIVE SEVEN EIGHT AND I'D LIKE
TO THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR. A WITNESSES IN
EITHER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION-
JUST YOUR NAME YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL. AND OR ANY
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU MIGHT
REPRESENT. THANK YOU IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE SEVENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN.
ZERO AND WE WILL GO TO FIVE OH
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DIANA
DOUGLAS WITH HEALTH ACCESS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IN OCTOBER
TWO FIVE FIVE ALL ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JANICE GLORY AT WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND I WILL GO TO LINE
OF SIX HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE KEVIN TO DRAW
THE REPRESENTING NFIB- LIKE TO
ALIGN OUR POSITION WITH THAT OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER- WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL BECAUSE OF
COST THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL
GO TO A LINE OF A SIX OH FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON RONALD KOEMAN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
NEXT SOKOTO LINE FIVE EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SURE AND
MEMBERS JOHNNY CANNELLA OUT ON
THE TOP OF THE QUOTATION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS CHIRLA
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FIVE
SEVENTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THERE WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY MR NAME AND POSITION
NOR ORGANIZATION PLEASE. MY
NAME IS ANDREA HAD STRUM. AND I
DON'T HAVE AN ORGANIZATION AND
IT SEEMS ODD TO ME THAT THAT IS
PART OF THE EXPECTATION HERE
MA'AM YOUR ABOUT YOUR OUT OF
ORDER JUST YOUR NAME AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE.
WELL I'M A MOTHER OF FOUR DOES
THAT SOUND HAS AN ORGANIZATION
YOU ARE OUT OF ORDER. I'M
OPPOSE YOUR BUILDER SERGEANTS
WOULD YOU- RISO I GET REMOVED
BECAUSE I ASK A QUESTION YOU
ARE OUT OF ORDER YOU ARE NOT A
REGISTERED WITNESS AND I WOULD
ASK FOR NAME AND POSITION AN
ORGANIZATION AND YOU'VE CHOSEN
NOT TO DO THAT SO I'M GIVE I
JUST ASK A QUESTION I DON'T
HAVE AN ORGANIZATION YOU HAVE A
POSITION SO I'M AGAINST THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SCENE AND I JUST IT JUST I DO
HAVE A COMMENT. NUMBER TWO I
WANT TO SAY THAT- I HAVE ALWAYS
SUPPORTED. HEALTH COVERAGE FOR
ALL- I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
IMPERATIVE THAT WE GET. PEOPLE
EVERYONE COVERED I THINK THE
SYSTEM IS HEALTHIER FOR ALL IF
WE DO THAT- THIS COULD
POTENTIALLY INCREASE COVERAGE
BY 200-008-0000 PEOPLE WERE NOT
REALLY COMPLETELY SURE- BUT- I
AM A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL COSTS WHICH COULD BE
BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND ALMOST
NINE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS-
DEPENDING ON DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS SO- I AM A LITTLE
TORN. THE BILL DOES HAVE A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION I THINK THE
BILL IS LIKELY TO INCREASE
HEALTHCARE ACCESS AND MAY
OFFER. AFFORDABLE COVERAGE
OPTIONS. BUT I'M I'M I FEEL
LIKE THERE MAY BE SOME MORE
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE HERE
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE COST
INCREASE MEAN TO EMPLOYERS. AND
ULTIMATELY EMPLOYEES IN TERMS
OF PREMIUMS AND OUT OF POCKET
COSTS SO- LIKE I SAID THE BILL
DOES HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- MR SANTIAGO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH
THANK YOU MISTER FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BILL AND-
GUIDED POINTED OUT. SOME OF
YOUR CONCERNS BUT- TO PROCLAIM
OCCASION NOTHING IN THE BILL
REQUIRES AN INCREASED COST. ON
ANY EMPLOYERS- IN IN WE SQUEEZE
WE START THAT SPECIFICALLY. BUT
I NONETHELESS APPRECIATE- THE
SEARCH FOR DECREASE COST- TO
THE EMPLOYEES- ON EXPANDING-
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE UNTIL THE
DEPENDENT. FAMILY MEMBERS- AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT TO
ENSURE THAT- THAT THE GOALS OF
THE BILLS ARE ADDRESSED IN THE
MOST EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
WAY. I THINK IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WITH. THAT
WE DO. DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOTIONS MISTER CALDERON SECOND.
I'M SORRY I'M SORRY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY SO THE MOTIONIS
DUE PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS- AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOW BURKE.
CARILLO. FLOOR MAIENSCHEIN.
MCCARTY THERE'S A- NAZARIAN AYE
RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON
WALDRON NO CALDERON. CALDERON
HI. SIX TO TWO IT'S TWO MORE
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS SIX
VOTES- YOU SEE MANY MEMBERS ARE
MISSING- WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOVING
ON TO MISTERS- MISTER GABRIEL
YOU HAVE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
SIXTY ONE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
SIR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS- PLEASE RESIGN AB SIXTY
ONE TODAY DESPITE RECENT
PROGRESS WITH VACCINES IT'S
BECOME CLEAR THAT OUTDOOR
DINING WILL BE A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF MANY RESTAURANTS
SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM PLANS
FOR KEEPING THEIR DOORS OPEN.
THIS BILL OFFERS A LIFELINE TO
STRUGGLING NEIGHBORHOOD
RESTAURANTS IN THE FORM OF
TEMPORARY REGULATORY
FLEXIBILITY. TO HELP FACILITATE
OUTDOOR DINING AS WELL AS MORE
ROBUST TAKE OUT AND DELIVERY
OPTIONS. IT'S A TEMPORARY
FLEXIBLE SOLUTION THAT IS A
VITAL TO PRESERVING THE
NEIGHBORHOOD RESTAURANTS THAT
CONTRIBUTE SO MUCH TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND THE PEOPLE WE
SERVE. WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFYING TO PART TIME MATT
SUTTON THE SENIOR VP OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AT THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. AND MADELINE UP
OFF ON- THE OWNER MARIA'S
ITALIAN KITCHEN WHICH IS ONE OF
MY ABSOLUTE FAVORITE
RESTAURANTS IN THE WEST SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY. THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
ABOUT THIS. SO WE HAVE MOTION
BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY SECOND BY
MR RODRIGUEZ- WILL MOVE ON TO
OUR WITNESSES- PLEASE GO AHEAD
WHEN WE DO HAVE ONE IN THE
GALLERY- BUT WILL GO HEAD TO
THE PHONE FIRST SO. OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. PLEASE OKAY I'D NEVER
KNOW. THOSE POINTS FIRST OF
THOSE MONEY AFTERMATH OF HIGH
THERE HI TOM. GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT CAN YOU HEAR ME YES MA'AM.
GREAT I'M SO SORRY- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
HI NATALIE NOT FINAL PRESIDENT
OF MARIE JOHN KITCHEN WITH
EIGHT LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA I'M
ALSO THE PROUD CHAIRWOMAN OF
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION'S BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JESSE GABRIEL WAS HELPING A
STARK COPS OPEN TO
OPPORTUNITIES BY HELPING
RESTAURANTS REMAIN NIMBLE NOT
RESPONSE TO THE ON GOING
BECAUSE THE CONNECTION
RESTRICTIONS I DON'T THINK DOOR
BUSINESS OPERATIONS. AND I WANT
TO THANK HIM FOR THAT. BUT I
ALSO WANT THANK YOU FOR BEING A
LOYAL CUSTOMER- OVER THE LAST
YEAR RESTAURANTS HAVE BEEN
SUBJECT TO WEEKLY CHANGES BY
STATE AND LOCAL DIRECTIVES WITH
REGARDS. TO HOW WE COULD
OPERATE A RESTAURANT. IT IN
FACT. TAKE OUT DELIVERY. IT WAS
CHALLENGING FOR OWNERS
EMPLOYEES AND CUSTOMERS. WHEN
YOU'RE DINING WITH ORDER TO
SHUT DOWN COMPLETELY AGAIN JUST
BEFORE THANKSGIVING. CONTINUE
TO BE CLOSED FOR MONTHS AND
MONTHS. RESTAURANT DISEASE
HOLIDAY SEASON IN FACT L. A.
COUNTY WAS SHUT DOWN FOR ALMOST
NINE MONTHS. EVEN TODAY THEY
CONTINUE TO BE RESTRICTED IN
ALL COUNTIES TO UNSUSTAINABLE
INDOOR CAPACITY LIMIT ACCESS
THAT IS 50% OF THE INDOOR
CAPACITY AND WITH THE PHYSICAL
DISTANCE FOR CABLE PLACEMENT
FOR ME AND SMALL RESTAURANTS
LIKE MINE. REALLY ONLY ALLOWS
425% USE OF THIS SITE THE
CONTINUATION OF THE STATE. THIS
IS WHY OUT DINING HAS BEEN A
LIFELINE FOR US TO SHARE OUR
GUESTS. COMMUNITIES TO CONTINUE
EMPLOYERS TO EMPLOY OUR AMAZING
TEAM MEMBERS. I KNOW THIS TO BE
TRUE FOR SO MANY SMALL
RESTAURANTS WERE OWNED BY
MINORITIES AND WOMEN.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN FACT
60% OF CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
OWNED BY PEOPLE OF COLOR. WE
ARE RESILIENT AND WE ARE
DETERMINED AND OUTDOOR. DINING
HAS KEPT OUR SPIRIT ALIVE.
OFFERS DINING I LIKE TO CALL IT
HAS. DEPRESSED NEIGHBORHOODS
INTO VIBRANT OUTDOOR EATERIES
LIKE THE CAFES WE SHOULD ALL
OVER EUROPE WE HAVE INVESTMENT
INTO OUTDOOR FESTIVAL LIGHTING
OUTDOOR HEATERS POTTED TREES
PLANTS AND FLOWERS TO CREATE AN
INVITING AMBIENCE. THE
CREATIVITY NIMBLENESS OF OUR
INDUSTRY MAKES ME S PROUD TO
BE A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION. YOUR
CONSTITUENTS OUR CUSTOMERS ARE
YEARNING FOR THEIR HAPPY PLACE
AND FOR MOST OF US HE BREAKING
BREAD WITH FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
AB SIXTY ONE WILL BE CRITICAL
AS THE RESTAURANT RECOVERING
CALIFORNIA WILL TAKE SEVERAL
YEARS. THAT IS IF WE CAN
CONTINUE TO MAKE GOOD POLICY IS
A REALITY AND YOU KNOW FURTHER
HARM TO THE STATE'S RESTAURANT
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU AGAIN AND
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AND THOUSANDS
OF RESTAURANT OWNERS AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES SPREAD THROUGHOUT
EACH OF YOUR COMMUNITIES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WILL MOVE TO THE. GALLERY
I BELIEVE WE HAVE A WITNESS IN
THE GALLERY. THE YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MET SUTTON OF THE-
RESTAURANTS. THERE'S A LOT IN
THIS BILL I THINK WHAT PERTAINS
TO THE JURISDICTION OF THIS
COMMITTEE REALLY GETS AT THESE
NEW OUTDOOR DINING SPACES THAT
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED. IN MANY
MANY COMMUNITIES AND IN SHORT
TEMPORARY CATERING
AUTHORIZATION WAS ALLOWED VIA
ABC EMERGENCY REGULATIONS THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL THE
DEAL WITH THIS COMMITTEE'S
JURISDICTION WOULD SIMPLY ALLOW
SOME TEMPORARY FOOD
PREPARATION- IN WHAT'S CALLED
SATELLITE FOOD FACILITIES
MEANING. ADJACENT OR NEXT TO
THESE NEW AND REINVENTED DINING
SPACES IT'S DONE WITH TIGHT
CONTROL IT'S DONE ON A
TEMPORARY BASIS AND WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES NOW FOR- OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
POSITION AND ORGANIZATION IF
YOU REPRESENT ONE. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MADAM OPERATOR.
YOUR PARENTS SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION OF AB SIXTY ONE OF
MY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF SIX OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU KAREN MEMBERS OF THE MONEY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE OF
FOUR FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FOUR FIFTY NINE DO YOU
HAVE A SOME YOU YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THEN WILL GO TO A LINE OF
SIX THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
NUMBER SO HE HAS TO LEAVE SHOP
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN
SUPPORT AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THINK THE NEXT TO
GO TO A LINE OF SIX FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEP WHEN
THEY GET THAT IN OPERATE WITH
THE INDEPENDENT HOSPITALITY
COALITION REPRESENT THE
INDEPENDENT RESTAURANTS
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT EIGHTY
FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR. WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. CHEN MY NAME I'M SORRY
WHAT JUST YOUR NAME AND
POSITION PLEASE MY NAME IS
ANDREA HAD STRONG AND I AM
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU.
BRING IT BACK SEE NO OTHER
WITNESSES BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE OR FOR ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE WHO ARE YOU ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS MR GABRIEL
I AM THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- THE BILL HAS A DO
PASS AS AMENDED- RECOMMENDATION
TO APPROPRIATIONS. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY. I CAN'T REMEMBER WE
HAD A- I'M SORRY WAS IT WAS MY
MISTAKE HERE KERR IN THE SECOND
BY MR RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU-
WHICH I CLOSE WHICH TO GABRIEL
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHENEVER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MATTIS SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WOULD I WOULD I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE BURKE.
CARILLO FLORA. MAIENSCHEIN
MCCARTY MCCARTY I LIVE IN THIS
AREA. NAZARIAN HIGH RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
WALDRON WALDRON AYE CALDERON
CALDERON AYE. EIGHT ZERO YOUR
BILL HAS EIGHT VOTES IT'S OUT
OF COMMITTEE WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR GABRIEL.
MISTER KALRA YOU HAVE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB THREE TWENTY
THREE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY
THREE WILL ALLOW FOR A STATE
OVERSIGHT THAT IS MORE
CONSISTENT BY CREATING A CLEAR
pLICENSE LONG TERM CARE
FACILITIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
DEATHS CAUSED BY THEIR CLEAR
NEGLIGENCE. AND POOR CARE.
ADDITIONALLY UNCHANGED FOR
TWENTY YEARS AB THREE TWENTY
THREE ADOPTS A STATE ON A
RECOMMENDATION TO INCREASE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH COUNTY AMOUNTS. MOVING
FORWARD ROBUST INCLUDE NURSING
HOME OVERSIGHT BY CITY PH WILL
BE CRITICAL. EFFORT TO AVERT
FURTHER TRAGEDIES THAT HAVE
ONLY BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
CODE OF THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
CLASS AS CITATIONS THE MOST
SERIOUS AND ONLY ISSUED A CDPH
CRUISE OF THE FACILITIES
ACTIONS. WAS THE CAUSE OF A
RESIDENTS TO. THE CURRENT
DIRECT PARKS BECAUSE LEGAL
STANDARD IN STATUTES CREATE
INCONSISTENCIES WHEN APPLYING
CLASS DOUBLE A. CITATIONS IN
OUR STATE'S NURSING HOMES
BECAUSE COURTS AND LEGAL
EXPERTS CONCLUDED THAT DIRECT
PROXIMATE CAUSES CONFUSING. AND
UNCLEAR IN FACT THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT HAS SINCE
REJECTED THE APPLICATION OF
PROXIMATE CAUSE AND COURSE
PROCESS RELIED ON A SUBSTANTIAL
FACTOR TEST TO PROVE CAUSATION
IN NEGLIGENCE. THE CHANGES
SUBSTANTIAL PROCTOR PROPOSE
UNDER AB THREE TWENTY THREE.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT NURSING
HOME. A NURSING HOMES AND
FACILITIES APPEAL A CLASS
DOUBLE A CITATION AND A
SUPERIOR COURT. THE STATE HAS
BURDEN OF PROOF FROM THE JUDGE
MUST APPLY THAT CAUSATION
STANDARD IN STATUTE.
ADDITIONALLY PENALTY AMOUNTS
CREATE A DISINCENTIVE FOR
FACILITIES TO VIOLATE HEALTH
AND SAFETY REGULATIONS IN THE
FIRST PLACE. AND THESE MOUNT
THESE AMOUNTS HAVE NOT KEPT UP
WITH INFLATION. AB THREE TWENTY
THREE INCREASES AND REVISES
THOSE STATUTORY AMOUNTS AND
INCLUDES NEGOTIATED AMOUNTS
FIRST PASS ON THIS COMMITTEE IN
TWENTY NINETEEN BUT BY AB FIVE
OH SIX. SHOULD AB THREE TWENTY
THREE PASSES COMMITTEE I'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION IN CONJUNCTION WITH
C. DPH ON ADDRESSING THIS LONG
STANDING ISSUE. HOWEVER OF
THEIR SUGGESTED A MOMENT TO
INCLUDE A FORESEEABILITY TEST
AS AN ELEMENT TO SUBSTANTIATE A
CLASS DEVOID. OF CITATION WAS
THE REASON FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
VETO IN AB FIVE OR SIX AND
THEREFORE THAT IS ONE AREA-
THAT UNFORTUNATELY. WILL BE
DIFFICULT TO NEGOTIATE. WELL ME
OVER THE PHONE TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS PAMELA
LOOP WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. AND TONI CHICKEN
TELL OF CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES
FOR NURSING HOME REFORM THANK
YOU MR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER KALRA WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. AFTER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS AVAILABLE
AND THE SENIOR ATTORNEY AT
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
THREE TWENTY THREE. WE PUT
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THREE AND A
WIN FOR EVERYONE. IT'S A WIN
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. BECAUSE IT PROVIDES
GREATER CLARITY FOR HOW THEY
ACCESS NURSING HOME DEATHS
VIOLATIONS. IT'S A WIN FOR
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
BECAUSE IT GIVES THEM BETTER
GUIDANCE ABOUT THE STANDARD BY
WHICH THEY MUST COMPLY. IT WENT
FOR NURSING HOME RESIDENTS
BECAUSE IT HELPS ENSURE THAT
THEY CAN LIVE IN PLACES. THAT
ARE BETTER REGULATED WHICH WILL
IN TURN HELP KEEP THEM SAFE.
AND ONE DAY IN THE COMING
CRISIS HAS TAUGHT US. IS THAT
ARE SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
HOWEVER MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. AND THAT ARE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES. HE
CONSISTENT AND CLEAR GOVERNMENT
OVERSIGHT. AFTER A LENGTHY
INVESTIGATION INTO HUNDREDS OF
NURSING HOME DEATHS. MY
COLLEAGUES AND I AT DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA PUBLISHED
REPORT CALLED NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS CHANGE. WE CAN
EXPLAINS WHY THE CURRENT LAW
FELL SHORT AND PROVIDING
ADEQUATE GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT.
IN OUR REPORT WE DETAILED
MULTIPLE AND- RESULTS AND
LICENSING CITATIONS OF NURSING
HOME DEATHS. HE FOUNDED THE
CURRENT LEGAL STANDARDS
GOVERNING CITATIONS FOR NURSING
HOME DEATHS IT'S CONFUSING AND
IS PARTIALLY TO BLAME PRETTY
INCONSISTENT RESULTS. EVEN
BETTER LAWYERS AND JUDGES TO
GRAPPLE WITH THE STANDARD
BECAUSE IT IS NOT USED IN OTHER
LEGAL CONTACT. EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY THREE DR SUBSTANTIAL
FACTOR STANDARD. I TERM
UNDERSTOOD BY THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND WHICH WILL HELP
PROVIDE CLARITY AND IN TURN
MORE CONSISTENT AND IMPROVED
LICENSING OVERSIGHT OF SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES. FOR THE
SAKE OF OUR NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS. THE FACILITIES THAT
CARE FOR THEM AND FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB P. TWENTY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON
AB THREE TWENTY THREE MY NAME
IS TONY TICKET TELL AND I'M A
STAFF ATTORNEY WITH CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE FOR NURSING HOME REFORM.
THERE'S NO RESIDENTS HAVE
CERTAINLY SUFFERED IN THE LAST
YEAR AND WE OWE IT TO THEM TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF NURSING
HOME CARE. OUR LAWS AND
REGULATIONS REGARDING STANDARDS
ARE PRETTY GOOD THEY HAVE BEEN
THAT WAY FOR A LONG TIME. THE
PROBLEM HAS BEEN ENFORCEMENT
WHICH WAS ABYSMAL PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC AND SIGNIFICANTLY
CURTAIL CURTAIL DURING THE
PANDEMIC. EIGHTY THREE TWENTY
THREE WILL ENHANCE DETERRENCE
OF BAD CARE AND NURSING HOME.
SUCH DETERRENCE HAS NEVER BEEN
NEEDED MORE. THE BILL PROVIDES
CLARITY TO THE CRITERIA FOR
DOUBLY CITATIONS SO THAT WE
BETTER DETER THE CONDUCT THAT
CAUSES THE DEATH OF RESIDENTS.
AND THE BILL GIVES A LONG
OVERDUE INFLATIONARY BUMP THE
PENALTY AMOUNT TO ENSURE THAT
DETERRENCE IS NOT ERODED BY
DEPRECIATING DOLLARS. R.
CITATION CITATION SYSTEM IS
VERY FLAWED. COMPLAINT AGAINST
NURSING HOMES CONTINUE TO RISE
EVERY YEAR AND ACTIONS TO
ADDRESS THOSE COMPLAINTS
REMAINED PRETTY FLAT AND
LETHARGIC. DALY I SPEAK TO
RESIDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES
WHO ARE BEYOND FRUSTRATED BY
THE STATE INCONSISTENCY IN
MEANINGFULLY ENFORCING THE
RULES MEANT TO PROTECT THEM.
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THREE WILL
UPDATE THE LAW AND BRING A
LITTLE MORE CONSISTENCY IN A
LITTLE MORE JUSTICE TO
ENFORCEMENT. AB THREE TWENTY
THREE ALSO FITS COMFORTABLY
INTO THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PROTECT PLAN A PACKAGE OF
BILLS. THAT AIM TO REPAIR
BREAKDOWNS IN NURSING HOME CARE
AND PROTECT FACILITY RESIDENTS
FROM HARM. IT'S BEEN ENABLED BY
POOR POLICY. PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND- HI. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WELL NOW MOVES ARE
REGISTERED- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MERGING ON BEING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA SAYS
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HELP
INSTABILITIES ARE CURRENTLY
IMPOSE MORE AMENDED AB THREE
TWENTY THREE. THE BILL
CURRENTLY CHANGES THE CAUSATION
ELEMENT FROM PROXIMA COSTA
SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR FOR EE
CITATIONS THIS BILL DOES NOT
INCLUDE UNFORTUNATELY AL
MURATSUCHI ABILITY TO THIS NEW
STANDARD AND WE BELIEVE THERE
NEEDS TO BE. WELL WE'RE
COMMITTED WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORED SPONSORED AS HE PH
LIKE WE DID ON THE PRIOR BILL
BY MISTER KALRAAB FIVE OH SIX
TO FIND COMMON GROUND. AND WE
ACTUALLY GOT TO A PLACE IN
NEUTRAL IN AB FIVE OR SIX AND
IT WAS UNFORTUNATELY VETOED OUR
HOPE IS TO REACHING THE
AMICABLE RESOLUTION OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS RUNNING BETWEEN
TWENTY THREE. AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT AND
THAT PROCESS- WITH MISTER KALRA
AND THE OTHERS INVOLVED FOR
THESE REASONS. WE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY. WE HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR IN AMERICAN ALEXANDRIA
ACT MET WITH LEADING AGE
CALIFORNIA. BUT NONPROFIT
SENIOR LIVING PROVIDERS
INCLUDING- SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH US ABOUT THE CONCERNS WE
HAVE RAISED AND FORTUNATELY WE
HAVE A COMPLAINT WE HAVE
CONCERNS- AS MY AS SHANE-
PREFERENCE- OBVIOUSLY RICHARD.
IT IMPLICITLY. LOWERED THE
EVIDENCE TO RECEIVE IT UP LATER
BY LEE HSIN AND WE UNDERSTAND
THE DESIRE FOR QUICK EDUCATION
BUT ARE OPPOSED TO LOWERING THE
STANDARDS FOR AND- FOR DOUBLE
LIFE. VIOLATION DUE TO THE
SIGNIFICANT RAMIFICATIONS FOR
FACILITIES THE RECEIPT OF LIFE
HIGH TENSIONS INCLUDING
SUSPENSION OF LICENSURE WHICH
WOULD DISPLACE- SENIORS AND-
DISQUALIFICATION. FOR COST
PAYMENT. I MENTIONED BY KATHY
IN IN THIRD QUARTER MEETINGS I
INTO NINETEEN AGREED TO
LANGUAGE THAT HELP CLARIFY THE
EVIDENCE STANDARD WITH WHICH
THINK THAT THE TWO PART
DEFINITION AGREED TO TWENTY
NINETEEN IS THAT THE BEST
APPROACH- WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
TO HOPEFULLY RESOLVE OUR
CONCERNS AND COME TO AN
AGREEMENT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR
NAME. ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE AND POSITION ON
THE BILL PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MADAM OPERATOR. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THE BABY THREE
TWO THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF FIVE SIXTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT WITH THAT
THE ARE YOU CALIFORNIANS
CONCORD THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU NEXT NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE OF
FIVE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BARBARA GLAZER WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE ARE OPPOSE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO LINE OF FIVE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS CRUCIAL
IN A VERY REPRESENTING AARP IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF SIX TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DANIEL SABRINA
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL. SEE NO
ONE WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. I HEAR A
MOTION. MOTION BY MISTAKE HERE
CURRY A SECOND BY MISTER MADE-
MISTER MCCARTY THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
THE BILL DOESN'T C<c.cyan> DO PASS</c>
RECOMMENDATION WHICH LIKE CLOSE
MISTER KALRA. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS AS WANT TO THANK YOU IN
YOUR STATUS IS THE I THINK THE
FIFTY YEAR WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS BILL. I APPRECIATE IT
HOPEFULLY YOU WON'T HAVE TO
COME BACK AGAIN I DO WANT TO
THANK GOD JUST A SUPPORTERS BUT
THE OPPOSITION WHO HAVE SPENT A
LOT OF TIME. OVER THE YEARS
TRYING TO TRYING TO GET TO A-
RESOLUTION SO WITH THAT ARE
STOPPING US FROM LIKE THE-
FIRST. APPRECIATE YOUR
PERSISTENCE MISTER KALRA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I
WOULD AYE MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOTE BURKE. CARILLO
FLORA. MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN
AYE RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
I SANTIAGO. WALDRON CALDERON
CALDERON HIGH. HAS SIX TWO ONE
IT NEEDS TO MORE OKAY WILL BE
THE BILL ON CALL MISTER KALRA
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER
JONES SAWYER YOU HAVE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB FIFTY EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY SIR THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING. THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SPECIFICALLY
DEMANDS CLARIFIED THAT
PHYSICIAN APPROVAL IS NEEDED
BEFORE AN OVERRIDE CAN OCCUR
AND THAT IS BILL DOES NOT LIMIT
MEDICAL STAFF'S ABILITY TO
ESTABLISH STANDARDS FOR QUALITY
ASSURANCE. THESE AMENDMENTS ARE
PRODUCT OF ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION. AND AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD I AM COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO FURTHER ADDRESS
THEIR CONCERNS. AB EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT WELL ALLOW HEALTHCARE
WORKERS PROVIDING DIRECT
PATIENT CARE TO OVERRIDE A
HOSPITAL OUT OF THE RIVER. WITH
PHYSICIAN APPROVAL WHEN THIS
WITHIN THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE
AND ULTIMATELY IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PATIENT. THE
BILL ALSO CLARIFIES THAT HEALTH
CARE WORKERS CAN BE CONSULTED
WHEN WITH WHEN NEW TECHNOLOGIES
ARE INTRODUCED INTO A HEALTH
FACILITY TO ENSURE A SMOOTH
IMPLEMENTATION. WHILE THE
RHYTHMS ARE AN IMPORTANT TOOL
USED TO HELP DECIDE TE BEST
COURSE OF TREATMENT FOR
MILLIONS OF PATIENTS A YEAR.
ARRHYTHMIC BIAS AND
SPECIFICALLY RACIAL BIAS AND
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY ARE WELL
DOCUMENTED. AT TWENTY NINETEEN
STUDY FOUND I WIDELY USE
HOSPITAL ALGORITHM REFERRED
BLACK PATIENTS TO PESTER CARE
PROGRAM SIGNIFICANTLY FEWER
TIMES. THAN THEIR WHITE
COUNTERPARTS. WHEN IN NEW ARE
RE IS IT REPEATEDLY SHOW US.
THE WIDESPREAD IMPACT OF
IMPLICIT BIASES WE AS
LEGISLATORS HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT. MAJOR HOSPITAL
SYSTEMS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
ALREADY RECOGNIZED THIS NEED AS
WELL. AND CONCURRENTLY
IMPLEMENTED THE SAME WORKER
PROTECTIONS TO THEIR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS
TECHNOLOGISTS CERTAINLY A
HELPFUL TOOL THAT COMPLEMENTS
THE SKILLS OF HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS. BUT IS NOT A
REPLACEMENT. FOR REAL LIFE X.
EXPERIENCE ULTIMATELY WILL BE
PROVIDE AS MANY CHECKS AS
POSSIBLE TO REDUCE IMPLICIT
BIASES IN ALL ASPECTS OF HEALTH
CARE WE WILL SAVE LIVES. AB
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT PROMOTES
PATIENT WELL BEING BY CREATING
NECESSARY PROTECTIONS FOR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS TO DO THEIR
JOBS WITHOUT FEAR OF
RETALIATION BECAUSE THE
QUESTION AT ALL RETURN. AS
THEIR PATIENTS ADVOCATE WITH ME
TODAY DERIDE TESTIMONY. OVER
THE PHONE THIS TAYLOR JACKSON
ON BEHALF OF THE BILL'S SPONSOR
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION. AND JENNIFER
MALLET WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BOUGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MR JONES SAWYER
WE WILL MOVE TO THE WITNESSES
SUPPORT- PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR THE WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT. YOUR PHONE LINES ARE
OPEN. HELLO MISTER TERRY MEMBER
TAYLOR JACKSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
ROB BONTA RESERVE EIGHTY EIGHT
FIVE EIGHT I DON'T REMEMBER
JONES SAWYER SAID IMPLICIT
BIASES THAT HUGE ISSUE IN
HEALTHCARE AND STUDY FROM TRUMP
SIGNIFICANT FIVE THAN HERE AND
IN THE ALGORITHMS DEPLOYED ON A
LARGE SCALE THE HEALTH
FACILITIES WHEN YOU EVERYTHING
FROM SETTING PRESCRIPTION PLANS
DESIGNATING PATIENT ACUITY AND
DETERMINING HOSPITAL DISCHARGE
TIMELINE. EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT SIMPLY ENSURE THAT
HEALTHCARE PROVIDER CAN
DISAGREE WITH THE CLINICAL
ALGORITHM TO MAKE THE BEST
TREATMENT DECISION FOR THEIR
UNIQUE PATIENT WHEN IT IS
WITHIN THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE
WHICH NOW INCLUDES THE APPROVAL
OF THE PATIENT'S POSITION
WITHOUT FEAR OF PUNISHMENT.
FROM THEIR EMPLOYER SOLELY FOR
THE DECISION. THEY'RE BOUND BY
THEIR LICENSE CURRENTLY AND
THEY'RE TRYING COMMITMENT TO
THEIR- TO DO WHAT IS RIGHT AND-
THAT CARE AND TREATMENT.
HOWEVER WE A CLEAR OUTWEIGH
RECALLING FOR IN THE CODE.
WE'RE DOING JUST THAT THERE'S
BEEN HEALTHCARE WILL. TO BE PUT
IN POSITION. WHERE THE BACK
HERE THERE FOR THE PATIENTS.
ATTENTIVELY PUT THEIR AND
LIKELY ON THE LOWER. AB EIGHT
OFF OF OPT. FOR GREATER
ENGAGEMENT WITH. IN THE
HOSPITAL. ASKING TO WORK BE
NOTIFIED WE NEED TO. AFFECTING
THEIR JOB IS BEING BROUGHT IN.
THAT WORKERS GET THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET SOME INPUT
ON WHAT KIND OF TECHNOLOGY
SELECTED AN ITEM PLAYERS
PROVIDE ADEQUATE TRAINING FOR
THE NEW TECHNOLOGY. HEALTHCARE
TREATMENT IS NEVER A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL FORMULA AND THE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL WILL
MEAN THAT HEALTHCARE WORKERS
PRIORITY AND REMAIN THEIR
PATIENTS. FOR THAT REASON THE
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
I. ABOUT EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT. THE YOU VERY MUCH OUR
NEXT WITH SINCE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON DOCTOR WOULDN'T-
JENNIFER BAILEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
WHERE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB EIGHT FIVE EIGHT. OCTOBER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS PRESENTING
A DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
MINORITIES IN TERMS OF
INFECTION RATE HOSPITALIZATION
AND MORTALITY MANY BELIEVE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AS A
SOLUTION TO GUIDE CLINICAL
DECISION MAKING FOR THE
PROBABLY FEES RESULTING IN THE
RAPID DISSEMINATION OF
UNDERDEVELOPED AND POTENTIALLY
BY MODEL. WHICH MAY EXACERBATE.
THE DISPARITIES GAP. THERE'S
HOPE THAT AI HELP TREATMENT
DECISIONS INCLUDING THE
ALLOCATION OF SCARCE RESOURCES
WITHIN THE CRISIS. HOWEVER IT
SHOULD NOT LIMIT INDEPENDENT
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL JUDGMENT.
OR A HEALTH CARE WORKERS
ABILITY TO ACT AS A PATIENT
ADVOCATE. ALGORITHM SHOULD NOT
DETERMINE THE CARE NEEDED BY
PATIENTS. GIVEN THE
PERVASIVENESS OF FIVE HE'S A
FAILURE TO PROACTIVELY DEVELOP
COMPREHENSIVE MITIGATION
STRATEGIES DURING THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC RISKS
EXACERBATING EXISTING HEALTH
DISPARITIES AND HINDERING THE
ADOPTION OF A AYE TOOL CAPABLE
OF IMPROVING PATIENT OUTCOME.
AB EIGHT FIVE EIGHT SECONDS ON
A PATH TO MAKE SURE
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR ETHNICITY OR ECONOMIC
STATUS RECEIVE THE BEST CARE
FOR THEM. AND PROTECT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS FROM
RETALIATION IF THEY REQUEST
OVER RIGHT HEALTH INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY AND CLINICAL
PRACTICE GUIDELINES. THE LABOR
FED IS PROUD TO SUPPORT EIGHTY
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR VOTE ON THIS
LEGISLATION TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE DO HAVE TO
REGISTER WITNESSES OPPOSITION
ONE I BELIEVE IS AN ARE
WITNESS- VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOM AND I'M NOT SURE WHERE THE
OTHER ONE IS. THAT MR HAWTHORNE
ON THE PHONE YEAH. PERFECT
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR OUT OF WORK. THANK YOU
ALEX AUTHORITY THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE DO
APPRECIATE THE GOAL OF THE BILL
AND- SEVERAL OF THE AMENDMENTS
BEING TAKEN TODAY. BUT SEVERAL
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUES DO REMAIN
UNRESOLVED AND WE REMAIN
OPPOSED. FIRST THE BILL
UNNECESSARILY DUPLICATE
EXISTING CLINICAL IMPERFECTIONS
WALL INTO THE LABOR CODE. THIS
EXPOSES HOSPITALS TO A BROAD
ARRAY OF FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS.
SMALL VIOLATIONS OF THE LAW
INCLUDING VIOLATIONS WERE NO
HARM OCCURRED. CAN'T FIGURE
EXPENSIVE LAWSUITS FROM PLAYERS
GENERATING LARGE FEES FOR
ATTORNEYS BUT SMALL WORDS FOR
WORKERS. ACCORDING TO A RECENT
STUDY AUTHORED BY THE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT DAS
RELATIONS. AND FORMER CHIEF OF
THE DIVISION OF OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH THE AVERAGE
AWARD TRUMP FULLY IN THESE
TYPES OF LAWSUITS WAS TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS. WHEREAS THE
AVERAGE ATTORNEY FEE WAS FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SECOND LIKE ALL EMPLOYERS AND
PARTICULARLY IN HOSPITAL
ENVIRONMENT WHERE LIVES ARE AT
STAKE EMPLOYERS MUST HAVE
MANAGEMENT RIGHTS TO MAINTAIN A
CHAIN OF COMMAND. BY PLACING AN
INDIVIDUAL PRACTICING
PRACTITIONERS JUDGMENT OUTSIDE
OF EXISTING PROCESSES EVIDENCE
IN TECHNOLOGY THE BILL EXPOSES
PATIENTS TO UNNECESSARY RISK OF
WELL INTENTIONED BUT-
ULTIMATELY UNSAFE MEDICAL
TREATMENT. FOR THOSE REASONS WE
DO REMAIN OPPOSED TO AB EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS IN WHO'S IN OUR- VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM PLEASE GO
AHEAD WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS EMILY HUGHES
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION. FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH US OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL WEEKS WE
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND
CONSIDERATION AND HE AND HIS
STAFF HAVE PUT IT UNDERSTANDING
OUR CONCERNS. OUR INITIAL
DISTRESS WAS IN REGARD TO THE
ABILITY FOR HEALTH CARE WORKERS
INDEPENDENTLY OVERRIDE HEALTH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY. AND
CLINICAL PRACTICE GUIDELINES.
AS YOU CAN SEE IN THE
AMENDMENTS THE AUTHOR DID
ELUCIDATE THAT TO DO SO A
WORKER MUST NOW RECEIVE THE
APPROVAL OF THE SUPERVISING
POSITION. ONLY GREATLY
APPRECIATE THIS CLARIFICATION.
AND ASK THE AUTHORS OFFICE IS
AWARE THERE REMAIN MINOR
OUTLINED CONCERNS WITH THE
SPECIFIC DRAFTING OF THE
LANGUAGE. THAT WE LOOK FORWARD
TO RESOLVING. ADDITIONALLY CMA
IS STILL EXTREMELY CONCERNED
REGARDING THE LEVEL OF
INVOLVEMENT THIS BILL REQUIRES
HEALTH CARE WORKERS TO HAVE IN
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS
AROUND HEALTH INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY. ALTHOUGH LANGUAGE
HAS BEEN ALTERED. EVEN AS
AMENDED THE BILL DOESN'T
HESITATE HEALTH FACILITIES ALL
HEALTH CARE WORKERS A LEVEL OF
ENGAGEMENT AND THE DESIGN.
BUILD AND VALIDATION OF HEALTH
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY THAT WE
FEEL IS NEITHER APPROPRIATE NOR
PRACTICAL. AGAIN I APPRECIATE
THE OFFERS OFFICE FOR WORKING
WITH US TO ALLEVIATE OUR
INITIAL APPREHENSIONS AND THE
AUTHORS COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUING NOT WORK. BUT UNTIL
THE AFTER MENTIONED ISSUES ARE
RESOLVED. CMMS RESPECTFULLY
REMAIN OPPOSED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL AND ADAM OPERATOR WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU IF YOU
ARE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND ZERO NOW. IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP FOR SIXTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHAT
EXPENSE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN IS
JUST NINE AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA COULD BE AFTER
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION WE LINE OUR COMMENTS
MY COLLEAGUES CMA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THANK YOU. AND AS A REMINDER IT
IS ONE AND THEN ZERO
PROPOSITION OF. EIGHTY EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT. OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE DONE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE
THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS- MISTER JONES SAWYER
DO WE HAVE A MOTION. I MOVED A
MOTION BY MISS- MISS CALDERON A
SECOND BY MR MCCARTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS. MISTER JOHN SIR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND I'M GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH CMA-
JUST A QUICK STORY WHY I'M EVEN
INVOLVED IN THIS- MANY OF YOU
KNEW. ME WHEN I WAS A LOT
HEAVIER- WITH DIABETES. AND
SOME OTHER HEALTH CHALLENGES-
OVER A YEAR AGO. AND IT. I WAS
TOLD I WAS AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
BLACK MAN. THAT I HAD NO CHOICE
IN THE MATTER I WAS GOING TO
HAVE DIABETES I WAS GOING TO
HAVE ALL THE AILMENTS AND THEY
GAVE ME DRUGS AND PILLS. I WANT
TO PUT ME ON INSULIN- WHILE I
WAS THERE BECAUSE THAT THE
ALGORITHM THAT WAS THERE- BY
TALK TO MY DOCTOR HE WAS
FOLLOWING ALGORITHM. AND THEN A
NURSE WITH THE LAST NAME OF
DONALD- WHO SAYS. OF LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR FORMER LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR. DONNELLY SAID DOWN
WITH ME AND SAID THIS IS WHAT
YOU DO. FORTY POUNDS LESS
LATER. EATING HEALTHIER BASED
ON RECOMMENDATIONS
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT SHE MAY.
I'M OFF AND SOMEONE. AND IT CUT
MY MET FOREMAN IN HALF. IT WAS
THE COMBINATION OF ALL THREE
WORKING TOGETHER. THAT I CAN
STAND BEFORE YOU. LESS OF A
READY TO INVEST BEFORE. BUT
DEFINITELY HEALTHIER THAN I WAS
BEFORE AND THAT'S WHY I'M
INVOLVED IN EACH. AND I WILL
WORK WITH CMA AND THE OTHERS SO
WE GET TO A PLACE OF COMFORT- I
AND I COMMIT TO THAT. WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
JONES SAWYER THE BILL DOES SHE
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
YOU LOOK LIKE A SHADOW OF YOUR
FORMER SELF BUT YOU LOOK YOU
LOOK FABULOUS- AND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHAT. I WOULD
AYE MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NOT VOTING BURKE BURKE
I CARILLO. FLORA FLORA NO
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN EYEING RIVAS.
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ HI SANTIAGO
WALDRON WALDRON HIGH CALDERON
CALDERON HI. NINE ONE THE BILL
HAS NINE VOTES IS OUT WE'LL
LEAVE WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OF
THE FURTHER SAID ON THANK YOU
MISTER JONES SAWYER. NEXT UP.
MR LEVINE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IF YOU
FIFTEEN TWENTY WOULD ELIMINATE
THE OUT OF POCKET COSTS FOR
PROSTATE PROSTATE CANCER
SCREENING FOR INDIVIDUALS FIFTY
FIVE YEARS OF AGE AND OLDER OR
INDIVIDUALS TO FIND AS HIGH
RISK. BLACK AS A FAMILY HISTORY
OF PROSTATE CANCER A GENETIC
PREDISPOSITION TO PROSTATE
CANCER IS A VETERAN OR AS
DETERMINED BY THEIR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
NEARLY TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS IN CALIFORNIA WILL
BE DIAGNOSED WITH PROSTATE
CANCER MAKING IT THE SECOND
MOST DIAGNOSED CANCER IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE MOST
DIAGNOSED IN THE ENTIRE COUNTRY
A BLACK PERSON WITH A PROSTATE
WILL BE DIAGNOSED WITH PROSTATE
WITH PROSTATE CANCER AT A RATE
ALMOST 80% HIGHER THAN NON
HISPANIC WHITE PEOPLE WITH
PROSTATE AND ARE TWICE AS
LIKELY TO DIE. BECAUSE OF A
LACK OF ACCESS TO TESTING AND
CARE- THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
REQUIRES AN INDIVIDUAL OR SMALL
GROUP HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLAN
OR HEALTH INSURANCE POLICY TO
INCLUDE COVERAGE FOR ESSENTIAL
HEALTH BENEFITS. WHICH INCLUDES
PREVENTIVE SERVICES SUCH AS
PROSTATE CANCER SCREENINGS
HOWEVER. THERE ARE STILL
INSURED INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE
OUT OF POCKET EXPENSES FOR THE
SCREENS. POSTURING IS AN
UNNECESSARY BARRIER TO SCREEN
FOR PROSTATE CANCER SCREENING
IS A CRITICAL FIRST STEP. FOR
DIAGNOSIS IF DETECTED EARLY
NEARLY ONE HUNDRED PERCENT. OF
PATIENTS WILL SURVIVE. AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY WILL HELP TO
ALLEVIATE THE BARRIERS THAT
PREVENT THOSE AT HIGH RISK OF
PROSTATE CANCER CAN GET
GETTING. EARLY SCREENING AN OUT
OF POCKET EXPENSE SHOULD NOT BE
A BARRIER BETWEEN DIAGNOSIS
GETTING TREATMENT. AND SAVING A
LIFE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MOVING NOW MOVES TO
THE WITNESSES WE HAVE TO
REGISTERED WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT- WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
MADAM- OPERATOR. THANK YOU YOUR
LINER OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WORD MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND GAS- DR JOHN LAMB I AM THE
PRESIDENT ELECT OF THE
CALIFORNIA UROLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS THE
REPRESENTATIVE TO THE AMERICAN
UROLOGICAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE MANY
PRACTICING UROLOGIST IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
MYSELF AND I AM A PRACTICING
UROLOGIST IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY OF LOS ANGELES. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO GIVE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY. PROSECUTORS THE
MOST COMMONLY DIAGNOSED CANCER
AND THE SECOND LEADING CAUSE OF
CANCER DEATHS IN OMIT
CALIFORNIA MAN. WITH THE ONE IN
EIGHT MEN WHO WILL BE DIAGNOSED
IN THEIR LIFETIME. ALTHOUGH
PROSECUTORS ARE DOUBTS THAT
BELIES IN RECENT YEARS DUE TO
THE ADVANCES IN TREATMENT IN
EARLIER STAGE DIAGNOSIS WAS
SCREENING. DECLINE FROM
PROSTATE SPECIFIC ANTIGEN OR
PSA TESTING FROM TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT TO TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. MOST LIKELY CAUSED BY
THE MISLEADING INFORMATION
BASED ON OBSOLETE DATA AND HAVE
COINCIDED WITH AN UPTICK IN THE
DIAGNOSIS AFFECTED FRANCE
PROSTATE CANCER. I HAVE
PERSONALLY SEEN THIS IN MY OWN
PRACTICE WHERE MEN ARE
PRESENTING TO ME WITH INCURABLE
METASTATIC PROSTATE CANCER THEY
ARE LOOKING FOR A HOLD AND
OFTEN MY PRIMARY CARE
COLLEAGUES ASKED ME DOES THIS
PROSTATE CANCER DO THIS. AND IF
I'VE EVER SEEN THIS BEFORE AND
I ONLY RESPOND IT'S BEEN MANY
YEARS BACK BEFORE PROSTATE
CANCER SCREENING WAS
WIDESPREAD. A RECENT ANALYSIS
FROM THE NEW ENGLAND JOURNAL OF
MEDICINE PROJECTING THE IMPACT
OF PSA SCREENING FROM THE
WIDELY CITED. EUROPEAN
RANDOMIZED STUDY OF SCREENING
FOR PROSTATE CANCER TRIAL
ESTIMATED THAT THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE MEN. WOULD HAVE TO
BE SCREENED ON ELEVEN CASES OF
PROSTATE CANCER WOULD NEED TO
BE DIAGNOSED TO PREVENT ONE OF
PROSTATE CANCER DEATHS OVER A
TWENTY FIVE YEAR TIME SPAN.
WHICH COMPARES FAVORABLY TO
ANYTHING THAT WE DO IN
PREVENTATIVE MEDICINE AND IS
QUALITATIVELY SIMILAR TO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. SUPPORTING
BREAST CANCER SCREENING. SO I A
CLINICIAN WHO SCREAM. DIAGNOSE
AND TREATS PATIENTS PROSTATE
CANCER THE DALLAS IS A BENEFITS
AND HARMS OF SCREENING MAY BE
MORE FAVORABLE THAN GENERALLY
APPRECIATED. CERTAINLY RESPECT
AS AS WE'VE STATED SUCH AS RACE
FAMILY HISTORY GENETIC
PREDISPOSITION BEING A VETERAN.
SIGNIFICANT RAISES THE PRICE
INDIVIDUALS RISK OF DEVELOPING
PROSTATE CANCER THUS MAKING THE
AVAILABILITY OF EARLY DETECTION
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT. BLACK MEN
HAVE A TWO FOLD HIGHER RATE OF
PROSTATE CANCER DEATHS AND
PRESENT WITH MORE AGGRESSIVE
DISEASE. AT YOUNGER AGES AND
HAVE A HIGHER INCIDENCE
COMPARED TO MEN OF OTHER RACES.
THIS RACIAL DISPARITY IN DANCE
IS CALLING THE WORST AMONG ALL
CANCERS IN THE UNITED STATES.
HAS STRATEGIES FOR CREATING
RACIAL AND SOCIAL PARITY AND
PROSECUTORS ARE NEED TO
CONSIDER SCREENING STRATEGIES.
TO MAXIMIZE THE EARLY DETECTION
OF PROSTATE CANCER THAT NEED
TREATMENT IN ORDER TO REDUCE TO
THESE DEATHS. FURTHERMORE
TREATMENT OF LATE STAGE
PROSTATE CANCERS IN FACT.
QUALITY OF LIFE AND PLACE AN
INCREASE ECONOMIC BURDEN ON THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. INCLUDING
WILL LOCK WILL ALSO WORKER
PRODUCTIVITY AND INCREASE
FINANCIAL TOXICITY FOR THESE
AFFECTED MEN. AND ALTHOUGH
EXISTING LAW REQUIRES PLAN TO
PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR THE
SCREENING AND DIAGNOSIS OF
PROSTATE CANCER. IN THESE OUT
OF POCKET EXPENSES SUCH AS
DEDUCTIBLES COPAYMENTS AND
COINSURANCE THAT MAY DETER OR
EVEN PRE THAT MAN ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN LOW SOCIAL ECONOMIC
STATUS OR IN UNDER SERVED
POPULATIONS FROM UNDERGOING
DETECTION OF EARLY STAGE
PROSTATE CANCER. AND THUS IS A
SOURCE OF DISPARITY FOR
PROSTATE CANCER SURVIVAL. THUS
THE PASSAGE OF THIS BILL WILL
ELIMINATE THIS UNNECESSARY
BARRIERS TO SCREENING WHICH IS
A CRITICAL FIRST STEP FOR THE
DIAGNOSIS. AND WILL SAVE THE
LIVES OF MANY MEN. AT THE YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND I WAS. ASK
YOU TO. VOTE I. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR MUCH- MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT WITNESS ON FOR THE BILL.
VERY PLEASE GO AHEAD NEARLY
YES. I THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME- PANELIST AND- MY
COLLEAGUE JOHN GET AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS CHARLES ROGERS I AM A
CANCER SURVIVOR- I WAS
DIAGNOSED BETWEEN THIRTY. WHICH
STATE FOR PROSTATE CANCER AT
THE AGE OF FORTY FIVE. OR FORTY
PER BERKELEY DURING A ROUTINE
PHYSICAL I'LL PUSH MY DOCTOR.
ABOUT OF ALL THE BIGGEST BE
CONCERNED WITH THAT THE FORTY
YEAR OLD BLACK MAN. AND A
PERSONAL BOTHER THREE CHILDREN
WHO SHOULD TALK ABOUT A BALLOT
QUESTION OVER THE TO DO THAT.
BUT OF COURSE NOT PERSISTED HE
DECIDED TO GO AHEAD AND ISSUE
IF YOU ARE. A FROM THE- WHAT
DOCTOR ORDERED THAT THE ARE YOU
BETA- NOT FOUND TO DO CONTROL
LET NOT WISHED FOR THAT. BUT A
LOT OF PEOPLE FITNESS MY HEALTH
FOR ALL BY LAW I AM IT IS NOT
THE FIRST. OF THE TWENTY NINE
YEAR TO SPEAK CAREER AND IT
HELPED CITIZENS HERE IN OF-
HELLO. HAD I. WHAT PROFIT TO
HER WHAT TO DO TO. HELLO THE
SPECTRUM FACTOR. ARE YOU KNOW
FOR THAT SO. NO LEGISLATURE
CONNECTED ATTACK THAT'S RATED
HIGHER. ALL RIGHT AWAY BECAUSE
SOME MEN ARE JUST INTERFERE. OF
OUR DEALINGS GIVEN THE CUSTOMER
AT THEY'RE GONNA MISS. THE
DOCTORS THAT. AND IF THEY COME
LAW SO SECOND BACK- IT'S REALLY
TOUGH FOR THEIR SIDE NUMBER TO
GET YOUR WITH JUDY RESPECT BEEN
A BY LET. ON GO BEEN LIKE ME.
WILL BE ABLE TO BE SCREENED
FOR. RECORD COST SHARING. A
STORY OF A OF FOUR AND I'M A
HAVE TO SONS. THEY WANT TO BE
STATE HAVE TO BE TOUGH- THE
TENURE DIFFERENCE OF SO AFTER
FIVE. ARE YOU DIAGNOSIS CAN BE
A GOOD BETWEEN LAW. AND I SAW I
SEE HERE TODAY- YOU KNOW I
COULD YOU KIDS USUALLY. A HARM
THAT THEY THAT LIVING WITH THIS
TO FACT THAT I GOT MORE
DETECTION. AND I'M STILL HERE-
THEY'RE DIAGNOSED. ALL OF THE
HUNT OF THE MEN DO SOBOT CANCER.
OF THE FIVE. US ABOUT. I
TARGETED RADIATION. AND- I'M
VERY FORTUNATE. THE MOST GENTLE
FREE TODAY ACROSS THE MONITOR
MY HEALTH ACROSS THE GLOBE LIKE
PHYSICAL ANARCHY FOR TOXIC
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
JUST YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF
YOU REPRESENT ONE AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL MADAM
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES. THANK YOU IF YOU AREN'T
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF FIVE EIGHTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ANDRE AGASSI
AIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION AND FOR THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. REMINDER TO
ONE AND THEN ZERO YOUR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION A BABY FIFTEEN
TWENTY. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
FIVE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BRANDON MARCING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
YOU CAN THAT CURRENTLY IN
SUPPORT OF AMENDED PETITION BUT
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR TAKING-
THE AMENDMENTS RECENTLY I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING THE BILL
IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SCENE NINE WE HAVE A
MOTION BY I MISS AGUIAR-CURRY A
SECOND BY MR MCCARTY I BELIEVE-
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS THAT DOES ENJOY
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION FROM THE
CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
MISTER LIVING. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU FOR
THE CONSIDERATION OF THE
COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WOULD. HI WHAT I MAYES.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW BIGELOW AYE BURKE BURKE
I CARILLO. FLORA. MAIENSCHEIN
THIS MAIENSCHEIN I'D MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN
I REALIZE. RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
I SANTIAGO. WALDRON WHAT
WALDRON AYE CALDERON. CALDERON
HIGH. TEN ZERO. JUST A
CLARIFICATION ON THE MOTION I
HAVE IT AS A DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND YOU SAID DO
PASS AS AMENDED SO JUST OF JUST
CLARIFICATION FOR THE RECORD
PLEASE.
THE MOST WAS THE PASTOR
PREPARATIONS THANK YOU AND THE
AND THE VOTE COUNT WAS TEN ZERO
TEN ZERO GREAT OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. YOUR BILL IS OUT MR
LEVINE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHERS TO ANNA THANK YOU.
NEXT UP MISTER RIVAS. RIVAS YOU
HAVE AB ELEVEN FORTY FOUR.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR. WELL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND I
HAVE ACCEPTED- THE COMMITTEES
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS- I'VE
ALWAYS KNOWN THAT MANY OF THE
LEGISLATURE IS BEST POLICY
IDEAS COME FROM OUR
CONSTITUENTS. AND THIS
LEGISLATION- IS A GREAT EXAMPLE
OF THAT IT WAS PROPOSED BY
COULD SITUATE NAME SUZANNE
MCBRIDE FROM CITY WATSONVILLE
WHO MANAGES A SMALL COTTAGE
FOOD OPERATION OUT OF HER HOME.
I JUST LEGISLATION PROPOSES TO
MAKE A NUMBER OF UPDATES TO
CALIFORNIA'S COTTAGE FOOD LAWS.
THE COLLEGE WOULD OPERATIONS OR
CFO'S ARE SMALL BUSINESSES. IN
WHICH PEOPLE MAKE AND SELL
HOMEMADE FOODS TO HELP
SUPPLEMENT THEIR INCOME OR IN
SOME CASES IS THEIR PRIMARY
SOURCE OF INCOME. UNDER CURRENT
STATE LAW CFO'S ARE LIMITED TO
MAKING FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
OR LESS IN ANNUAL SALES FROM
THEIR FOOD PRODUCTS- THIS FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR FIGURE. HAS NOT
BEEN UPDATED SIX YEARS TO COUNT
FOR INFLATION AND THE RISING
COST OF LIVING HERE IN OUR
STATE. IN ADDITION CFO'S ARE
NOT CURRENTLY ALLOWED TO SHIP
HOMEMADE FOOD THROUGH THE MAIL
OR OTHER THIRD PARTY- SOME
DELIVERY SERVICES ACROSS OUR
STATE AND THIS IS DESPITE THE
RISING IMPORTANCE OF SUCH- OF
SUCH A SUM SERVICES AMID THE
PANDEMIC- THIS BILL PROPOSES TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES BY FIRST
ALLOWING IN THE STATE. THE
DELIVERY OF PRODUCTS VIA MAIL
ORDER. AND OTHER DELIVERY
SERVICES AND SECOND INCREASING
THE SALES LIMIT TO SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR CLASS A
CFO'S AND A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND FOR CLASS BE CFO'S AND
THIRD PREVENT TEEN CLASS BE
CFO'S FROM NEEDING A COLLEGE
WOULD PERMIT IN MULTIPLE
COUNTIES. WITH THE
STRAIGHTFORWARD BUT IMPORTANT
CHANGES TO CALIFORNIA'S
EXISTING COTTAGE FOOD LAWS
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE ONE FOUR FOUR
WILL CREATE SUBSTANTIAL NEW
OPPORTUNITY FOR SMALL BUSINESS
ENTREPRENEURS LIKE SUZANNE- IN
MY DISTRICT AND ACROSS OUR
STATE. WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY-
ARE SONIA CHANG OF- KELLY
GRANOLA LLC IN KHAKI SEEN OF
KHAKIS KERNELS I BELIEVE CATHY
SINGH IS THE ONLY ONE THAT.
WILL BE AVAILABLE TO- MAKE- A
TESTIMONY MISTER CHIP- WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM MADAM
OPERATOR PLEASE THE LINE FOR
THE WITNESS IN SUPPORT. YES I
DO NOT SEE KATHY THING BUT I
ESTIMATES JOHN ON THE LINE
PERFECT THANK YOU. HELLO YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES UP I JUST
WANTED TO HEAR YOU CAN HEAR ME
I AM NOT HAPPY THING I AM TONY
CHANG GALLAGHER NOLAN. AND I
JUST WANTED TO THAT FOR YOUR
RECORD. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF MY FELLOW
ARE USING COTTAGE FOOD
OPERATORS MY NAME IS TONY CHANG
I AM CALIFORNIA LET GIRL AND I
HAVE BEEN TEACHING CREDENTIAL
MORE IMPORTANTLY IN TWENTY TEN
I AM A SINGLE MOTHER OF TWO
CHILDREN. AND I DECIDED TO STAY
HOME WITH MY KIDS INSTEAD OF-
TEACHING. AT I HAVE MY CHILDREN
TWO WEEKS FOR. I NEEDED A
INCOME STREAM WOULD ALLOW ME TO
FLEXIBILITY OF PUTTING MY
FAMILY FOR. IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
I APPLIED FOR A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY COTTAGE FOOD OPERATION
CLASS BE PERMANENT AND STARTED
SELLING A NUTRITION CAN HELP
FOCUS DELICIOUS GRANOLA. AND MY
DAUGHTER IS IT HEALTHY AND TAKE
BAD NOBODY WILL EAT IT. MY
SENSE THAT INCLUDED TWENTY FOUR
WHOLESALE ACCOUNT IN ADDITION
TO DIRECT THEM. I ALSO STARTED
THE GRANOLA OF THE MONTH CLASS
WHICH I HAD TO SHUT DOWN
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T SHIP MY
PRODUCTS. AND THE CLERK WILL
PROBABLY FOR NEEDING DELIVERY
EACH MEMBER HOME ON. TOP OF THE
OTHER RESPONSIBLE. AND THEN.
BUT. OKAY SO I WOULD WHEN I HAD
THEM THAT I CAN NOT CAN THE CO
ESPECIALLY THANK ITSELF EASY
AND THANK YOU **** IN FACT
DURING THE TIME SHIFTING AND
EVEN THANK FOR THE LIVE IN PART
I WOULD LOVE TO SIT YOU LIKE
GOING LESS TO TRY BUT BASS I AM
NOT ALLOWED TO WHAT'S FOUR BOTH
ORDERED I NEEDED MARKET HAS
THAN MY HUNKY COULD HAVE SO I
MY BE CUT A BREAKING MORE
COMMERCE BAKER. NOW THAT I HAVE
OWNED BOTH OF BUSINESS I HAVE A
UNIQUE ON ADVANTAGE AND THE
THAT THE OF THEM ALTHOUGH THE
FOOD LAWS YES SOMEONE ENEMY JAN
TO START BAKERY FROM THERE THE
CURRENT RESTRAINT PREVENT THEM
FROM PROVIDING A VIABLE INCOME
STREAMS FOR THEIR FAMILY
BECAUSE THE GOOD THING
CALIFORNIA BARKER PASSES OTHER
STATE AND THE CURRENT FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS BAIL WHEN THEY
COULD FOR INSTANCE START UP
INTO A COMMERCIAL KITCHEN
BEFORE THEY NEED TO TAKE THAT
STEP. FOR INSTANCE LAST YEAR
KATHY THINK BUSINESS KATHY
COLONEL WOULD DOING SO WELL
THAT SHE NEARLY FOR PASSED THE
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR CAP
ACTUALLY SAID IT WAS HARD TO
IMAGINE TELLING MY REPEAT
CUSTOMERS AND RETAILERS THAT I
COULDN'T PROVIDING GOODIES
DURING THE BUSIEST TIME OF THE
YEAR I THINK ASIAN AMERICAN
IMMIGRANTS I KNOW THE DARING TO
DREAM AND WORKING HARD TO MAKE
THOSE GOALS A REALITY IT'S PART
OF THE AMERICAN NARRATIVE AND
COTTAGE FOOD OPERATIONS ALLOW
PEOPLE TO PRODUCE SMALL
BUSINESS. WITH MINIMAL RISK. WE
THIS BILL WE ARE NOT ASKING
CHANGE THAT. THING FAN. NEARLY
JEFF. SITTING BY. TOOK BACK THE
BOUNDARIES ALLOW OUR BUSINESSES
TO GROW. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO THE
OUR OF CAR WITHOUT. BY PASSED
AB ELEVEN FOUR. WE WOULD BRING
HOME TO SELL PEOPLE. BUT GREAT
FOR. TO OPTION AT. DURING THE
PANDA'S. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THINKING. THE STAFF ANY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE WILL
NOW. WE DON'T HAVE ANY RARE
WITNESSES OPPOSITION SO WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES
FOR. OTHERS IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME ANY
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE. AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL- MADAM SET- MADAM OPERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR A FOR
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
IF YOU'RE A SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT OF AB.
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE UP AT SIX FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU KAREN MEMBERS KIDNEY MARC
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY FARMERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A FEW QUEUING UP
JUST REMINDER IT IS SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION OF AB ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
SIX THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS BURKE FOUND
AND I'M WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR
JUSTICE AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
AB ELEVEN FORTY FOUR. THANK YOU
I WILL JUST NOTED- WE WILL BE
LIMITING TESTIMONY TO TWENTY
MINUTES SO IF WE IF WE HAVE IF
WE HAVE A HUGE NUMBER IN THE
QUEUE WILL BE TWENTY MINUTES SO
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU.
AND WE ONLY HAVE TWO LEFT IN Q.
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP FOR NINETY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FINE HI
MY NAME IS DAVID CRITICAL ON
BEHALF OF THE CRADLE CANDY AND
FORGER AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE UP FOR
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE FOUR FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA WEBSTER MARKETING SO
AND I AM SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU AND WE DO
HAVE ONE MORE THAT CUED UP ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. I WILL GATHER
THEIR NAME OR THEIR NUMBER. AND
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB. ELEVEN FORTY FOUR. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE OF THE. SIX
FORTY FIVE. MOMENT. THANK SIX
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THEY ARE NOT MATURE WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE TOO WE HAVE A
MOTION. MOTION BY MISTER IS
ARIANNA SECOND BY MISS BURKE-
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS MR RIVAS I HAVE YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- DOES ENJOY
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION. WHICH
I CLOSER SUSPECT LAST WHEN I
VOTE THANK YOU VERY CHEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTIONS
THE PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHAT HI WHAT I
MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BURKE BURKE HI
CARRILLO. FLORA MAGI
MAIENSCHEIN HI MCCARTY. MCCARTY
HIGH IN THIS AREA. NAZARIAN
HIGH RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
I SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON I
CALDERON. NINE ZERO THE BILL
HAS THE BILL HAS NINE VOTES-
WILL BE THROWN OPEN FOR OTHERS
AT ON IT BUT THE BILL WAS OUT
SO MOVE ON TO MR STONE YOU HAVE
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB EIGHT OH
EIGHT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SIR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AB EIGHT OH EIGHT IS ULTIMATELY
THE NEXT STEP IN THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE REFORM THAT. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS WE'VE CREATED A DIFFERENT
FRAMEWORK FOR DEALING WITH KIDS
IN OUR FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. BUT
ONE OF THE GAPS THAT HAD REALLY
YET TO BE FULFILLED WORK. KIDS
WITH THE HIGHEST NEEDS AND
ULTIMATELY THE STATE ENDED UP
SENDING THOSE KIDS. OUT OF
STATE. AND CERTIFYING VARIOUS
NUMBERS OF FACILITIES. DUE TO
SOME PROBLEMS OF THOSE
FACILITIES THE STATE ENDED UP
DECERTIFYING ALL OF THE OUT OF
STATE FACILITIES AND BROUGHT
THOSE KIDS BACK ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY SOME ODD. AND THAT
RAISES THE QUESTION OF WHY
CALIFORNIA CANNOT DEVELOP THE
CAPACITY TO DEAL WITH ALL THOSE
KIDS REGARDLESS OF LEVEL OF
NEED IN STATE AND THAT'S WHAT
AB EIGHT AWAIT IS ABOUT IT IS
CREATING. A CRISIS SUPPORT FOR
KIDS WITH THE HIGHEST MEANS IN
THE REASON THAT WE'RE HERE AS
WELL AS WITH HUMAN SERVICES IS
IT COMBINES MENTAL HEALTH
FACILITIES AS WELL AS THIS
GROUP CRISIS INTERVENTION
FACILITY IN A PILOT PROGRAM
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT TO SEE IF
WE CAN REALLY FILL IN THE GAP
AND DEVELOP THAT CAPACITY DEAL
WITH THESE KIDS IN CALIFORNIA.
OBVIATING THE NEED TO SEND THEM
OUT OF STATE WHICH WOULD BE
ULTIMATELY A VERY GOOD THING
FOR CALIFORNIA THAT'S WHAT ABA
DALY IS IT. THESE ARE.
INTERVENTIONS THAT ARE
INDIVIDUALLY TAILORED TOWARDS
THE KIDS. AND AT THE HIGHEST
LEVEL THERE WOULD BE SOME
FAIRLY RAPID STEP DOWN. OUT OF
THOSE AS APPROPRIATE FOR THE
NEEDS OF THAT CHILD TO GET THEM
INTO. BETTER INDIVIDUALIZED
PLACEMENTS. WITH CRAIG THIS
NOTION OF SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC PROGRAM
S. T. R. T. P.'S. FOR KIDS TO
GO INTO. SHOULD THEY NEED THAT
LEVEL OF ASSISTANCE AS THEY
ENTER THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM.
THIS WOULD BE AN S. T. R. T. P.
OF MAYBE ONE OR TWO BEDS AT THE
MOST SO IT IS HIGHLY
INDIVIDUALIZED TAILORED.
TOWARDS THOSE KIDS OF THE
HIGHEST NEEDS. THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT STEP FOR
CALIFORNIANS DURING WE KEEP
KIDS. HERE AT HOME AND CLOSE TO
HOME INSTEAD OF SENDING THEM
OUT OF STATE. AND WITH ME I'VE
BEEN WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH.
SEE FAQ IT WAS THE W. D. A. AND
I. HAVE KATHY CENTER LINK OF
THE CALIFORNIA WILL FOR
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. AND TEN
BERWICK OF THE SENECA FAMILY
AGENCIES. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL BECAUSE SENICA. AS
A PROVIDER OF FAMILY SERVICES.
IS ONE OF THE KINDS OF
ORGANIZATIONS WE WOULD NEED TO
RELY ON TO CREATE THIS
CAPACITY. HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MATTER OPERATIVE. OPEN THE LINE
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN ROBERT HALF
A CENTURY LINK OUT ALL OF THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION SHE GOT MEDIATED
PLEASE GIVE ME A CO SPONSOR AB
EIGHT AWAIT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE NOTED THE PURPOSE OF AB
EIGHT OH WAIT HIS TURN GRAPHIC
APP ON OUR SERVICES AND SUPPORT
TO YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE
SPECIFICALLY THOSE WHO
EXPERIENCE VERY SIGNIFICANT
COMMA I HAVE SIGNIFICANT
SERVICE NEEDS. FOR MANY YEARS
EVEN CREATING CPR COUNTY THE
STRUGGLE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF A
SMALL GROUP OF VERY HIGHLY
TRAUMATIZED YOU SEE IF YOU HAVE
THE STRENGTH TO BUILD CONTENT
OF THOUGHTFUL SET OF SERVICES
AND SUPPORT PROGRAMS WILL HELP
TO BUILD THEIR RESILIENCE AND
HELP THEM OVERCOME THE TRAUMA
THEY HAVE EXPERIENCED. THIS
ISSUE CREATED THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE REFORM IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
AND WAS NOT FULLY ADDRESSED IN
SUBSEQUENT IMPLEMENTATION
EFFORTS. AS A RESULT OVER TIME
LISTING SERVICE THINK
HEIGHTENED FOR THE THOUGHT THAT
IF YOU USE UP THE SERVICE ARRAY
KEEPING TAKES. PROCEED TO BE A
PRIVATE PRACTICE BY PONDERING
EIGHTY TWENTY EIGHTY THREE
THOUSAND AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY ALSO CO
AUTHORED AB EIGHT AWAIT. AMONG
OTHER THINGS AB TWENTY THREE
REQUIRED THE STATE TO PERFORM A
GAP ANALYSIS OF SERVICE. FOR
USE WITH MORE COMPLEX NEEDS AND
TO DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS TO
ADDRESS THAT MEANS THAT
ANALYSIS WAS NOT COMPLETED BY
THE DEADLINE IN THE LEGISLATION
AND OF BEHIND SCHEDULE. WHAT IS
IN PROGRESS NOW WE HAVE QUITE
FRANKLY LOST TIME AND LOST
GROUND AND OUR CHILDREN IN.
UNIFORM THE RESULTS ABOUT. WE
KNOW COUNTY SIXTY OVER THESE
YEARS THIS IS A FOR WHICH
BETTER MORE. AND MORE CONCRETE
SURVEY ARE YOU NOW. TO HELP I
DON'T AND BUILD UNDER. AND HELP
THEM RESULT TO ANY VOICE. FOR
ALL. OR IF. INSURANCE INITIAL
TERM. SO WE CAN GET THEM BACK
IN A FAMILY SETTING AS WE TO
PASS. DONE THE SO MANY OF THEIR
PEERS. STEM PARTLY EIGHTY
EIGHT- IT WOULD SO LET'S PULL
IN THE HIGHER END OF THE CAN.
WAS SERVICES ARE TO. A WITH
INTEL. SO THAT ARE COUNTY. ARE
NOT FOR TO RELY OUT OF OPTION
TO CARE. YOU WE WITH THE AUTHOR
THAT IS NOT WHAT WE TO BE DOING.
SPEC COUNTY THAT HAVE MY SORT
IN STATE FOR MANY. WE NEED A
FAIR NEEDS AND BROUGHT
PLACEMENT CHOICES TO. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. IN A WAY THAT THEY
DO NOT EXIST TODAY SO WE CAN
AVOID THESE OUT OF STATE. STE
FINALLY THAT ALSO PRIOR TO
PRIORITIZE INTENSIVE TREATMENT.
FOLLOWED QUICKLY BY A STEP DOWN
TO INTENSIFIED HOME BASED
SERVICES. THE GOAL IS NOT TO
SIMPLY CREATE A CONGREGATE CARE
OPTIONS FOR YOU. AND THEN JUST
LEAVE THEM THERE. THE GOAL IS
TO ENSURE WE HAVE A TO CONTINUE
ON FOR ALL OF THE- RESEARCH
THAT WE STRIVE TO SUPPORT THEM
IN HOME BASED SETTINGS AND THAT
WE FILL THE GAP BETWEEN NOW
EXIST. FOR THE RELATIVELY SMALL
NUMBER OF YOU PRETEND THAT.
CONTINUUM FALL SHORT TODAY. WE
REALLY HAVE. THE ALL FARAI. THE
STAFF SPEARHEADING THE- AND FOR
THE THREE WE URGE. THOUGHT ON
THAT MEASURE I DON'T COURSE I'M
HAPPY. AFTER QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY TO MOVE ON TO THE-
WITH. PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIRED MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MONIES CAN BE ERICA
I'M THE CEO AND FOUNDER OF
SENECA FAMILY OF AGENCIES. AND
FROM OUR INCEPTION IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE AND I CAN START TO
CREATE A CONTINUUM OF CARE. TO
HELP CHILDREN AND FAMILIES TO
THEIR MOST DIFFICULT TIMES AND
WE TRIED TO DO THAT.
UNCONDITIONALLY WITH THE IDEA
THAT NO MATTER WHAT NEED TO
USE- HAS WILL BRING TO THE
TABLE OR THEIR FAMILY THAT WE
WOULD PROVIDE SERVICES AND
SUPPORT. TO HELP THEM THROUGH
THAT TIME. MORE THAN FIVE YEARS
AGO WITH THE HELP OF THE IRVINE
FOUNDATION- WE CONVENE A
STAKEHOLDERS MEETING. OF SOME
OF THE TOP THINKERS IN THE
STATE ABOUT WHAT WE COULD DO
ABOUT THE GAPS IN CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM. THAT WERE CAUSING US
RATHER THAN FIGURING- CHILDREN
IN- IN IN THE STATE. TO SEND
THEM OUT OF STATE TO LARGE
CONGREGATE CARE FACILITIES AWAY
FROM THEIR FAMILIES AND AWAY
FROM THEIR SUPPORT NETWORKS.
AND THAT STAKEHOLDERS GROUP
CAME UP WITH A SERIES OF
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WAS
FOLLOWED ON- IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS BUT THE CHILD WELFARE
COUNCIL'S INTERESTS
RECOMMENDATIONS. THAT TALKED
ABOUT A FULL CONTINUUM OF CRE-
IN THAT CONTINUUM FOCUSES ON
PREVENTION IT FOCUSES ON
SERVICES LIKE WRAPAROUND AT THE
CENTER OF THAT CONTINUUM. BUT
IT ALSO FOCUSES ON VERY
INTENSIVE SHORT TERM SERVICES.
THE IS WITH THE GREATEST NEEDS
AND THE GREATEST RISK FOR
SAFETY HI. THAT'S A REMAINING
GAP IN THE SYSTEM AND THAT THE
GAP IN THE SYSTEM THAT SUPPORTS
CALIFORNIA TO SEND TIME AND
TIME AGAIN. YOU TO OUT OF STATE
THAT WE COULD HAVE SERVED IN
STATE. AND CLOSE TO THEIR
FAMILY AND CLOSE TO THEIR
SUPPORT NETWORKS. WHEN WE
BROUGHT THE YOUNG PEOPLE BACK
FROM OUT OF STATE THEN WE WHEN
WE REALIZED THAT THAT THAT THE
PLACEMENT WARRANT- THE
DIRECTION. WE WANT TO FOLLOW
THE STATE WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT
WITH INTENSIVE ENOUGH.
WRAPAROUND SUPPORT CAN WE CALL
THEM- EXPEDITED SERVICES THAT
WE COULD BRING MANY OF THOSE
YOUNG PEOPLE HOME CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT. BUT WHAT WE'VE
ALSO FOUND. IS THAT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF YOUNG PEOPLE. IT FOR
SHORT PERIODS OF TIME HIGHLY.
AND FARM IN. TYPE OF. THIS BILL
BRINGS US TO CAL AND ALLOW US
TO AGAIN. AND CAN IN THE WAY
THAT WE- WITH AROUND HOME BASED
SERVICES TENANTS. INTENSIVE
WRAPAROUND BUT IT PROVIDE TO
CONTINUE ON THAT SAYS NO MATTER
WHAT HAPPENS WE CAN SERVE YOU
HERE IN THE STATE CALIFORNIANS
MADE TREMENDOUS PROGRESS WITH
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE C. R.
WITH THE- LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE'S DECISION TO
IMPLEMENT- FAMILY URGENT
RESPONSE SYSTEMS AS A WAY TO
DIFFERENT YOUNG PEOPLE FROM
HOSPITALS AND MORE INTENSE IN
SETTINGS AND TO PROVIDE SUPPORT
AT HOME. THIS IS THE ONE OF THE
FINAL PIECES TO COMPLETE THE
CONTINUUM AND THE PROMISE THAT
WE MAKING THE CALIFORNIANS THAT
WILL KEEP YOU HERE AND
TURBULENT CONDITIONS AND NO
MATTER WHAT YOU NEED TO ENTER
THE MOST DIFFICULT TIMES OF
YOUR LIFE I URGE. YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- DO REDUCE
OPPOSITE. SO MADAM OPERATOR
PLEASE- OPEN THE LINE FOR THE
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU YOUR
LINES ARE OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON REAR WHEN YOU
YOURSELF TURNING FIFTY FOUR
BETTER SAN FRANCISCO BASED
ORGANIZATION THAT IS DEDICATED
TO MORE THAN FORTY YEARS
STATEWIDE AND NATIONALLY TO
TRANSFORM CHILD WELFARE AND
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM SO THAT
CHILDREN TRIED. THE U.
FAULCONER OPPOSED TO THE EIGHTY
EIGHT OH WAIT A BILL THAT IS
NOT GROUNDED THAT WOULD HARM
CHILDREN UNDERMINE CALIFORNIA'S
CONTINUING CARE REFORM.
ALTHOUGH EIGHTY EIGHT AWAY
CONTENT LAUDABLE THE BILL WOULD
FATALLY FLAWED IN SHOULD NOT
MOVE UNLESS COMPLETELY
OVERHAUL. THE BILL WOULD CREATE
A PILOT PURPORTEDLY TO SERVE
YOU PREVIOUSLY WOULD HAVE BEEN
SET UP THE FACILITY BECAUSE
THEY WERE DEEMED TO HAVE ME
THAT COULD NOT BE MET IN
CALIFORNIA. NUMBER EIGHTY EIGHT
OKAY IT'S BASED ON UNSUPPORTED
ASSUMPTIONS RATHER THAN ONE AN
ANALYSIS OF THE NEED TO FOSTER
YOUTH TO ANY ASSESSMENT OF THE
SERVICE GAP REPORTS THE
PROCESSES THAT PREVENT ME FROM
BEING BACK EITHER A FAMILY OR
CONCRETE SETTING UNDER EXISTING
LAWS AND STRUCTURES. THREE
BURKE STAKEHOLDER INCLUDE YES
YOU SAY I THE- IN THE NATION
THAT WOULD SERVICE GAPS.
IDENTIFIED PIE WITH PARTY
POPULATION AND ENSURE THE
EVIDENCE BASED BOB FOR YOU. PER
SERVING YOU CAN ONLY
RESTRICTIVE OR LIMITED. EIGHTY
EIGHT OKAY THE PROPOSAL A
RETURN TO SAY MA POLICY DOES.
THANK WOULD BE AN EXCLUSION OF
THE NEED AND THE HAVE BEEN YOU
EXAMPLE CAN SAY IN- INCLUDE
BLOCK INTO POINT. BOB IN
CALIFORNIA BETTER AT MINIMUM
THE LARGEST WITH CANCERS
SUPPORTED BY EVIDENCE FOR THE
FOLLOWNG DAY WHAT. WHY YOU
PILE THE WHAT HAPPENED EXISTS
TO SUPPORT ME HAVEN'T ENGAGED
IMPACT YOU AND FAMILIES IN THE
TIRMIDHI NEED- WILL BE THIRD
AND HAVE ENSURED THAT THE
TARGETED POPULATION IS STARK.
WE DO NOT HAVE THE ANSWERS OR
MECHANISM DETERMINING THE
ANSWERS TO THESE QUESTIONS.
YEAH AB EIGHT OKAY. AB EIGHT
ZERO THE BILL UPON HIM FROM AND
LESSONS FOR FREE PREVIOUS FOR
ACT. RIGHT YEAH THANK YOU KATIE
RENDON SWIMBAIT SERVICES THE
TROUBLED BY OF TRAFFIC BRING
AND PC ARE. NOT Y. ON WHY ANY
DATA IN OUR OR EVIDENCE YEAH
SUPPORT. INSTEAD EIGHTY EIGHT
OH EIGHT WITH WHY NOT FORTY I'M
SUPPORT EXPANSION THANK.
CALIFORNIA IN A BILL TO IN INTO
THE PRE OPTIONS WITHIN THE
CURRENT FRAMEWORK BEING. I
DON'T THINK TREATMENT THAT THAT
BASED INTERVENTIONS THAT DO NOT
EXIST IN CALIFORNIA. YEAH THE
BILL WOULD BE TO FIND
TRANSITION SUPPORT DEVELOP
OTHER SERVICES TO SUPPORT YOUTH
AND FAMILY SETTING AND THE
STATE CAN ABILITY. TO SUPPORT.
HERE OF TREATMENT NEEDED TO
SURVIVE AFTER YOU PUT BEHIND ME.
CALIFORNIA'S RECENT EXPERIENCE
IN THE LAST YEAR WITH THE
DECERTIFICATION OF ALL HOW TO
TAKE CARE TO BUY EXTRA CARE
FACILITY BECAUSE MOST
FACILITIES DID NOT MEET
CALIFORNIA STANDARD AND WE'RE
NOT MEETING THE NEEDS OF.
CALIFORNIA YOU. AND THE- OF THE
WALK YOU BACK IN STATE PROVIDED
OF INFORMATION THAT WE ARE
IGNORING. THE MAJORITY OF THOSE
YOUTH WHO CAME BACK FROM
CALIFORNIA THE HUNDRED THIRTY
SOMEONE YOU RETURNED TO A
FAMILY SETTING WITH SUPPORT.
YEAH ALMOST ALL OF THE
REMAINING YOU RETURNED AGAIN
STATE PLACEMENT WITH A VERY
SHORT TIME FRAME. AB EIGHT WE
PROPOSE A RADICAL DEPARTURE
FROM SOUND PUBLIC POLICY
DEVELOPMENT IN CURRENT PRACTICE
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE BASED
JUSTIFICATION EACH OF THE
REFORM EFFORTS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED INVOLVED DATA
ANALYSIS THE BIRTH STAKEHOLDER
INPUT AND SOME MEASURE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. SIMILAR PRODUCT
AND SHOULD BE REQUIRED FOR AB
EIGHT OKAY AB EIGHT AWAIT
SHOULD NOT BE RUSHED THROUGH
THIS YEAR FOR APPROVED WITHOUT
PCHR YOU BOUGHT THAT ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED ZINKE EIGHT OH
EIGHT AND. PURCHASE YOUR
NOTEBOOK THANK YOU. THE YOU
VERY MUCH WILL MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES NOW FOR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL- JUST
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE AND YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MADAM OPERATOR. THANK YOU
DEAR IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
OF AB EIGHT OH EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE FOR THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
COUNTY DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION HERE WITH
THE SUPPORT AMENDED PETITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL
GO TO LINE SIX FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR MEMBERS PERSONAL HIT OFF
ON BEHALF OF THE FRESNO COUNTY
AND THE COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE SIX SIXTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
TURN MEMBERS NATOLIN COOPER
FROM THE OPEN MARKET MORE ON
BEHALF OF CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
OVER TO ONE OF SIX FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHURCH MEMBERS DANIEL
SANCHEZ ON THE ON THE CHEAP
PROBATION OFFICERS OF
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE BONTA
REPEATEDLY THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU.
AND AS A REMINDER WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OF AB
EIGHT OH EIGHT. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF SIX SIXTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIRTY CAP ON BEHALF OF THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT EIGHTY
EIGHT OH EIGHT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU ABOUT
THE LINE OF FIVE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. KELLY BROOK ON
BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTY THE
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO MORE
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE. C. NINE DO I
WHO HAVE A MOTION. MOTION BY
MISTER MCCARTY SECOND BY MR
BURKE MOTIONS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS THE BILL DOES
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
MR STONE WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VISITOR MEMBERS AND I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
WHILE SEIZE CONCERNS I THINK
ARE WELL TAKEN IT IN FOUNDED IN
THE FACT THAT WHEN THOSE
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE KIDS WERE
BROUGHT NEEDED TO BE BRING
BROUGHT BACK BECAUSE- OF THE
DECERTIFICATION THOSE
FACILITIES. THEY WERE ALMOST
ALL PLACED WITH INDIVIDUAL
FAMILIES AND THAT BEGS THE
QUESTION OF WHY THEY WERE SENT
OUT OF STATE IN THE FIRST PLACE
BY THREE IS THIS IS A PILOT
PROGRAM AND WHAT WE'RE REALLY
TRYING TO DO HERE. THE ALL THE
OUT OF STATE FACILITIES HAVE
BEEN DECERTIFIED BUT THE FACT
IS THAT OF A COUNTY ASKS DSS TO
CONSIDER ANOTHER PLACEMENT OUT
OF STATE THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS OF
THE CERTIFIED. AND WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS PROVIDE AN
OPTION HERE AS THE S. AS DOES
THE GAP ANALYSIS THAT THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO DO. WE'RE TRYING TO
PROVIDE A REAL OPTION. THAT
PROVIDES THAT THAT KIND OF A
PLACEMENT THAT. CARRIES ARE
CONCERNED THAT WE DON'T HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT MAKES THEM
WANT TO LOOK. OUT OF STATE AND
THIS GIVES US AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT THING WORKING ON IS A IS A
BUDGET. ASK AS WELL TO INVEST
IN THIS CAPACITY. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE AND I AM NOT. GOING
TO ENCOURAGE IT A PROLIFERATION
OF THE NUMBER OF BEDS. BECAUSE
IF WE BUILD THOSE BEDS WE WILL
FILL THEM AND THAT IS
ANTITHETICAL TO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE. WHAT WE TRY
TO DO IS MAKE SURE WE KEEP THE
KIDS IN STATE. THEY GET THE
LEVEL OF SERVICE WHATEVER THEY
NEED ON AN INDIVIDUALIZED
BASIS. PLAYED AN INDIVIDUALIZED
BASIS. SO THAT THEY CAN STAY IN
STATE. GET THE MEET THEIR NEEDS
ADDRESSED AND BE PUT INTO AN
APPROPRIATE FAMILY PLACEMENT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THAT'S
REALLY WHAT THIS PILOT. IS
ABOUT BUT IT NEEDS TO BE DONE
THOUGHTFULLY. CAREFULLY NEED TO
BE APPROPRIATELY FUNDED. AND I
THINK IT IS IT IS. PAST TIME
THAT CALIFORNIA REALLY LOOKED.
HARD AT WHAT CAPACITY WE HAVE.
ASKED THOSE HARD QUESTIONS
THAT'S WHAT THE PILOT WAS ABOUT
AND I ASK FOR YOUR I. HAVE A-
THINK THINK YOU MISTER STONE
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY- FROM
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE. THANK YOU
FOR THE WORK YOU'VE DONE IN
THIS AREA I KNOW THIS AND THEY
WORKED IN. IN THIS IS AREA FOR
MANY YEARS AND- PRECIADO
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS VERY
MUCH- WITH THAT- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES AYE
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE BURKE. BURKE HI
CARILLO CARILLO HI LAURA.
MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY MCCARTY I
AND NAZARIAN. RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. WALDRON
WALDRON AYE CALDERON CALDERON I.
IT'S TEN ZERO TEN ZERO YOUR
BILL IS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHER STAND ON THANK
YOU MR STONE. MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
SURE NOW MOVING TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. AB THIRTY TWO ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE FIRST AND FOREMOST
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING TIRELESSLY
WITH MY STAFF AND SPONSORS. ON
MARCH THIRTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DECLARED
A NATIONAL STATE OF EMERGENCY
BECAUSE OF THE COVERT NINETEEN
VIRUS. IT OOK A PANDEMIC TO
REALIZE WE NEED TO FIND
AFFORDABLE AND RELIABLE WAYS TO
ENSURE OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. BY
ALLOWING MORE FLEXIBILITY
PATIENTS COULD CONTINUE TO SEE
THEIR PROVIDERS CREATING A
BRIDGE TO EXPAND ACCESS IN MORE
NORMAL TIMES. AB THIRTY TWO
MAKES THIS FLEXIBILITY TO
ACCESS OUR HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
MORE PERMANENT SO THAT ACCESS
DOESN'T GO AWAY WITH THE
PANDEMIC. WELL THE PANDEMIC HAS
LED TO DISRUPTIONS IN PATIENT
ACCESS TO CARE OF CARE
TELEHEALTH SPECIFICALLY
CALIFORNIA CARE HAS ALLOWED
PROVIDERS TO BRING CARE TO
THEIR PATIENTS. AND WHILE
VIRTUAL CARE CANNOT AND SHOULD
NOT REPLACE IN PERSON CARE.
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THE
TELEHEALTH EXPEDIA ACCESS TO
CARE I WILL FOSTER MORE
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED
POPULATIONS. ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAM AB THIRTY TWO
WILL INCREASE HEALTHCARE HEALTH
CARE TAXES WELL THE DISC
DECREASING DISPARITIES CREATED
BY INCOME. RACE AND ETHNICITY
LACK OF MOBILITY A SHORTAGE OF
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS ARE
TECHNOLOGY BASED BARRIERS. I
PERSONALLY HAVE GOTTEN A GREAT
DEAL OF FEEDBACK FROM
CONSTITUENTS AND OTHERS HAVE
SAID THE TELEHEALTH HAS BEEN A
LIFESAVER. STUDENTS ENTERING
THE HEALTH WORKFORCE HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO GRADUATE ON TIME AND
JOIN THE FRONT LINES BECAUSE
TELEHEALTH ALLOWED THEM TO
SATISFY THE REQUIRED CLINICAL
HOURS. SAFETY NET PROVIDERS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO PREVENTATIVE CARE-
AND HAVE SEEN A DECREASE IN
THOSE SHOWS. IN TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY LACK
ACCESS TO RELIABLE. ALL THE
PROVIDERS AND HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY BENEFICIAL. AN
ELDERLY COMMUNITIES WHERE
TECHNOLOGY CAN BE A CHALLENGE
TELEPHONIC CARE HAS MADE IT
EASIER TO ACCESS SERVICES. STAY
AT HOME PARENTS WHO DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO CHILDCARE ARE ABLE TO
SPEAK TO PROVIDERS VIA VIDEO OR
PHONE. AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST
ESSENTIAL WORKERS HAVE NOT HAD
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN TAKING TIME
OFF AND TAKING CARE OF
THEMSELVES. POLITICS TELEHEALTH
IS REVOLUTIONIZING HOW WE
PROVIDE SAFE. EQUITABLE AND
EFFECTIVE HEALTH CARE. IT IS A
CRITICAL TOOL IN OUR HEALTH
TOOLBOX. PLEASE JOIN ME IN OUR
TELEHEALTH COALITION IN
CHAMPIONING THIS EXPANSION OF
OPTIONS FOR A CONSTITUENT
PATIENTS AND THEIR PROVIDERS
INCREASING ACCESS IN BOTH
PRIMARY AND SPECIALTY CARE. AND
REDUCTION OF THE BARRIERS TO
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES ACCESS TO
THE CARE THEY NEED TO LIVE
HEALTHIER LIVES. WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IS DOCTOR MELISSA
MARSHALL CEO OF COMMUNICATOR
HELP CENTER. AND DR ANAYA WHO
IS THE ASSISTANT CLINICAL
PROFESSOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAMILY MEDICINE AT UCLA. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
MOVE ON TO THE- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. HELLO MISTER CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DR MELISSA MARSHALL. I
AM THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER
COMMUNICATOR HOLE CENTERS A
NONPROFIT MULTISITE FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTER TO
PROVIDE CARE TO OVER TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND PATIENTS REGULAR
COUNTY. I'M ALSO A FAMILY MAN
METAPHYSICIAN TWENTY YEARS AND
A PROUD BOARD MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION. COMMUNICATOR LIKE
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS ACROSS
THE STATE IS PROUD OF HOW
QUICKLY WE TRANSITIONED OUR
KAREN SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY.
TO GUARANTEE TIMELY QUALITY
ACCESS TO CARE. KEY TO OUR
SUCCESS FOR THE POLICY
FLEXIBILITIES AND PAYMENT FOR
MEDICAL AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE PROVIDED USING TELEHEALTH
INCLUDING AUDIO ONLY MODALITIES.
COMMUNICATOR HAS PROVIDED OVER
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
TELEHEALTH VISITS AS PART OF
OUR PANDEMIC RESPONSE. 3% WILL
BUY VIDEO VIDEO VISITS ARE
CHALLENGING FOR MANY REASONS
BUT WERE MORE SUCCESSFUL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BECAUSE OF
THE LONGER LENGTH OF VISITS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TROUBLESHOOT
ISSUES WITH TECHNOLOGY. WITH
OUR QUICK ACTIONS TO WATCH
TELEHEALTH OUR PATIENTS
REPORTED FEELING SAFE DURING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
THEY ALSO DID NOT HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT MISSING WORK FOR
TRANSPORTATION BARRIERS THAT
ARISE WHEN NEEDING TO TRAVEL IN
PERSON FOR CARE. TELEHEALTH
INCLUDING ACCESS TO AUDIO ONLY
MODALITIES THAT ADDRESS THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE HAVE THE POWER
TO BE A GREAT EQUALIZER.
TELEHEALTH HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY TRANSFORMATIONAL
FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INTERVENTIONS. AS A CEO AND
FORMER CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER
QUALITY AND CLINICAL
APPROPRIATENESS MATTER DEEPLY
TO ME I KNOW THAT THERE HAS
BEEN A CONCERN ABOUT A
REDUCTION IN QUALITY DUE TO
TELEHEALTH THE COMMUNICATOR
MAINTAINED ITS STRONG
PERFORMANCE IN PARTNERSHIP
HEALTH PLANS QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM IN TWENTY
TWENTY WE ARE IN THE TOP FIVE
FOR CLINICAL QUALITY OUT OF A
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS FOURTEEN COUNTIES. I AM
HERE TODAY TO RESPECTFULLY URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO ADOPT THE
NECESSARY POLICY CHANGES. TO
ALLOW HEALTH CENTERS LIKE US TO
CONTINUE THESE FLEXIBILITIES
POST ENDEMIC. WITH THE
LEGISLATION'S BRIDGE PERIOD FOR
HEALTH CENTERS TO MAINTAIN
THEIR CURRENT PAYMENT WALLET
VALUE WAITING TELEHEALTH
UTILIZATION IN A NON PANDEMIC
PERIOD. THIS LEGISLATION
PREPARES HEALTH CENTERS FOR THE
FUTURE AND RECOGNIZES THE ROLE
OF TELEHEALTH AND EVALUE BASED
ENVIRONMENT. I WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT THIS
IS THE HEALTH EQUITY ISSUE. AS
A PRIVATE PATIENT KAISER I CAN
HAVE A TELEPHONE TO THAT WITH
MY PROVIDER. STATION HEALTH
CENTERS DESERVE THE SAME. 77%
OF OUR PATIENTS SURVEYED
STRONGLY AGREED THAT TELEHEALTH
MADE IT EASIER TO SEE THEIR
PROVIDER. THE FACT THAT THIS
LEGISLATION ALLOWS FOR PHONE
VISITS RECOGNIZES THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE. BROADBAND AND INTERNET
LIMITATIONS ARE REAL EVEN FOR
THOSE THAT DO HAVE PROPER
DEVICES TROUBLESHOOTING
TECHNOLOGY WITH PATIENTS HAS
BEEN TIME CONSUMING FOR BOTH
PARTIES. WE HAVE DOCUMENTED
MORE NO SHOWS FOR VIDEO VISITS
OVER FROM DOESN'T. IN AN
INFORMAL SURVEY WITH OUR
PATIENTS THEY REPORTED THAT
THEY PREFER PHONE TO VIDEO AT
70% WE ALL RECOGNIZE THAT THE
GENIE IS OUT OF THE BOTTLE WE
CAN MAINTAIN TELEHEALTH AND
MAINTAIN QUALITY FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OUR PATIENTS. FOR
THESE REASONS I AM PLEASED TO
BE HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATES AND THE CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. MISTER
CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND YOUR
CURRY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS DR YOU ALI AND I AM.
AN ASSISTANT PROFESSOR IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAMILY MEDICINE
AT UCLA AND WORKED CLOSELY WITH
THE LATINO POLICY AND POLITICS
INITIATIVE. IN THE CENTER FOR
THE STUDY OF LATINO HEALTH AND
CULTURE WITH MY PARTNER FOR
RESEARCH ON THE SUBJECT. OF
TELEHEALTH INTOLERABLE
POPULATIONS SOME OF WHICH I
SHARED WITH YOU AT THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. ON
TELEPHONE POLICY IN FEBRUARY.
AS A PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN FOR
DIVERSE PATIENT POPULATION
EDUCATOR AND FAMILY MEDICINE
AND RESEARCH ADDRESSING HEALTH
DISPARITIES ARE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. I'M GRATEFUL FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY AND ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF MY PATIENTS TODAY.
THE PANDEMIC BROUGHT TO LIGHT
THE INADEQUACY OF OUR COUNTRY'S
EXISTING TELEHEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
INEFFICIENCIES AND
REIMBURSEMENT RULES IN PLACE
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC. AND
STRUCTURAL BARRIERS IN ACCESS
TO CARE FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE
PATIENTS. THE LOWER
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
TELEPHONE VISIT CREATED
FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS FOR
PRACTICES AS WE MOVE TO
PROVIDING THE MAJORITY OF OUR
BUSINESS YOUR TELEHEALTH. AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
PHYSICIANS WHO ARE CARING. FOR
ALREADY UNDERSERVED PATIENT.
FRANKLY FIFTY THREE HIGHLIGHT
THE NEED TO ENSURE TELL HEALTH
CARE WITH ABLE TO BE DELIVERED.
WHAT IF. AND AFTER WITH. THE
TEMPORARY POLICY ADMIN CHANGE
THAT CAN. MAY IN RESPONSE TO
THE TENDER. ALLOWED PER PATIENT
CARE ACCESS THAT CARE. COVERAGE
AND PAYMENT PARITY FOR
TELEPHONE ALLOWED US TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE BOTH ACUTE
AND CHRONIC CARE. AND TO BRIDGE
THE DELAYS IN CARE ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC DIRECTLY AND
INDIRECTLY HAS LED TO. A
REALITY WE HAVE COME TO BECOME
MORE ACUTELY AWARE OF WITH THE
ADVENT OF TELEHEALTH IS THAT
NOT EVERYONE HAD CONNECTIVITY.
COVERAGE AND PAYMENT PARITY FOR
AUDIO ONLY TELEHEALTH AND THAT.
ALLOWS THEM OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE PATIENTS ARE ELDERLY
PATIENTS ARE PATIENTS WITHOUT
COMPUTERS ARE PATIENTS WITHOUT
PRIOR DIGITAL SKILLS. ALSO HAVE
ACCESS TO CARE FROM THE SAFETY
OF THEIR HOMES. EVEN IF A
CLINIC TO MINIMIZING ANY
POTENTIAL RISK OF COLD EXPOSURE
FOR OUR PATIENTS MANY PATIENTS
STILL RELY. ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION OR CATCHING A
RIDE WITH A NEIGHBOR OR FRIEND
WHICH LEADS TO EXPOSURE. BUT
THE OUR OUR PATIENTS
COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR
PROVIDERS AND THE MODALITY THEY
HAVE AVAILABLE TO THEM. WHEN
CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE AND
NECESSARY. ENSURING EQUITY AND
ACCESS FOR ALL OF OUR PATIENTS
INCLUDING THOSE MOST VULNERABLE
WILL BE KEY TO IMPROVE LONG
TERM OUTCOMES. WHICH WILL
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND REDUCE LONG
TERM HEALTH CARE COSTS. IT'S
REQUIRED THAT BE THOUGHT BOTH
IN PERSON AND NOT A DIFFERENCE
FOR ALL INTO THE- OKAY.
REIMBURSEMENT FOR INTERNET.
FUNDAMENTALS PROVIDING. TO PAY
IN THE NET TELL HOW AT LEAST
THE SHORT TERM. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW
WHILE WE BUILD UP THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SERVE THEM
VIA VIRTUAL BUSINESS FOR THE
LONG TERM. HAPPEN CURRENT
RESEARCH HAS DEMONSTRATED THE
WAYS IN WHICH INTEGRATED
TELEHEALTH CAN IMPROVE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF TRADITIONAL%
CARE. IT CARRIED OUT FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OUR PATIENTS HELLO
HOPE GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY
TO IMPROVE CHRONIC CARE
MANAGEMENT. TO A CERTAIN.
DELIVERY OF HIGH QUALITY CARE
WE WILL NEED TO AND TELEHEALTH
DELIVERY. FOR EQUITABLE
ACCESSIBILITY AND INCLUSIVITY
STRATEGIZING ON WAYS TO ENSURE
THE SYSTEM DOES NOT LEAVE OUR
MOST VULNERABLE PATIENTS
BEHIND. WILL NEED TO PROMOTE
SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE QUALITY OF
CARE STANDARDS THAT APPLY
WHETHER CARE IS. PROVIDED
VIRTUALLY OR IN PERSON AND OVER
TIME CAN DETERMINE. BEST
PRACTICES FOR THE RIGHT MIX OF
IN PERSON AND TELL HEALTHCARE.
BECAUSE THE PROPOSED
LEGISLATION RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF COVERAGE AND
SUFFICIENT PAYMENT FOR
TELEHEALTH. INCLUDING AUDIO
ONLY ENCOUNTER ALL PEACE AND
ALSO RECOGNIZES THE NEED FOR
CONTINUED EVALUATION AND
RESEARCH TO ENSURE THAT WE TO
PROVIDE. HIGH QUALITY CARE TO
ALL PATIENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO CONSIDER HOW WE CAN PROMOTE
TELEHEALTH SERVICES HAT WE CAN
HELP ADDRESS. AND CAREFULLY
AVOID FURTHER CONTRIBUTING TO
INEQUITIES WITHIN OUR NEW ERA
OF HEALTHCARE DELIVERY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
PHONE FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
ANY ORGANIZATION YOU MIGHT
REPRESENT. AND YOUR POSITION-
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MADAM
OPERATOR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ONE AND
ZERO FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF PORT
EIGHTY OKAY. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
WE'LL GO TO LINE UP FIVE SIXTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIVE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
DO YOU HAVE A TIME YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CARDMEMBERS PRICE
DOUGHERTY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ANESTHESIOLOGISTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
I WILL NOTE THAT WE WILL- WE
WILL LIMIT THE TESTIMONY TO
TWENTY MINUTES I KNOW THERE'S
ABOUT FIFTY PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE
SO. PLEASE GO AHEAD NEXT CAR.
YOU WERE GOING TO LINE UP FOR
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON THE STRUCTURE MEMBERS
CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF TO
DISTRICT HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP
FORUM IN SUPPORT IN ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORTING CONCEPT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER
THE LINE UP FOR SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANKS ON BEHALF
OF- CHANGE SHOULD BE AMERICA
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
JUST AT NINE THE CALIFORNIA
PODIA ETTRICK MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION S. C. H. E.
BEHAVIORAL SERVICES ALL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO GO TO LINE OF FIVE
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS CAN.
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ACROSS THE LINE OF SIX
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS TERRY HE-
GRATEFUL RECIPIENTS OF RECENTLY.
URGENTLY NEEDED HELP VOLUNTEER
WHO BETTER TO HELP OUT THAN HIM
BUT MAKE THE ECONOMY. FOUR
EIGHT THIRTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER THE
LINE SIX SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING HERE NUMBERS
CALLS WHEREAS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GINETTA
PHOTO LINE UP FOR FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBEKAH GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT BOTTOM LINE FIVE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KELLY
BROOK BOBBIE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS WERE PROPOSED CONCERT
ADDITIONALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE
DISSERTATION OF CALIFORNIA
IRVINE COUNTY TO CALIFORNIA IN
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HERE IN AND DO THE
ETHNIC SUPPORT. THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO GO TO
LINE OF FOUR SEVENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEGHAN SUPER COMBI HALF
OF CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATE THE PROTOPLANETARY
IMPORT. THANK YOU. YOU KNOW TO
GO TO LINE OF FIVE FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS RECTANGLE REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN NURSES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
GREAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOT
TO GO TO LINE UP FOR NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KATIE
WRITTEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KNOCKED OVER ONE OF
SIX EIGHTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE WORK ON BEHALF OF THE
DENTIST HELP AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NOT GOING TO
LINE OF FOUR SIXTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MOLLY WRITTEN
WITH IT'S A CALIFORNIA CAPITAL.
PART THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
STRUGGLE TO LINE UP FOR THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
NICHOLA HORN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH FACILITIES IN THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
FORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AN EXTROVERT SO LINE
OF SIX SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI THIS IS SERRA YEARS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA WITH
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WE'RE GONNA GO LINE
UP BY SIX SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BOB GRAHAM HALF
OF THE CENTRAL ACCENT CAL.
BOARD OF AB THIRTY KEEPS. THANK
YOU. EXTROVERTED LINE OF SIX
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU NEED A STRONG GRAN A. R. P.
CALIFORNIA BOND VOLUNTEER ON
BEHALF OF OUR OVER THREE
MILLION MEMBERS IN SUPPORT OF
AB THIRTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK IN OCTOBER LINE UP.
FOR THIRTY FIVE. HI THE
BALLERINA HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
A PROUD CO SPONSOR IN THE
THIRTY. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ABOUT THE
LINE OF SIX EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
JERRY MEMBER. ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS THE INSTITUTION OF
PSYCHIATRY CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY SOLANO COUNTY AND
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE COURT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU VOTER ONE OF
SIX NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DETAILS OF THE
NOTIFICATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO LINE OF SIX
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU TERM MEMBER THURBER'S
ON BEHALF OF THE INVITATION
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT. Q. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
ONE OF SIX FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THAT AFTERNOON SURE
NUMBER WILLIAM UP THE BURKE ON
BEHALF OF NAY ROUTE. CALIFORNIA
BARTON. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ABOUT THE
LINE OF FIVE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
REALLY TORN ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY CLINIC ASSOCIATION OF
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY THREE. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE'LL
GO TO LINE UP FIVE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KAREN
WATER BOND REPRESENTING BENEFIT
FAMILY CLINIC A COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTER AND MEDICAL
CLINIC STRONGLY SUPPORT AT
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU NEXTCODE
PLEASE. WHAT A LINE UP TO SIX
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RANDALL HAGER
FOR THE PSYCHIATRIC SOLUTIONS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE OF SIX SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. PROTEON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
CURRENTLY OPPOSED UNLESS A MAN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU ABOUT
A LINE OF SIX THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
DAVID LEVINE WITH THE HEALTH
ALLIANCE THE MAN CALIFORNIA AND
THE NORTH COAST CLINICS NETWORK
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
YOU ABOUT A LINE OF FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
NEXT GENERATION. AND WITH ALL
THE REDWOOD COMMUNITY HEALTH
COALITION FOR OUR SPEECH THE
FOR SHORT IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
T. V. THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. GIVE ABOUT
THE LINE OF A SIX SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HEY DIANA
DOUGLAS WITH HEALTH ACTED
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE CURRENTLY
SUPPORT IF ABOUT IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
PHOTO ONE OF SIX EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHE SAID
AFTERNOON KELLY HIT ON BE HALF
THAT ARE HELD IN SUPPORT EIGHT
PM. THANK YOU WILL GO TO ONE OF
SIX THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BUT A LINE OF
SIX FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY COUNTY EGGMAN BOULDER
VALLEY HEALTH CENTERS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY OF CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
TWO. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. IN ORDER TO LINE UP
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ELIMINATES
ABILITY AND THE DIRECTOR OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THAT DENNIS
FAMILY CLINIC AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU NEXT ONE IS
GONNA COME FROM SIX THIRTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIRTY THREE
YES PLEASE CALL HI MY NAME IS
CHRISTY BOY ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA DIALYSIS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO THANK
YOU NEXT CALL GIVES. MEXICO
CAROLINA SIX FORTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS ON
ORLEANS LINE OF THE NATIONAL
MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS SOCIETY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU GO TO A LINE
OF FIVE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
MY NAME IS ROBERT CAMPBELL WITH
THE LOS ANGELES LGBT CENTER AND
WE ARE IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF EIGHTY THIRTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ABOUT ONE OF
FIVE EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK GOODNESS OKAY
SHAILA WITH WALKING OPEN IF I
COULD DISTRICT WE CURRENTLY ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AMENDED THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND WEBER TO LINE UP EIGHTY
THREE A LINE IS OPEN. NEWNESS
IS GOING BACK MILLAN CALLING
BEHALF. MARCH OF DIMES AND SAN
MATTEO COUNTY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YOU WILL GO TO
LINE UP BY FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ROY AFGHAN
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE TROOP CARE- WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BUT THE LINE OF FIVE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS MARK LOCAL MEDIA ON
BEHALF OF THE STANDARD
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY TEAM THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
ABOUT THE LINE UP FOR FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON HE INJURED CHILDREN
ALLOW IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
PM THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YOU
WILL LINE OF SIX SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE SIX
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE CHECK YOUR MUTE BUTTON.
THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE OF SIX
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CRIPPLED FROM
BEHALF OF A KILL A HEALTH AND
LOS ANGELES AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
YOUR BOTTOM LINE OF SIX SEVENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS MODELING
COOPER FROM THE OPEN MARKET
MARK ON BEHALF OF CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY IN FORT THANKYOUNG
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU ABOUT ONE OF SIX
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
VIDEOBOARD REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION AND
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES BOTH
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. ONE OF SIX
EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU CAN TALK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA TO CARE COALITION
STONE TEMPLE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. Q. WHAT TO A LOT
OF SIX EIGHTY- A LINEUP OPEN.
GOOD MY NAME IS ERICA FONG ON
THE OF THE NATIONAL MS SOCIETY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO ONE OF SIX
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HEARING DOCTORS PROPOSED IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU BUT A LOT OF
OPEN. HI I'M ON BEHALF OF
DEFECTED FROM THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING. FROM
THANK YOU MEXICO PLEASE. THANK
YOU ABOUT THE LINE OF SIX
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BARBARA PLAYED YOU WITH A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
IN ORDER TO ALIGN OF SEVEN
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON TERMINATE MEMBERS
OPERATE AGAIN ON BEHALF OF ALL
TO GET HELP FOR HIS PART THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
NO FOR THEIR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN VIEW OF THE SUN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE YOU HAVE ACCEPTED
THE AMENDMENTS JUST HAVING
OCCURRED THANK YOU- THE BILL
DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION- YOU KNOW
COMMENTS- WE DID HAVE- WE DID
HAVE A MOTION BY MISS BURKE THE
SECOND BY MISS CALDERON- WOULD
WHICH I CLOSE. WHICH I WOULD
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAKING THE
TIME WITH YOUR STAFFING MY
STAFF TO COME TO THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE WERE
PROPOSING AND YOU WERE
PROPOSING. YOU KNOW WE CAN'T DO
THESE JOBS ALONE AND IT TOOK A
TEAM AND I REALLY WANT TO THANK
FROM THE BOTTOM MY HEART. AS
WELL AS MY WHOLE STUFF AND
WE'RE SO EXCITED ABOUT THIS
BILL TO GET IT ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE HOPE WE WILL DO SO
TODAY- YOU KNOW FIRST OF ALL.
LET'S REMEMBER COLLEAGUES.
TELEHEALTH IS REVOLUTIONIZING
HOW WE PROVIDE SAFE EQUITABLE.
AND EFFECTIVE HEALTH CARE. AND
I SIMPLY AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR OUR VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU.
WELL I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT TO THIS- TO
THIS BILL INTO THIS ISSUE. THE
LONG STANDING COMMITMENT. AND
I'M HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THIS SIDE I'M A FIRM BELIEVER
IN A STRONG BELIEVER IN
TELEHEALTH. AND I THINK IF ONE
THING THAT THERE'S ONE POSITIVE
THING WHICH ONE SMALL POSITIVE
THING THAT'S COME OUT OF
BECAUSE OF IT IT IS THE IS THE
PROOF OF CONCEPT OF TELEHEALTH
AND SO. BELIEVE IT'S OUR JOB TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN KEEP THIS-
ALIVE AND WELL- FOR THE HEALTH
OF ALL OF OUR PATIENTS AND I
THINK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS ON.
ON BEHALF OF THIS ISSUE- THE
BILL HAS A DO PASS AS AMENDED
RECOMMENDATION. TO
APPROPRIATIONS- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OKAY OKAY
MY ADVICE IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SO A MAN'S MAN
SIXTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL WHAT
I WOULD AYE MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
HI AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW.
BURKE CORREA. FLORA MAIENSCHEIN.
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS. RODRIGUEZ
VEGAS I'VE SANTIAGO. WALDRON
WALDRON AYE CALDERON CALDERON
HI. SEVEN ZERO NEEDS ONE MORE
ONE MORE BUT AS YOU CAN SEE THE
COMMITTEES WILL SLIDE SLIDE
RIGHT NOW SO- WITH THAT-
BELIEVE YOUR BILL ACCOMPLISHES-
PLEASE GO AHEAD WITH YOUR NEXT
BILL AB FORTY FIVE. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS WORK ON THIS
MEASURE. AB FORTY FIVE CREATES
A REGULATORY FRAMEWORK FOR
INDUSTRIAL HEMP PRODUCTS IN
CALIFORNIA. IN FOODS BEVERAGES
AND PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS. IF
LIMITS HEMP PRODUCTION PRODUCTS
TO CONTAINING NO MORE THAN
THREE TENTHS OF PERCENT THC.
REQUIRES THAT HIM PRODUCES BE
SUBJECT TO TESTING AND LABELING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THEIR PRODUCTS.
THE. TWO HUNDRED EIGHTEEN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BECAUSE ME
FEDERAL FARM BILL HER FIGHT
THAT INDUSTRIAL HEMP AS AN
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT. I'M
REMOVED INGREDIENTS AND HELP
FROM THE FEDERAL DRUG FOOD AND
DRUG ADMINISTRATION SCHEDULES.
THIS ACTION CLASSIFIED HEMP
INGREDIENTS AS GENERALLY SAFE
FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION AND OPEN
THE DOORS FOR FARMERS TO
CULTIVATE INDUSTRIAL HEMP.
CALIFORNIA LEGALIZED CANNABIS
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
NOTWITHSTANDING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S POSITION THE
CANNABIS IS ILLEGAL. IRONICALLY
WHILE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS REMOVED BARRIERS TO THE
LEGAL USE OF HAMPER DERIVED
PRODUCTS INCLUDING CBD
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT TAKEN A
SIMILAR APPROACH. CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY ALLOWS THE
MANUFACTURING AND SALE OF
RECREATIONAL MARIJUANA PRODUCTS
INCLUDING FOOD AND DRINKS YEAH
ONE OF HIM IS THE SOURCE OF CBD
TO BE ADDED TO FOOD PRODUCTS IT
IS PROHIBITED. MANY PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN PURCHASING HIM DERIVE CBD
PRODUCTS AT THE LOCAL NATURAL
FOODS SHOPS. FITNESS CENTERS
AND EVEN HIGH END DEPARTMENT
STORES FOR SOME TIME. AND THIS
IS A LEGAL. IN FACT SENIORS ARE-A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
PEOPLE CHOOSING TO USE HEMP
CBD. BECAUSE THEY DO NOT WANT
TO VISIT THE MARIJUANA
DISPENSARY. THE MANUFACTURE AND
SALE OF CBD DERIVED FROM HEMP-IS A RAPIDLY EXPANDING BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA WITH MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF ECONOMIC
PRODUCTIVITY. SHOULD THE STATE
CHOOSE NOT TO CLARIFY THAT HEMP
CBD PRODUCTS ARE LEGAL FOR SALE
AND CONSUMPTION BUSINESSES AND
THEIR TAX REVENUES ARE LOST. WE
HAVE A WILD WILD WEST FOR CBD
PRODUCTS NOW ONLINE AND IN
STORES UNWITTINGLY FILLING ON
REGULATED PRODUCTS. I DON'T
WANT MY CONSTITUENTS BY
UNTESTED UNREGULATED OUT OF
STATE FOR FOREIGN PRODUCTS.
THEY ARE UNSAFE. WHILE OUR
FARMERS AND BUSINESSES LOSE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. AB FORTY
FIVE WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO
MAKE IT EASIER TO ACCESS A NON
INTOXICATING ALTERNATIVE
PRODUCT CONSUMERS WANT AND FOR
FARMERS TO ESTABLISH THEMSELVES
IN A FAST GROWING INDUSTRY.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY ARE
RAN MARTIN REPRESENTING THE U.
S. CAMP ROUND TABLE AND AMY
JACK JENKINS REVERSING THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU RUN THEM
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR WITNESS IN SUPPORT. WE'LL
AND WE'LL WE'LL GO TO THE AS WELL THAT'S WILL GO
TO THE GALLERY FOR SO- THINKING
PLEASE GO AHEAD SIR. THE CHAIR
MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE U. S. HEMP ROUNDTABLE
AND CMG KHALIFA. I JUST LIKE TO
MAKE THREE POINTS TODAY. ONE IS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ALREADY ALLOWS. THE
STATE TO THEIR ALL AUTHORIZES
THE- MANUFACTURERS AND
RETAILERS TO SELL- TEXTURES
CREAMS TOPICALS THAT HAVE HIM
CVD. IT DOES NOT ALLOW THEM TO
INCLUDED IN FOOD AND BEVERAGES
DIETARY SUPPLEMENTS OR INTENT
PRODUCTS THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
THAT AND WOOD PULLED ALL THOSE
PRODUCTS INCLUDING THE ONES
THE SAME REGULATORY STRUCTURE.
I NUMBER TWO YOU WILL SOLVE
THIS BILL LAST SESSION IN AB
TWO TWO EIGHT I'M PASSING
UNANIMOUSLY OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE WHICH WE APPRECIATE
IT. I SAY THAT I BRING THAT UP
TO POINT OUT THAT THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY MUCH STRONGER VERSION
THAN THE ONE THAT YOU WILL
PASSED LAST SESSION- WE HAVE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OVER THE LAST
YEAR. TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL REGULATORY STRUCTURE
ANDS AND GRANULARITY- THAT WE
THINK IS GOING TO MAKE THIS
PRODUCT EVEN SAFER- FOR
CONSUMERSINCLUDING SOME VERY
PROFOUND- PROVISIONS RELATIVE
TO- TO TESTING. WHICH WOULD
MAKE SURE THAT CAN SEE BEAUTY
PRODUCTS ARE TESTED EXACTLY.
THE SAME AS CANNABIS PRODUCTS
OR- THE THIRD POINT I WANT TO
TODAY'S THAT THIS ISN'T. THING
FOR THE ECONOMY OF CALIFORNIA-
THERE ARE NATIONAL PROJECTIONS
ABOUT HIM CVD THAT SAYS OVER
THE NEXT YEAR. NATIONALLY THE
INDUSTRY IS GOING TO BE ABOUT
FIVE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS. CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS
20% OF THE WELLNESS MARKET.
THAT MEANS FOR CALIFORNIA ONCE
WE HAVE THIS IN PLACE. AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT A BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY OVER THE OVER
THE NEXT YEAR WITH ALL THE
REQUISITE JOB CREATION AS WELL
AS- AS WELL AS- TAX REVENUES.
WHEN WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH FOLKS WHO HAVE EXPRESSED
SOME CONCERNS LIKE THE FARM
BUREAU. WORKING WITH THEM AND
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO TRY
AND RESOLVE THEIR CONCERN THOSE
CONCERNS. WE'RE CONFIDENT WE'LL
BE ABLE TO- TO MAKE SOME
PROGRESS ON THAT AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD. WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
ANYTHING CAN FINALLY HAPPEN THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WITH THE CIA WE ARE
PLEASED TO BE PART OF THE OF
THE SERVER COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE P. FORTY FIVE AS
A MEMBER OF THE COALITION IS
HELPED SHAPE THE BILL TO ENSURE
THE INTERESTS OF OUR OVER FOUR
HUNDRED CANNABIS INDUSTRY
NUMBER THIRTY FOUR. EIGHTY
FORTY FIVE INCLUDES THE
FOLLOWING CRITICAL AND IT
DOUBLES AS A COMPREHENSIVE
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK FOR HAND
MANUFACTURING REQUIRING
OPERATORS TO ADHERE TO STRICT
NEW CONSUMER STATE STANDARDS
INCLUDE COMPREHENSIVE POPPING
PROTOCOL THE MILLER TO THE
STATE'S REQUIREMENT FOR CANADA
WHICH WILL ENSURE A LEVEL OF BT
AND PEACE OF MIND CURRENTLY
AFFORDED TO CANNABIS CONSUMERS.
IT HAD REGULAR CONSUMER SAFETY
PROTOCOLS INCLUDING ADVERTISING
AND LABELING STANDARDS BASED ON
EXISTING STANDARDS FOR CANNABIS
I'M NOT PLEASE ENSURE THE
ONGOING COMMUNICATION AND
COLLABORATION AMONG HEMP AND
CANNABIS LICENSING AGENCIES.
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT FACILITATE
COMPLIANCE AND ENFORCEMENT
AGAIN UNLIKE. MANY FACTORS I'M
A PREVIOUSLY NOTED- BY RAND
MARTIN B. AND THERE ARE MANY
OTHER PROVISION- THAT WE ARE
WORKING ON. AND CAN MAKE THE
BILL EVEN STRONGER CLARIFY
QUESTIONS THAT MAYBE AND CLEAR
AND ENSURE THE PROTECTION AND
VIABILITY OF THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY AND THE CROP AT. THIS
USED TO INCLUDE CLOSING ANY
REMAINING RECALL TO ENSURE THAT
ALL PSYCHOACTIVE CANNABINOID
ARE PROHIBITED AND HEALTH
PRODUCTS DEVELOPING AN COUPLE
POCKET FROM THE MANUFACTURE AND
SALE OF MOBILE AND HELPFUL
PRODUCTS. AND ESTABLISHING A
CLEAR AND BALANCED PROCESS AND
PATHWAY FOR THE INCORPORATION
OF KIND INTO THE COUNTER THAT
THE FIGHT SCENE BOB THE
PROTECTING THE INTERESTS OF
KIND OF THE OPERATOR AND STATE
BECAME WISHES TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR HER ONGOING
AND THOUGHTFUL COLLABORATION
WITH THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY TO
ADDRESS THESE. AND OTHER.
CRITICAL PRIORITY AND REQUIRE
YOUR I VOTE FOR A FORTY FIVE.
WHICH REPRESENTS AN STEP TOWARD
BUILDING A STRONG HAND AND KIND
OF THAT INDUSTRY CALIFORNIA
LASTLY I NOTE. OCTOBER EVEN ON
BEHALF OF EVEN THAT THANK YOUNG
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LIKE TO GO
AHEAD AND MOVE OPPOSITION
PLEASE I BELIEVE HAVE ONE
REGISTER OPPOSITION WITNESS.
MESSAGES INCLUDING. MY NAME IS
TAIWO ON A PRO TO THE CAN
BUSINESS. ON BEHALF OF A LARGE
CO OF ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS
HUNDREDS OF LIKE YOU CAN ADOPT
GREATER YOU'RE ALL HERE ENOUGH
AND AMENDED POSITION OF FORTY
FIVE AND A CURRENT FORM. WE
RECOGNIZE THE INTENTION TO
MAYBE FORTY FIVE POWER THEIR
UNINTENDED. CONSEQUENCES.
SHOULD THE BILL PASSED WITHOUT
AMENDMENT. AND IN CANADA PLANS
ARE ONLY GOOD BY AMOUNT OF
DELTON THC THE PLANT MAY PART.
BETTER OTHERWISE I. BOTH
PRODUCE THE SAME CAMERA NOISE
SUCH AS CBD AND THC. ARE ONLY
TWO OF UNDER OF OVER A HUNDRED
KNOWN CANONIZED ITS CURRENT
FORM AB 45% A CLEAR PUBLIC
HEALTH THREAT BY ALLOWING YOU
FACT THAT. THE PSYCHOACTIVE
PRODUCT BUDGET I MEAN THERE
INDEED THE CAMERA NOISE KNOWN
AS DELTA EIGHT. AND UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF AB FORTY FIVE
PASSING ALLOWED FOR PRODUCTS
SUCH AS THE IMMEDIATELY SOLD TO
UNDERAGE CONSUMERS TO RETAILERS
SUCH AS GAP NATION MONKEY ON.
THE FLOOR AND OTHER RETAILERS
CAN ONLY BE IN THE SAME WEATHER
HAMPER CANNABIS DERIVED MUCH
REQUIRE SEEN SIXTY SEVEN.
EIGHTY FORTY FIVE DOES NOT
ESTABLISHED AFTER REQUIREMENTS
IN FULL PARITY WITH CANISTER I
CAME IN I PRODUCT AND THOSE
CANDIDATES I THINK THE OWNERS
HAVE BEEN DEBATED THROUGH
CANNABIS REGULATIONS FOR YEARS
NOW. NOR DOES IT REQUIRE ANY
CONSUMERS FINAL FORM TESTING TO
ENSURE THE PRODUCT AND NOT
LEAST ANY HEAVY METAL FURTHER
TALKS WITH FROM THE PACKAGING
AND LABEL CLAIMS ARE ACCURATE.
LACK OF PARITY IN TESTING EAGLE
TO CANADA SAFETY TESTING
REQUIREMENTS BRIGHTON PUBLIC
OUT IN CONSUMER CONFIDENCE. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE TV MARKET
ACHIEVED OVER SEVEN FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN SALES AND IS
EXPECTED TO REACH TWO BILLION
DOLLARS WENT DOWN BY TWENTY
TWENTY TO. EIGHTY FORTY FIVE
HAD WRITTEN PRESUMABLY
UNINTENTIONALLY MISSES OUT ON
AN OPPORTUNITY TO GENERATE MUCH
NEEDED ADDITIONAL TAX REVENUE.
FOR STATE SIMILAR TO HOW
CANISTER I CAN WHEN I CAN TAP
NOW. WHEN THE ATTACK SUCH AS
ONE TEN PER MILLIGRAM.
CANDLELIGHT CAN GENERATE OVER A
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
OR MORE PER YEAR IN STATE TAX
REVENUE. ACHIEVING TAX COMPARED
WITH CANADA CAN ONLY LEAVE THE
LEVEL COMPETITIVE MARKET PLACE
FOR ALL HUMANOIDS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR ORIGIN. AB FORTY FIVE
SHOULD BE AMENDED TO ALLOW FOR
THE TAX EXEMPT RIGHT CAN ONLY
PRODUCT AS WELL AS TO ALLOW THE
CANNABIS INDUSTRY TO
INCORPORATE HEMP DERIVED
CANNABINOID PRODUCTS WITHIN
THEIR SUPPLY CHAIN. TO ENSURE A
FAIR MARKET START PROMOTE THE
VIABILITY. OF BOTH THE HEMP AND
CANNABIS INDUSTRY WITHOUT THE
PROVISION CAMP RETAIL WOULD BE
ONLY REACH. IN THIS TO HAVE THE
FISCAL. ADDRESSING GONNA COMP.
WHAT THE RESPONSE MAN WILL PER.
PUBLIC HEALTH. RAISE MUCH
NEEDED TAX- REVENUES FROM THE-
AND PROMOTE THE VIBE. OF ALL
CAN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NUMBER
TO THE FOR LINE FOR- ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SOME. OR
OPPOSITION WILL JUST BE ASKING
FOR NAME. ANY ORGAN YOU
REPRESENT. AND YOUR POSITION
THE BILL WHENEVER YOU'RE I'M
OUT OF MY- THANK YOU YOUR
SUPPORT- OR OPPOSITION OF AB
FORTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AB. FORTY
FIVE. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
WAR SEVEN ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE SEVEN ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF SEVEN NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MANY OF THE CORPSMAN ON
THE HELP OF CHARLOTTE WEB IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE
LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ABOUT ONE OF SIX EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
ORIGINS COUNCIL ORIGINS COUNCIL
REPRESENTS LEGACY CULTIVATORS
IN THE COUNTIES OF TRINITY.
MENDOCINO NEVADA THE GNOMON IN
MONTEREY AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE FOR
THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. HELLO I KNOW THE
SEVEN THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU TO THE DOCUMENTS OVER
PEDIATRICIAN THEN- CLINICAL
PROFESSOR AT UCSF- WE ARE
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
WHICH WILL ALLOW ADULTERATION
OKAY WHO'S YOUR SUPPLEMENTS AND
EXPOSE CHILDREN TO C. B. AND
THC AND ARE IN. THE DOSAGE AS
WELL AS WESTERN SHE IN
REGULATION. THANK THANK YOU THE
NEW. NEXT CALLER PLEASE AND
JUST YOUR NAME AND OR ONLY.
THANK YOU SEVEN OH SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GRAYSON BRYANT
ON BEHALF OF THE HUMBOLDT
COUNTY GROWERS ALLIANCE WE ARE
OPPOSE UNLESS. TO ADDRESS THAT
TESTING AND SAFETY ISSUES I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WHAT THE
LINE OF FIVE SIX SEVENTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN A MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE ANY BERNACCHI ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNSEL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YOUR ORDER LINE
UP SIX SIXTY FIVE REALIZE OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS EVEN AFTER WITH
CAMPAIGN ADVISERS ON BEHALF OF
THE KRONOS GROUP IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FORTY FIVE. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO LINE UP SEVEN
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY
THE TARGET MARKET REPRESENTING
SOCIAL EQUITY LOS ANGELES IN
THE COACHELLA VALLEY APPLIANCE
NETWORK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WITH A
LINE OF SEVEN EIGHTEEN LINE IS
OPEN. MR CHAIR NUMBERS TO FIND
THE PLAN WITH VISORS ON BEHALF
OF THE CANOPY GROWTH
CORPORATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU ABOUT A LINE OF SIX
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MICHAEL LONG ENJOYS EMERALD. IN
OPPOSITION COMMENDED THANK YOU
THANK YOU THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. YOU ABOUT A LINE OF
SEVEN SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ADAM SHE
JACQUI I'M ON THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF THE LONG BEACH
COLLECTIVE ASSOCIATION AND WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION IN THE
COMMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE UP FOR
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS JONATHAN TACKLE
REPRESENTING THE SAN FRANCISCO
CANNABIS RETAILERS ALLIANCE AND
THE SANTA ANA CANNABIS
APPROPRIATIONS IN OPPOSITION
BABY FORTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE UP
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MANY WITH ORANGE JUICE
IS ROUSSIN POLICY RESEARCH
ASSOCIATE WORKING AT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE AND WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE FAMILY BILL
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER INFO AT THIS
TIME. VERY WELL THANK YOU BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. I JUST LIKE TO SAY
ONE THING THANK YOU- MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FORWARD I DO WANT TO KNOW
YOU REFERENCE THE- THE ANALYSIS
THERE'S HAS BEEN A SLIGHT
CHANGE TO IN THE ANALYSIS ON
PAGE SIX- SECTION ONE ONE ONE
NINE TWO ONE POINT FIVE WHERE
WE HAVE STRICKEN. THE WORDS AND
ONLY IF PERMITTED UNDER STATE
LAW AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT FOR THE RECORD- AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY- THE AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU'VE ACCEPTED- ENSURE
THAT DPH HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
REGULATE- IN OUR OPINION TEMP
CONSISTENT WITH CONSUMER
PROTECTION OF PUBLIC HEALTH. I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHATEVER PROHIBITIONS WE HAVE
ON TOBACCO- WOULD APPLY TO
SMOKABLE HEMP PRODUCTS- AND I
KNOW THAT YOU CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OPPOSITION MOVING
FORWARD- AND WORK WITH MY STAFF
AS WELL AND ADDITIONAL CHANGES
TO THIS BILL- AND THE- AT THIS
POINT WE DO HAVE A TO PASS AS
RECOMMENDED AS AS- AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS AND WOOD.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING UP THE MEMBERS
THAT WAS IMPORTANT BECAUSE OF
SOME OF THE THINGS CANCERS AT
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION HAVE.
AND THEN I JUST WONDERING PUTS
SOME PHOTO ONE OF THE OF
OPPOSITION SAID- THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT TAX HIM IS NOT
CANNABIS IT IS NOT THERE YET
INTOXICANT. SO COMPARING HIM TO
CANNABIS IS LIKE COMPARING NON
ALCOHOL BEER WELL WITH BEER.
AND SO WITH THAT I WOULD. JUST
LIKE TO CLOSE ENOUGH FOR YOU I
WILL. THE MUCH MISSING HERE. WE
HAVE A MO BY MISS ZERO. A
SECOND BY MYSTIC- THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT WITH
THE HIGH MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I BIGELOW. BURKE
BURKE HI CARILLO. LARA
MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY MCCARTY HI.
NAZARIAN. MISSOURIAN I REQUEST.
RODRIGUEZ SANTIAGO WALDRON
WALDRON HI CALDERON. CALDERON
HI. SEVEN ZERO NEED ONE SO ZERO
WILL BE THE BILL CALL MISS
MISSING- WE ARE SO COMMITTEE
WHICH I PART ARE YOU READY
MISTER MCCARTY YOU CAN GET OUR
SIGNATURE S. SO MISTER MAY JUST
FLEW IN HERE SO. THESE WELL
THAT. WELL YOU GO AHEAD S.
RECORD I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
BILL IT'S A- DISTRICT BILL
FOCUSED ON YOLO COUNTY WHICH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
AND I- REPRESENTS- FIRST OF ALL
THE THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
US AND WE WILL ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH I
THINK STRENGTH IN THE BILL. IN
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
AGAIN THIS IS A PILOT PROJECT
FOR YOLO COUNTY TO CREATE A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM A RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT PROGRAM CALLED HOPE
YOU ALL OF. THIS IS A PROGRAM
INDIVIDUALS CAN- GET- DRUG
TREATMENT AS OPPOSED TO BEING
INCARCERATED SO IT'S A CHOICE
SO IF AN INDIVIDUAL IS
SENTENCED FOR- FELONIES RELATED
TO THEIR- DRUG ADDICTION AGAIN
AS MR RODRIGUEZ SAID THERE ARE
THERE ARE NO VIOLENT FELONIES
OR- SEX RELATED CRIMES- FOR
THIS MEASURE- INDIVIDUALS WITH
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET A
TREATMENT RATHER THAN
INCARCERATION BECAUSE WE KNOW.
OUR STATE PRISON SYSTEM IN OUR
COUNTY JAILS DON'T HAVE A
ROBUST TREATMENT PROGRAM AND SO
OFTEN TIMES PEOPLE JUST CIRCLE
IN AND OUT AND NEVER GET THEIR
UNDERLYING DRUG TREATMENT-
ADDRESSED WE DO HAVE A PROBLEM
HERE IN OUR STATE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY GREAT SOLUTIONS TO WHAT WE
SEE PEOPLE CIRCLING THROUGH.
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS
NOT EQUIPPED FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH
ADDICTION AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDERS ARE NOT LIKELY TO BE
ADDRESSED IN OUR STATE AND
COUNTY INCARCERATION FACILITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA- WE DID
ACCEPT AMENDMENTS THAT STATE
THAT THIS- PROCESS NEEDS TO BE-
BASED ON SCIENCE AND OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THIS BASE
ARE. BASED UPON THE AMERICAN
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MEDICINE-
ONCE TREATMENT IS COMPLETED FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS ONCE THEY
CHOOSE TO DO THIS THEY'LL HAVE.
THE OPPORTUNITY HAVE THEIR
RECORDS EXPUNGED YEAH WE DO TOO
MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE LAW ON THE
STREET. DESPERATE THAT ADDRESS-
THERE NEEDS- THE ROCK
CALIFORNIA AND WITH ME TODAY IS
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF YOLO
COUNTY AS WELL AS A COMMUNITY
ADVOCATE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL MOVE ON TO OUR WITNESS
AND SUPPORT FOR THIS IS A
SUPPORT. ON THE TWO HUNDRED AND
DISTRICT ATTORNEY JEFF. THIS IS
DISTRICT ATTORNEY JEFF REISIG
OF YOLO COUNTY- TOO MANY PEOPLE
WHO SUFFER FROM SERIOUS
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS. ARE
GOING TO PRISONS AND JAILS.
TIMES ARE MOTIVATED BY THEIR
ADDICTION AND PRISONS AND JAILS
ARE SIMPLY NOT PLACES WHERE
PEOPLE. WHO ARE SICK. GO TO GET
BETTER. AND THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY STATUS. WE'RE SIMPLY
NOT HAVING A LOT OF LUCK IN
CALIFORNIA THE DRESSING THIS
POPULATION. THAT IS ESSENTIALLY
GOING IN AND OUT OF REVOLVING
DOOR. SO WOULD PETE BETWEEN
FORTY TO PROPOSES. IS A LOCAL
TREATMENT ALTERNATIVES PRISON
IN JAIL FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN CONVICTED OF FELONY
LEVEL CRIMES WHICH WERE
MOTIVATED. BINDER SERIES
ADDICTION TO DRUGS BUT
COMPOSED. TOO MUCH OF A RISK
FOR EXPOSURE TO SIMPLY RELEASE
THEM. INTO AN UNSECURED
RESIDENTIAL FACILITY IN THE
COMMUNITY. WHERE THEY CAN
SIMPLY WALK AWAY OR CRAWL OUT A
WINDOW ON DAY ONE. AND
POTENTIALLY CAUSE MORE HARM TO
THEMSELVES AND OTHERS. SO
INSTEAD EIGHTY FIFTEEN FORTY
TWO ENVISIONS CREATING A
SECURE. HOSPITAL LIKE TREATMENT
ENVIRONMENT WITHOUT JAILS IN
BARS AND GUARDS AND GUNS. THEY
CAN SERVE AS A SANCTUARY FOR
SERIOUSLY ADDICTED FELONY
OFFENDERS. WHO VOLUNTARILY
CHOOSE TO TRY LOCAL COMMUNITY
BASED TREATMENT AND WRAPAROUND
SERVICES. IN A SAFE AND SECURE
SAID SETTING INSTEAD OF MERELY
IN WAREHOUSE BEHIND BARS. WE
CALL THIS PLACE HOPE YELLOW.
WHAT ALSO MAKES THIS TREATMENT
ALTERNATIVE VIEWS NEED TO THE
DESIGN STAFF BY TREATMENT
PROVIDERS AND THEY WILL DECIDE.
WHO'S AN APPROPRIATE CANDIDATE
WHO IS NOT WHAT THE TREATMENT
SHOULD LOOK LIKE. AND FOR THOSE
WHO SUCCESSFULLY CHOOSING
COMPLETE THE TREATMENT PROGRAM-
INSTEAD OF PRISON OR JAIL THEY
WILL HAVE THEIR CONVICTIONS
EXPUNGED AND GET A CLEAN START.
RIGHT HERE AT HOME IN YOUR
ACCOUNTING. OKAY EIGHTY DID
FORTY THOUSAND MUCH PILOT. YOUR
ANNUAL- THAT IS DESIGNED TO
OPERATE VOLUNTARY TREATMENT
ALTERNATIVE. TO THOSE WHO ARE
OTHERWISE ON THEIR WAY TO
PRISON OR JAIL. I WOULD URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO GIVE THIS
PILOT PROGRAM A CHANCE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOVE
ONTO OUR NEXT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT
THE BROWN. OKAY ONE MOMENT
PLEASE OKAY YEAH I GOT IT HERE
IS AT THIRTY BROWN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN- THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND WEBER MCCARTY AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS
ASHLEY BROWN. AND I AM A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND I CURRENTLY
IN LIGHT OF THAT THE
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIAN
REGISTERED NURSE. CLICK HELP
NURSES AND IN ADDICTION
TREATMENT COUNSELOR- AND ANGER
MANAGEMENT FACILITATOR AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE. I ALSO
HOLD A DEGREE AND- SUCH AS AN
ARCHITECT IN THE FINANCE AND A
BACHELOR OF SCIENCE DEGREE IN
NURSING I'M CURRENTLY FULL TIME
EMPLOYED AS THE DIRECTOR OF
NURSING SERVICES. AT ALL THANK
YOU THE BILL ANY AS WELL AS A
PROFESSOR AT A LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. THE REASON WHY I
IDENTIFY AS THE FIRST IS PRIOR
TO ANY OF MY ACCOMPLISHMENT I
ALSO HAD THE PDP NUMBER AT
EIGHT SEVEN TWO SIX NINE NINE.
I SPENT FROM NINETEEN NINETY TO
TWO THOUSAND AND ONE IMPOSSIBLE
THE FACT THAT. OUR TRUCK ABOUT
CHUCKLE OUT OF POLITICS
PRESIDENT HAVE BEEN OFF THE
PRESIDENT. KERN VALLEY STATE
PRISON ACCOUNT FOR YOUR TICKET
BERMAN THE NAME OF CO I SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE HAD I BEEN
OFFERED THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM FOR
TO PICK YOUR TREATMENT BUT THE-
HAVING TO DO A- PROGRAM OF
PRIVATE PRISONS MAYBE THE
OUTCOME. WILL BE CONTINUED TO
RETURN BACK TO FOR THE PRETTY
GOOD MIGHT HAVE BEEN DIFFERENT
I DO KNOW THAT WE GET FROM
WHERE WHAT WHERE I'M AT NOW-
THERE WAS NO EXPUNGEMENT MY
RECORD I HAD TO GO TOO MANY-
COURT APPEARANCES DEAL WITH.
SOME OF THE THINGS AND I CAN
TAKE COMPLETE RESPONSIBILITY OF
WHAT IT IS THAT I DID DEAL
HOWEVER I WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
PROGRAM BACK TO THE ONE OFTEN
AND EIGHTY FIFTEEN FORTY TWO.
TWO AT THE OTHER INDIVIDUAL
COMPUTER GET THEIR LIFE BACK IN
ORDER I'M NOT HAPPY ABOUT K.
POP WROTE AS I DID I REALLY
BELIEVE IN WHAT YOU ARE GOING
UP THERE ARE NONE CURRENTLY
REPORTED BILL. THANK. YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PARTICIPATE.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MICHAEL
PRITCHARD AND I'M SPEAKING AS
THE LEGISLATIVE CHAIR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS- I AM A PERSON IN
LONG TERM RECOVERY FROM
ADDICTION AND MENTAL ILLNESS
AND I'M ALSO FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PERSONS- SHE GOT
ALREADY SUBMITTED IN
OPPOSITION. LETTER TO THIS BILL
BUT I WOULD LIKE I'D LIKE SOME
ADDITIONAL POINTS OF
OPPOSITION. THE FIRST POINT OF
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IS THE
TERM PILOT PROGRAM- MENTAL
HEALTH STD TREATMENT HAVE
OPERATED IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SETTINGS FOR DECADES AND
THERE'S REALLY NO STRONG
EVIDENCE OF LONG TERM POSITIVE
RESULTS. BECAUSE THERE'S NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO CREATE A SAFE
THERAPEUTIC ATMOSPHERE INSIDE
OF THE FOURTH LOCKDOWN
FACILITY. LOCKDOWN TREATMENT IS
PUNISHMENT EVEN IF IT HAS A
TREATMENT LEGAL. DURING THE WAR
ON DRUGS PEOPLE WHO. PEOPLE ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY-
INCARCERATED FOR ADDICTION
ISSUES AND MAINLY. ETHNIC
MINORITY. WITH THE ADVENT OF
THE ODS WAY FOR CALIFORNIANS
MOVED AWAY FROM COURSE OF- CARE
AND ARBITRARY TREATMENT- I'M
TYPING TO TURN. ALTHOUGH THE-
FIRST AMENDMENT USES THE TERM
ASEM ASEM CONTINUUM DOES NOT
HAVE A LOCKDOWN LEVEL OF CARE
IN ADDITION THE STRUCTURE
DESCRIPTION OF THE PROGRAM IS
TAKING THE BILL WITH NO MENTION
OF WEBSITE INTO T. WILL AUDIT
FOR COMPLIANCE WITH BEST
PRACTICES. IN THE SYSTEM
CURRENTLY ADMISSION TO ANY
LEVEL OF TREATMENT BASED SOLELY
ON THE DETERMINATION OF MEDICAL
NECESSITY ACCORDING TO THE DSM
AND THE SECRETARY. SHE GAP IS
CONCERNED THAT AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY TO CREATE UNPARALLELED
ABILITY FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES T. INFLUENCE MEDICAL
DECISION MAKING TO CREATE THE
DESIRED OUTCOME OF LOCKING UP
PROBLEM PETTY OFFENDERS. THE
BILL EXCLUDES VIOLENT CRIME
HIGH LEVEL FELONIES SEX
OFFENDERS. THOSE WHO PUBLIC
ACTUAL POTENTIAL FOR PHYSICAL
HARMS IN OUR COMMUNITY AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO IS A NEW WAY
TO INCARCERATE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CAUSING ECONOMIC HARM ENDPOINTS
TO THEIR COMMUNITIES IN THE
FORM OF THAT. VANDALISM
LOITERING DISORDERLY CONDUCT
THE HOMELESSNESS. OTHER CHRONIC
DISEASES SUCH AS UNCONTROLLED
DIABETES AND OBESITY AND
OBESITY COSTS OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS TREMENDOUS TREMENDOUSLY
IMPACT ALL OF US ECONOMICALLY
SHOULD WE IMPRISON THESE PEOPLE
WITH THESE MEDICAL ISSUES UNTIL
THEY LEARN TO MANAGE THEM
PROPERLY IN ORDER TO. SAVE
HUMANITY STRONGER ECONOMIC HARM
THEY POSE. SHE CAN'T BELIEVE
THAT AB FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO IS A
CLEAR VIOLATION OF THE SPIRIT
OF THE ODS WEAVER A PERSON'S
RIGHT TO SELF DETERMINATION.
AND IS A RETURN TO INEFFECTIVE
HARMFUL DISCRIMINATORY
PRACTICES OF DEALING WITH THE.
DISEASE DETECTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE WITNESS.
GOOD EVENING WAY AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME CALORIES
IN L. MACHINE STAFF WITH DRUG-POLICY- ALLIANCE. THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO THE
COMMITTEE CAN KNOW IS THAT THIS
BILL IS OPPOSED BY EVERY STATE
TREATMENT ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA. PROFESSIONALS AND
PEOPLE IN RECOVERY WHO HAVE
DEVOTED THEIR LIVES TO HELPING
PEOPLE WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS OPPOSE THIS BILL. THE
SIGN DID NOT SUPPORT THE
EFFICACY. OF COMMERCE TREATMENT
IN LOCKED FACILITIES. WE DO NOT
DISAGREE. THAT SHOULD BE TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
HOWEVER EIGHTY FIFTEEN FORTY TO
REPRESENT AND MISGUIDED
APPROACH PROJECT PREVENTING
SERIOUS INJURIES AND WILL BE A
MAJOR STEP BACKWARD. IT
DESCRIBED AS THE PILOT I KNEW I
KNEW IDEA WE'RE TESTING. BUT
IT'S NOT A NEW IDEA IT'S
SOMETHING WE'VE TRIED
UNSUCCESSFULLY FOR NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED YEARS. RESEARCH
SPANNING DECADES HAS FAILED TO
DEMONSTRATE THE EFFICACY OF
COMMERCE TREATMENT AND
ESPECIALLY JOHN INEFFECTIVENESS.
AND CRYSTAL SET. WHAT WORKS IT
ITS AFFORDABLE ACCEPT SERVICE
IN THE COMMUNITY. WITHOUT
COMMUNITY BASED CARE THERE IS
NO SUCCESS WE DON'T NEED A NEW
JAIL LIKE SETTING TO DO THAT.
WHICH TREATMENT VIOLATES THE
FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN RIGHT TO
BODILY AUTONOMY AND PRIVACY IN
HEALTH DECISION. COURSE
TREATMENT CAN DAMAGE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN TREATMENT
PROVIDER AND RECIPIENT. AND
FURTHER TRAUMATIZED INDIVIDUALS
WHO OFTEN EXPERIENCE SEVERE
HARDSHIP DIMINISHING THE
LIKELIHOOD OF SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOMES FROM THE CURRENT
TREATMENT AS WELL AS ENGAGEMENT
AND FUTURE HEALTH SERVICES.
THIS BILL WOULD PLAY HEALTH
DECISIONS IN THE HANDS OF
JUDGES AND PROSECUTORS RATHER
THAN TREATMENT PROFESSIONALS.
WE ALSO FEAR EIGHTY FIFTEEN
FORTY TWO WILL BE APPLIED IN A
DISCRIMINATORY MANNER. AND
THEIR NATION RECKONS WITH
POLICING AND HAVE LONG COURSE
INSTEAD THE EFFECTS ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IS HIGHLY
INAPPROPRIATE TO PURSUE
POLICIES THAT ONLY GIVE MORE
LEVERAGE TO POLICE AND
PROSECUTORS. IN A PROFESSIONAL
RECOMMEND MOVING AWAY FROM
COERCION TOWARDS APPROACHES
THAT WORK INCLUDING ROBERT YOUR
COMMUNITY TREATMENT MEDICATIONS
FOR OPIOID USE DISORDER. HARM
REDUCTION SOBERING CENTERS AND
OUTREACH. THE EVIDENCE FOR
PROVIDING INCENTIVES TO ENGAGE
PEOPLE IN THREE MINUTES ROBUST.
UNLIKE THE EVIDENCE CARE
COERCED TREATMENT. EIGHTY
FIFTEEN FORTY TWO WITH THE
TRACK FROM THE VETERANS AND
DIVERT RESOURCES THAT COULD BE
BETTER USED IN THE COMMUNITY.
RECOGNIZING ALL THE DANGERS
EIGHTY FIFTEEN FORTY TWO THE
BALLOT BY ALL THE MAJOR SEVENTY
DISORDER TREATMENT
ORGANIZATIONS. AS WELL AS
CRIMINAL JUSTICE RACIAL JUSTICE
AND HUMAN RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS.
WE STAND WITH ALL THE
ORGANIZATIONS AND FOR
OPPOSITION THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT- TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST
NAME ORGANIZATION IF YOU
REPRESENT ONE IN YOUR POSITION
ON THE BILL. WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY MADAM OPERATOR ALL. THANK
YOU IF YOU ARE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THE
END ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE SEVEN TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HOLDING
THE SHARON WE HAVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU WILL GO TO LINE UP FOR
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR SURE NUMBER
COUNTY DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU ABOUT
THE LINE OF SIX THIRTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CAMERA HUMANA BUT THE ORANGE
COUNTY RECOVERY COLLABORATION
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
Q. WHAT THE LINE UP FOR FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BOBBLING
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL BE A
GREAT HELP AGENCIES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. DO YOU WORK OUT
THE LINE UP SIX SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- BACK FROM THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA NOT POSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. HE WILL WRITE A LINE OF
SIX SIX SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE GENERAL MEMBER
SUBSCRIBER TERRORISTS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU ACROSS
THE UP SEVEN THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL GUTIERREZ
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WHERE
DO I SEVEN TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. REBECA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
LEFT IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MISTER CALDERON- YES
THE KID IS SOMEONE MCCARTY
PLEASE RESPOND TO SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION'S. QUESTIONS. PLEASE
GO AHEAD YEAH SO I TRY TO TAKE
A LOT OF NOTES THERE AND IT IS
GOINGTO DRESS IN THIS IN THE
CLOTHES I THINK WE CAN HERE I
JUST THINK THIS IS- A RESPONSE
TO WHAT'S HAPPENING CALIFORNIA
THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS NOT
WORKING WE HAVE A REVOLVING
DOOR OF PEOPLE WHO ARE ARRESTED
FOR CRIMES RELATED THEIR DRUG
ADDICTION- CERTAINLY WE SEE IN
OUR STREETS RIGHT OUT HERE
OUTSIDE THE CAPITOL ON K.
STREET NOT ALL. INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE HOMELESS ARE HAVE A
DRUG ADDICTION PROBLEMS ARE
THEY COMMITTING CRIMES BUT
THERE'S- A STAG GREAT PARALLEL
YOU KNOW TRY FACT WITH ALL
THESE ISSUES AND YOU KNOW THE
VOLUNTARY COMMUNITY TREATMENT
SYSTEM ISN'T QUITE WORKING AND
I JUST WNT TO ADDRESS THE
FALLACY THAT THEY PUT HERE IS
THAT THE NOTION THAT IF SOMEONE
DOESN'T GO TO THIS TREATMENT
THEY CAN GO TO THEIR COMMUNITY
THEY CAN GO AT HOME ON THEIR
COUCH AND WITH AN ANKLE
BRACELET AND EVERYTHING YOU
KNOW CAN BE FINE AND DANDY NOW
THIS SAYS. WHATEVER THE
EXISTING CRIMES ARE CALIFORNIA
AND I CAN HELP WORK ON LAWS TO-
YOU KNOW REDUCE EFFECTIVE
DEFENSES THAT THEY BECOME
INCARCERATION BASED IT SAYS
WHATEVER THE EXISTS BEFORE
YOU'RE SENTENCED AN INDIVIDUAL
CAN HAVE A CHOICE YOU CAN GO
AND GET- TREATMENT AT THIS
FACILITY- OR YOU CAN GO TO-
COUNTY JIL OR PRISON AND SO
YOU KNOW WE GIVE PEOPLE A
CHOICE- THERE ALSO IS AN OPT
OUT CLAUSE SOME SOME YOU KNOW
WOULD SAY THAT. IF YOU WORK YOU
ARE FORCING THEM IN AND THEY
DON'T HAVE AN OPTION TO BACK
OUT WELL AFTER THE LAST
COMMITTEE PUBLIC SAFETY WE
CLARIFIED THAT ONCE AN
INDIVIDUAL ENTERS THIS- SECURED
RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT FACILITY
IF DAY OR THE PROVIDER I THINK
THIS IS NOT A GOOD FIT THEY CAN
OPT OUT YOU KNOW WHERE THEY'RE
GONNA GO OPT OUT TO BACK TO
PRISON THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GO
BACK TO THE COMMUNITY YOU KNOW
THAT THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS.
THAT THE QUIRKS DEAN THAT OUR-
BASED UPON THEIR CENTER OR NOT-
DEEM TO BE- ABLE TO BE
RELEASING THE COMMUNITIES
THERE'S GONNA SOME TYPE OF AN-
CARS. AND THEN YOU KNOW LASTLY
THAT- YOU KNOW. COVERS AND
FIRST FOUR SCORES AND YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES PEOPLE IS THE ROCK
BOTTOM. SOMETIME THAT'S WHY
THEY HAVE INTERVENTION WHEN A
FAMILY MEMBER GETS TOGETHER AND
pTREATMENT THAT'S WHAT IT IS
IT'S COERCION. WHEN WE HAVE-
DIVERSION PROGRAMS WE SAID DRUG
COURTS THE COURT MANDATES DOT
DRUG TREATMENT- THOSE- YOU KNOW
WORK FOR INDIVIDUALS MAY TIMES
NOT FOR EVERYBODY BUT WHAT'S
THE ALTERNATIVE. NOTHING
WORKING. NOTHING WORKING AND
SO- YOU KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I THINK THAT IT'S A PILOT.
IT'S IN ONE COUNTY IF IT WORKS
WE CAN REPLICATE ELSEWHERE IF
IT DOESN'T WORK. WHAT'S THE
HARM YOU KNOW THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IS THAT IS NOT WORKING
FOR SO MANY COMMUTES AROUND
CALIFORNIA I THINK THIS IS
WORTH THE CHANCE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO- ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE. OKAY THANK YOU. HI
MISTER NAZARIAN AND I'M SORRY
MISS WALDRON WAS FOR SITE MY
GOD SO. OKAY GOOD- YES YOU- SO
THE BILL. JUST QUICKLY FROM
HONG THE BILL REQUIRES THAT AT
THE TIME OF SENTENCING. IF THE
JUDGE MUST OFFER THE DEFENDANT
VOLUNTARY PARTICIPATION IN THE
PILOT PROGRAM AS AN ALTERNATIVE
TO JAIL. OR PRISON SENTENCE
THAT THE JUDGE WOULD OTHERWISE
IMPOSE IF THERE'S CERTAIN
CONDITIONS ARE MET- IT SO THE
VOLUNTARY PROCESS HOW DOES THAT
ACTUALLY WORKS WITH THE JUDGE
WOULD. OFFER THAT DURING THE
SENTENCING AND THEN. YEAH IT
WOULDN'T BE FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
I THINK THIS IS BASED UPON THE
EVALUATIONS WITH MEDICAL
EXPERTS AND IF WE COULD IF I
COULD ALLOW D. A. R.REISIG TO-
TAKE TO GO TO DETAIL ABOUT THIS
ISSUE. YEAH ARE YOU STILL
ONLINE MYSTERY SIX. YES I AM
AND THE ANSWER THAT QUESTION IS
TIME OF SENTENCING IF THERE'S
SOME INDICATION BY ANY OF THE
PARTIES THAT THE SUSPECT THAT
THE INDIVIDUAL SUFFERS FROM A
SERIOUS SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDER. THEY CAN BE REFERRED
OUT FOR AN ASSESSMENT BY HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES BY THE
EXPERTS AND THE WAY THE BILL IS
WRITTEN AS IF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES RECOMMENDS TREATMENT
THAT THIS PERSON WOULD BENEFIT.
THEN THE JUDGE WOULD THEN BE
EMPOWERED TO OFFER THE PERSON
THE TREATMENT ALTERNATIVES.
INSTEAD OF PRISON OR JAIL. AND
IF THE PERSON CHOSE THE
TREATMENT ALTERNATIVE. OF THE
PROGRAM WHICH WILL CALL HOPE
YOU'LL THE WOULD BE COMPLETELY
CONTROLLED BY HELP AND- HELP
THE AND HUMAN SERVICES. OKAY
AND- I MEAN WE ALL KNOW THE
CITIZENS WE'VE HEARD THEM TIME
AND TIME AGAIN ABOUT- THE HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
LANGUISHING IN OUR PRISONS AND
JAILS RIGHT NOW I'M NOT GETTING
THE TREATMENT THAT THEY NEED.
ONLY TO BE RELEASED AGAIN WE
KNOW THAT 95% OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN PRISON WILL BE RELEASED.
MOSTLY WITHOUT TREATMENT
WITHOUT- THE NEEDED PROGRAMS.
AND THE ONLY TO RESERVOIRS
AGAIN SO I MEAN. WE HAVE TO
COME TO A POINT WHERE JUST
PUTTING PEOPLE IN PRISON OR IN
JAIL AND SERVING TIME IS NOT
THE SOLUTION TO THE PROBLEM IS
WE REALLY NEED TO DEAL WITH THE
ROOT OF THE PROBLEM WHICH IS
THE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER AND
THE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. THAT
PEOPLE ARE FACING THAT CAUSE
THEM TO GET INTO THE IN CAR
SCHOOL SYSTEM SO I AM
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER. I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE IT CALM AND SEE HOW I
THE OFFER WORK IN THIS AREA.
AND TO ALL- POINT NOW THAT WE
WERE SENT OUR- VOTERS TO MAKE A
NAME. AND SO PROBLEMS FOR A
DISTRICT. AND WE UNIQUELY. SOME
TO BE ABLE TO SEE THE ISSUES-
FROM THE THIRTY THOUSAND FEET
VIEW THAT WE GET THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO HAVE. AND I
VERY MUCH COMMEND. YOU WANTING
TO STEP IN AND TAKE THIS
CHALLENGE ON AND TO TRY TO
SOLVE THIS ISSUE- AND TO BRING
ALL THE RIGHT PLAYERS. FRANKLY
TO HELP SUPPORT YOUR- EFFORTS
SO- I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL AND I KNOW IT'S A PILOT
PROJECT AND IT'S ONLY FOR YOUR
COUNTY. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
ANYONE ELSE. SEE NO ONE- THE
BILL DOES ENJOY IT TO PASS AS A
MAN AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS YOU HAVE
ACCEPTED THE AMENDMENTS- WHICH
I CLOSE WHICH MCCARTY THANK YOU
KNOW I ENJOY THE- TO
CONVERSATION FORM MY COLLEAGUES
HERE AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPOSITION THESE ARE GROUPS
THAT I'VE WORKED WITH ON SO
MANY ISSUES SO IT'S SOMEWHAT
DIFFICULT TO GO OUTSIDE OF YOUR
COMFORT ZONE. BUT THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY BECAUSE THE STATUS
QUO JUST IS NOT IS NOT WORKING
IS NOT SUSTAINABLE. AND I THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR WORKING
WITH US AND- THAT I ASK FOR YOU
RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU- DO
WE HAVE A MOTION. MOVED THE
BILL. COME FROM A MOTION BY
MISTER IS AIRING A SECOND BY
MISS BURKE- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT BY
WHAT I MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
BIGELOW. BURKE THIRTY FIVE
THREO. LARA. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN ONLINE MCCARTY HI
MCCARTY HI THIS AREA THIS AREA
AND I RIVAS. RIVERSIDE
RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO WALDRON
WALDRON HIGH CALDERON CALDERON
HI. EIGHT ZERO YOU HAVE A VOTES
YOUR BILLS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHER STAND ON THANK
YOU MR MCCARTY. MR MAIENSCHEIN.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MENTAL HEALTH
IS AN IMPORTANT ASPECT OF
HEALTHCARE THAT IS OFTEN
OVERLOOKED ESPECIALLY IN
CHILDREN AND MOTHERS ONE IN
FIVE WOMEN WILL BE AFFECTED BY
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER DURING
PREGNANCY OR WITHIN THE FIRST
YEAR OF GIVING BIRTH AND THE
PREVALENCE OF MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES IN CHILDREN HAS BEEN
RISING. EVEN BEFORE THE CALVET
NINETEEN CRISIS. THERE ARE GAPS
IN DIAGNOSING AND TREATING
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS AND SHORT OF A-
SHORTAGE OF PROVIDERS. WITH THE
APPROPRIATE KNOWLEDGE AND
EXPERIENCE THE IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC HAS EXACERBATED THIS
THESE ISSUES. EARLY IN
APPROPRIATE DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT HAS BEEN PROVEN TO
MITIGATE MORE SERIOUS MENTAL
THE OCCURRENCE OF DEPRESSION.
AB NINE THREE FIVE WOULD
ADDRESS THAT SHORTAGE OF
PSYCHIATRISTS. AND INCREASING
PREVALENCE OF MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS AND MOTHERS AND
CHILDREN. REQUIRING HEALTH
PLANS TO MAKE AVAILABLE
PROVIDER TO PROVIDER TELEPHONE
AND VIDEO MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION. THIS CONSULTATION
FINAL SUPPORT PROVIDERS IN
BUILDING THE CAPACITY TO
DIAGNOSE AND TREAT THESE
DISORDERS. EXPERT EYE CARE TO
PATIENTS AND ELIMINATE
UNNECESSARY APPOINTMENTS AND
REDUCED HEALTH CARE COSTS. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
JOIN THE OVER SEVENTY
ORGANIZATIONS AND SUPPORT. AND
BOEING I ON THIS IMPORTANT
MENTAL HEALTH LEGISLATION. ON
THE PHONE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. OF CRYSTAL MCCAULEY.
AND DOCTOR PAY TRAFFIC
STEINBERG. THE DIRECTOR
PSYCHIATRY AT UCSF. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM OPERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINE FOR WITH
THE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. GOOD EVENING CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES COURSE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU THANK YOU MY
NAME IS COOPER MCCAULEY AND
ANOTHER ISSUE. PROVIDING IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WHEN I GAVE
BIRTH TO MY FIRST SON IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN I DID NOT
KNOW I WAS AN INCREASED RISK OF
DEVELOPING A MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH COMPLICATIONS BECAUSE OF
RISK FACTORS LIKE A FIRE EATING
DISORDER. AND A FAMILY HISTORY
OF DEPRESSION. I NOW KNOW THAT
ONE IN FIVE CALIFORNIA BIRDS
WILL RESULT IN A MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH COMPLICATION. IT
IS IN FACT THE MOST. COMMON
COMPLICATION OF CHILDBIRTH. I
NOT KNOW THE MICHAEL. THE
TICKET NUMBER COULD YOU SEE
SECTION DEEMED. WHEN MY SON'S
HEART CANNOT TOLERATE THE DEATH
CLOSE MY WAS GIVEN TO MOVE MY
LABOR. MY RESULT IN THE MENTAL
HEALTH COMP. LIKE POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER. THIS IS A
CONDITION THAT IN MY CASE HATED
PROFESSIONAL INTERVENTIONS
PROCTER. AND LEARN NEW COPING
MECHANISMS JUST TO GET THROUGH
MY DAY. THURMOND PLAYED. COUNTY
INTRUSIVE THOUGHTS. AND VISIT.
FLASH NOT ONLY WAS I UNAWARE OF
THE RANGE OF THESE COMMON
DISORDERS OR THE RISK FACTORS
THE MY POSITION BUT NOT PLEASE
KNOW MUCH ABOUT THEM EITHER. I
FINALLY GOT ON THE ABOUT HOW
MUCH I WAS TO A FRIEND WOULD
OPEN ABOUT HER- OWN MENTAL
STRUGGLE AND SHE ENCOURAGED ME
TO OPEN UP TO MY DOCTOR. SINCE
I WAS ONLY A FEW MONTHS
POSTPARTUM I MADE AN
APPOINTMENT WITH MY OB AFTER
ALL EVERYTHING I WAS FEELING
SURROUNDED MY PREGNANCY AND MY
FOR. MY WE LET YOU KNOW THAT
WHILE SHE WAS SHE EMPHASIZED
HOW HARD THINGS HAVE BEEN FOR
ME SHE WAS NOT A MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL AND WAS NOT
COMFORTABLE MANAGING MENTAL
HEALTH MEDICATION. I WOULD NEED
TO BE REFERRED TO A
PSYCHIATRIST. I GOT FOR MY
HEALTH INSURANCE PLAN DOCUMENT
THE LEARNED THAT THERE WAS NO
PSYCHIATRIST WHO SPECIALIZES IN
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH. IN MY
AREA OR ON MY PLAN. I OPTED TO
SEE THE FOR PSYCHIATRIST LIKE
TO GET A- OF THE HAD AN OPEN.
THE DOCTOR DID AGREED I NEEDED.
TO MANAGE MY ANGER AND AN
ABILITY TO SLEEP. BUT HE WAS
NOT COMFORTABLE PRESCRIBE
MEDICATIONS TO LACTATING. HE
WOULD NEED TO REACH OUT TO MY
OB TO FIND OUT WHAT MEDICATIONS
WOULD BE SAYING. THEY WOULD BE
NINE WEEKS UNTIL THE TIME I
MADE MY INITIAL OBSTETRICIAN
APPOINTMENT TO OPEN UP ABOUT MY
SUFFERING TO ACTUALLY HAVING. A
MEDICATION PRESCRIBED TO TRY TO
HELP ME WITH MY SYMPTOMS. THANK
YOU TO MY OB OR PSYCHIATRIST
HAD ACCESS TO REGION EXPERTS ON
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH IN REAL
TIME. THEY COULD HAVE REDUCED
MY COVERING AND THAT OF MY
FAMILY GREAT. I YOU FOR
SUPPORTING THE AND FAMILIES
CALIFORNIA BY SUPPORTING EIGHTY
NINE THIRTY FIVE TODAY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MOVE ONTO OUR
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. HELLO MY
NAME IS DR PEDRO TIME BUSHEL I
MUCH NOT ALLOWED TO CATER TO
THE DIRECTOR OF THE UCSF
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY PORTAL.
WE CURRENTLY PROVIDE
CONSULTATION TO PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS IN OVER TEN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES AND GROWING.
THE TURN ON MENTAL HEALTH
DISORDERS IMPACT UP TO ONE IN
FIVE MOTHERS. AND SIMILARLY ONE
IN FIVE CHILDREN WITH
MATHEMATICA ESTIMATED ECONOMIC
COST TO CALIFORNIA TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION A YEAR. NATIONAL
ECONOMIC CULTURE ESTIMATED TO
BE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN BILLION A YEAR. AS YOU
HEARD COMPLAINTS OF THE STORY
WE HAVE A FRAGMENTED AND
COMPLEX MENTAL HEALTH DELIVERY
SYSTEM. WITH SEVERE MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDER SHORTAGES
INCLUDING PSYCHIATRISTS. OUR
SYSTEM WITH MOTHERS AND
FAMILIES SEARCHING FOR CARE AND
THERE MUST BROKEN MOMENT.
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY FIVE THE
MOTHERS AND CHILDREN MENTAL
HEALTH SUPPORT ACT PROVIDES A
BETTER WAY. MODELED AFTER THE
EVIDENCE BASED MASSACHUSETTS
HEALTHCARE ACTIVE PROGRAM. IN
SIMILAR STATEWIDE THE PATRIARCH
OF PROGRAMS THE OVER THIRTY
THREE. EIGHTY NINE THIRTY FIVE
WOULD PROVIDE PRIMARY
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS TO CARE
FOR CHILDREN AND PREGNANT. AND
POSTPARTUM WOMEN THE ABILITY TO
CONSULT WITH A MENTAL HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS. INCLUDING
EDUCATORS. ABOUT THE PATIENT.
BUT BOTH OF AN EIGHT TREATMENT
OPTIONS INCLUDING TAKE A
THERAPY AND. THINKFACTORY
PROVIDING REAL SUPPORT TO FROM.
PROVIDERS THE- INCREASE THE
CAPACITY TO MANAGE BASIC
DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY
RESERVING LIMITED AVAILABILITY
OF MENTAL HEALTH IS THAT FOR
MORE COMPLEX PRESENTATIONS. FOR
EXAMPLE RECENTLY WE WERE ABLE
TO CONSULT WITH THE
PEDIATRICIAN THE PATIENT WOULD
HAVE FALLEN THROUGH THE CRACKS
BETWEEN THE REGIONAL CENTER
SCHOOL AND MENTAL HEALTH AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
THE TWELVE YEAR OLD BOY THE
FOUNDING VIçT AND A RARE
GENETIC DISORDER CALLED GREATER
WELLINGTON ROAD HAD BECOME
INCREASINGLY AGGRESSIVE IN THE
CONTEXT OF QUARANTINE BRENT
CRUDE UP WALK IN THE ON BUT IF
YOU READY. MIGHT OTHERWISE HAVE
WAITED SEVERAL MONTHS FOR
TREATMENT PUTTING A FAMILY
ONGOING PHYSICAL WRECK A
SIGNIFICANT EMOTIONAL DISTRESS
OR. MADE HIM AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. IT'S TIME TO GET
SOME TO OR EARLY BACK. AND I TO
CARE TO. MCCARTY THREE TO.
MOTHER NATURE. WE CAN THAT. BY
POWERING FROM MICHAEL. THE CARE
FOR THEIR- I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT SB NINETY FIVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES IN OFFICE. NUMBER
WALKING DOWN BEHALF WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
INSURANCE COMPANIES
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY FIVE. BUT WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE INTENT
OF THE BILL AND I UNDERSTAND
THE DESIRE OF THE AUTHOR HAS TO
ENSURE CALL IN RELEASING
INSURERS HAVE IMMEDIATE ACCESS
TO CARE. WE ARE CONCERNED WITH
THE REQUIREMENT ON HEALTH PLANS
AND INSURERS HAVE A
PSYCHIATRIST AND A RECOGNITION
AVAILABLE TO CONSULT WITH
POSITIONS. THAT NOT ONLY
CONCERNING WITH RESPECT TO THE
POTENTIAL ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN
AND I KNOW COST IMPLICATIONS
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY AS NOTED
BY PITTSBURGH ANNOUNCES THAT
THE LACK OF EVIDENCE THAT THIS
MANDATE WILL RESULT IN BETTER
PATIENT OUTCOMES. AS YOU KNOW
WHILE I REMEMBER STRIVE TO
INCORPORATE EVIDENCE BASED CARE
THANK YOU NOT DIRECTLY ENGAGE
IN THE PRACTICE OF MEDICINE BY
LOCATING IT BY HER DECISION.
ARE EATING ON HOW DO I SET I
THEIR PAY. BY ADDRESSING THIS
OF. EIGHTY NINE THIRTY FIVE.
PRESUMABLY BECAUSE BACK TO BUY
A PLACE HELP PLANS AND INSURERS
IN THE BUSINESS AT THE- MEDICAL
PRACTICE. FURTHERMORE AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT YOU
BURKE ANALYSIS AT EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY FIVE WHICH POINT TO
NASA'S. DONE IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. REGARDING EIGHTY
SIXTEEN SIX AN ALMOST IDENTICAL
BILL WHICH IS HELD IN
APPROPRIATE. FOUND THAT THERE
IS LIMITED EVIDENCE ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF PSYCHIATRIC HE
CONSULATES GENERALLY AN
INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF PSYCHIATRIC
ECON PUTS THE TYPICALLY FOR
CHILDREN AND BECAUSE PART IN
PERSON. ONE POINT MAJOR WHEN I
TO KNOW. THAT THERE LIMITED
EVIDENCE SHOWING THAT
PSYCHIATRIC A CONSOLE- ARE
ACTIVE AND IMPROVING
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT OF MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS AS MEASURED
BY IMPROVEMENTS IN THE RECEIPT
OF MORE APPROPRIATE CARE.
MENTAL HEALTH OUTCOMES IN
PATIENTS PROVIDER KNOWLEDGE AND
SKILL DEVELOPMENT FOR MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT PROVIDER
SATISFACTION AND TIMELINESS OF
SERVICES. LEAVING US WITH THE
QUESTION GIVEN THE CURRENT
UNCERTAINTY SURROUNDING OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AS WE
COLLECTIVELY CONTINUE TO FACE
THE COMPANY NINETEEN PANDEMIC
TOGETHER. IS THIS THE RIGHT
TIME TO IMPOSE ADDITIONAL
MANDATE ON OUR SYSTEMS. AND
MORE IN THIS A PROVEN EFFECTIVE
EVIDENCE BASED POLICY THAT WILL
FUNDAMENTALLY BRING ADDITIONAL
VALUE TO THE PATIENTS WE ARE
SEEKING TO PRIORITIZE.
REGRETTABLY WE DON'T THINK THE
EVIDENCE BASED ANALYSIS SHOWS
THAT IT IT AND FOR THAT REASON
WE MUST. RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY FIVE. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NAY WITNESS
PLEASE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PRESTON YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE TODAY ALSO AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION EIGHTY NINE THIRTY
FIVE DISTINCT BREVITY INTO
AVOID REDUNDANCY I WILL SAY- WE
DO AGREE WITH FIRST WITH AT
THIS BLOCK AND SENTIMENTS I
WILL ALSO INDICATE FROM- THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE'S PERSPECTIVE. WE ARE
CONCERNED FROM ACROSS STATE TO
PROTON THAT. THIRTY ONE NOW
WITH YOU MANDATE- WILL COME
ALONG WITH THAT THEN INCREASE
IN HEALTHCARE COSTS INTO THE
SUBURBAN OUT THIS PERTAINING TO
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY FIVE THE
STATE THAT THE BILL WILL
INCREASE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
WELL THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
MAYBE NINE THIRTY FIVE MAYBE
SMALL ON ITS OWN WHICH I'M MORE
THAN WILLING TO. ADMIT AND
ACCEPT IT HAVE TO BE TAKEN IN
CONTACT WITH THE OTHER BENEFIT
MANDATES THAT HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED THROUGHOUT THE
COURSE OF THIS YEAR
COLLECTIVELY THEY DO INCREASE
PREMIUMS AND HEALTHCARE COSTS
FOR EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES.
WELL IN IN I. THIRTY FIVE
CERTAINLY ADDRESS AN IMPORTANT.
I'M OPEN REMAIN COGNISANT OF
THE CUMULATIVE IMPACT THESE
MANDATE DO YOU HAVE A GREAT THE
HEALTHCARE COSTS UPWARDS. BUT
THAT BEING SAID WE SUPPORT THE
EXPANSION OF TELEHEALTH IN
GENERAL CONCEPT. EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY FIVE SOMETHING REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH REMOVED THE
PHONE LINES FOR. A WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR
NAME POSITION. AND ORGANIZATION
OF PEOPLE LONG TO ONE. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MADAM MADAM
OPERATOR. THANK YOU OUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. OF.
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF FOUR FOUR THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIRTY
BEING THE FUTURE RICARDO
CARDINAL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT AND LOOK
FOR THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORTING CONCEPT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU ABOUT THE LINE UP FOR
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FRANKEN'S ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
PHYSICIANS NINE OH TEN AND A
CALIFORNIA TELEHEALTH NETWORK
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL
GO UP THE LINE OF SIX OH FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE CHEN HAMPTON
CALIFORNIA THAT THEY SENT
HEALTH PLAN- RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WHAT A LINE UP FIVE OH
ONE YOUR LINES OPEN. GOOD
EVENING THIS IS JENNIFER LAURIE
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
ABOUT THE LINE UP TO SIX FIFTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING MADAM. GOOD EVENING-
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBER THIS IS
WILLIAM MICHAEL BURKE ON BEHALF
OF NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BUT THE
LINE UP. FOR EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
KELLY MCMILLAN I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MARCH OF DIMES AND
THE CHILDREN ESPECIALLY CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WHAT A
LINE UP FIVE SEVENTY FIVE
AIRLINERS OPEN. FIVE SEVEN FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS MARSHALL ON BEHALF OF
THE FABRIC INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINETY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WHAT A LINE OF SIX
SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MEDIA ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
CALIFORNIA DIVISION WE'RE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. ALTHOUGH NINE OF SIX
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS ANY TREND I'M WITH
THE NATIONAL HEALTH LAW PROGRAM
AND WE ARE SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BLIND OF
FIVE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FIVE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN- YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE GERMAN MEMBERS RECTANGLES
AND THEY HAVE THE AMERICAN
NURSES ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
ACROSS THE LINE OF A SIX NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SIX
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF SEVEN
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER THIS IS ADRIAN SILVA
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE A CHILD A FAMILY
SERVICES PRACTICE SUPPORT
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY FIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU. TO LINE UP
TO SEVEN THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MOLLY ROBERT WAS
HEAD OF BILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA
WERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. YOUR NEXT OVER
THE LINE OF SEVEN FORTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHARE
MEMBERS CAP MUST WORK ON BEHALF
OF THE LOCAL HEALTH PLAN TO
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION BY THE
AB. NINE THREE FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU OVER THE LINE- IT'S
SEVEN FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HIS NAME CHAIR MEMBERS PUT. ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
AND CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THE LINE OF
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SURE MEMBERS GALLAGHER ON
THE UP AND THEIR HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS ALSO THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. A
LINE OF SEVEN TWENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. REBECA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. Q. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU ABOUT THE LINE SEVEN
FORTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH HI THIS IS LEE MANDEL ME
IN CALIFORNIA REGISTERED NURSE.
IN SUPPORT OF. NINE THIRTY FIVE
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU TO LINE OF SEVEN
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIVE HUNDRED KM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH NOW IN THE PORT THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ORDER ONLINE AT SEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SEVEN THREE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PHOTO LINE UP SEVEN FORTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL YES
THIS IS YVONNE THEY ARE WHAT IS
WRONG- MARIN COUNTY AND THE
COPS WHAT PART OF THE FOURTH
CENTURY. I DON'T YOUR BOOK
BUSTLING. AND I. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU WILL
GO TO LINE OF SEVEN FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI DIFFERENT
PLAYERS AT LEAST FROM THE
BRIDGES THEIR BUSINESS GROUP ON
HEALTH IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YEAH
THANK YOU WILL GO TO A LINE OF
SEVEN FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU TERM MEMBER
SERVERS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU WELL TRY LINE
SEVEN FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI HI THIS IS MELANIE WILL BE
EXPERIENCE AT MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE- THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION
MOTION MR MCCARTY. A SECOND
WITH A MISTER NAZARIAN SECOND
BY MISTER NAZARIAN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS.
WHICH I TO CLOSE MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR HAIRMAN JUST TO A
COUPLE POINTS THAT THE
OPPOSITION RAISED I DO WANT TO
ADDRESS- UNFORTUNATELY WE DO
BELIEVE THAT SUBURBAN ANALYSIS.
THAT CONFUSE THE TELE PSYCH
CONSULT PROGRAM PROPOSED IN
THIS BILL WITH HE CONSULTS AND
IMPORTANT DIFFERENCES THAT HE
CONSULTS PROVIDE FOR WRITTEN
CONSULTATIONS AND THIS BILL
RIGHT- PROPOSES. AN INTERACTIVE
CONSULTATION SO. PROVIDER
SPECIALIST WITH CONNECT VIA
TELEPHONE OR VIDEO AND HAVE A
LIVE INTERACTIVE DISCUSSION
REGARDING TREATMENT WHICH
OBVIOUSLY WOULD BE FAR SUPERIOR
AND THEN SECONDLY IN TERMS OF
COST- I REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT
THIS WILL RESULT IN HEALTH CARE
COST SAVINGS BECAUSE SO MANY
MOTHERS HAVE HAD TO FACE
MULTIPLE APPOINTMENTS WITH
MULTIPLE POSITIONS. BECAUSE
THEIR SYMPTOMS WEREN'T
IDENTIFIED HER PROPER TREATMENT
WAS NOT PRESCRIBED IN THIS BILL
WILL CUT DOWN ON THOSE
UNNECESSARY APPOINTMENTS BY
FACILITATING A MORE DIRECT.
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE PROVIDER
AND SPECIALIST SO UP WITH THAT
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I BOTH. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHAT I
WOULD AYE MAYES. AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW. BURKE
BURKE HIGH CARILLO. FOR
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY MCCARTY I NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS. RIVAS HI
RODRIGUEZ. SANTIAGO WALDRON.
WALDRON I CALDERON. OKAY.
WALDRON WALDRON I'D CALDERON.
CALDERON I. NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
YOUR BILLS OUT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
NAZARIAN YOU HAVE TO BILLS
BEFORE US. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WHICH ONE WOULD YOU LIKE
ME TO START WITH I'LL START
WITH AB NINETY SEVEN. PLEASE
WILL DO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COLLEAGUES A. B.
NINETY SEVEN WOULD PROHIBIT A
HEALTH PLAN BEGINNING. ON
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY SECOND.
FROM IMPOSING A DEDUCTIBLE ON
AN INSULIN PRESCRIPTION. OVER
FOUR MILLION CALIFORNIANS
SUFFER FROM DIABETES. FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS WITH DIABETES
INSULIN IS AN ESSENTIAL PART OF
A HEALTHY LIFE APPROXIMATELY
FOUR MILLION ADULTS HAVE BEEN
DIAGNOSED WITH TYPE ONE
DIABETES. IF YOU HAVE DIABETES
YOU MOST LIKELY REQUIRE INSULIN
TO SURVIVE. HOWEVER BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. THE PRICE OF INSULIN
INCREASED OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
60% THE SKYROCKETING PRICE IS
UNTENABLE OFTEN CAUSING UNDUE
BURDEN ON OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM AND FORCING MANY WHO
CAN'T AFFORD THEIR MEDICINE.
THE SELF RATION AND LEADER
BEING ADMITTED TO EMERGENCY
ROOMS UNFORTUNATELY. ACCORDING
TO A STUDY PUBLISHED IN THE
JOURNAL OF AMERICAN MEDICINE IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN NEARLY
26% OF DIABETIS. PRESCRIBE
INSULIN REPORTED COST RELATED
UNDER USE LEADING TO POOR
GLYCEMIC CONTROL AND POTENTIAL
HEALTH PROBLEMS THAT ARE EVEN
MORE COSTLY AND POTENTIALLY
DEADLY. DUE TO THE PANDEMIC AS
PEOPLE BEGAN TO LOSE THEIR JOBS
THESE STATISTICS ONLY WERE
FURTHER EXACERBATED ESPECIALLY
FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR. ACCORDING
TO- CHIP BOURBON ALICE'S
APPROXIMATELY ONE OUT OF THREE
CALIFORNIANS N. D. M. H. C.
PARTNER MEANT- DEPARTMENT OF-
MANAGE HEALTH CARE SO- HEALTH
CARE. AND D. O. Y. DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE REGULATED PLANS
USING INSULIN OR 360-007-0050
PEOPLE AGAIN JUST THAT NOT GIVE
THE- SPELL OUT THE ACRONYMS.
ACCORDING TO A JOB ANALYSIS A
PROXY ONE OUT OF THREE
CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE UNDER THE
M. H. C. OR DO I REGULATED
PLANS USING INSULIN OR
360-007-0050 PEOPLE WOULD
BENEFIT FROM EXEMPTING INSULIN
FROM INSURANCE DEDUCTIBLES. JOB
ALSO FOUND A PREPONDERANCE OF
EVIDENCE THAT HIGHER COST
SHARING REDUCES APPEARANCE TO
INSULIN AND LOWER COST SHARING
INCREASES ADHERENCE TO INSULIN
AND THAT COST SHARING FOR
INSULIN IS EFFECTIVE IN
IMPROVING ADHERENCE TO INSULIN
IN PATIENTS WITH DIABETES.
OPPONENTS OF MY BILL WILL SAY
THAT AB NINETY SEVEN WILL RAISE
PREMIUMS. BY OVER TWENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS BUT ACCORDING
TO CHIPPER AB NINETY SEVEN
WOULD INCREASE TOTAL NET ANNUAL
EXPENDITURES BY TEN MILLION
DOLLARS DOLLARS TOTAL OR ONLY
POINT ZERO ZERO EIGHT PERCENT.
COLLEAGUES I JUST WANT TO
REPEAT THAT AGAIN EVEN THOUGH
IT'S A TEN MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE IT IS ONLY POINT 0008%
THIS IS BY THE INDEPENDENT
SUBURBAN HOUSES- TO GO FURTHER
ACCORDING TO THE SENATE BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE ON HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES. CALIFORNIANS
SPENT TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
TWO BILLION ON HEALTHCARE IN
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN. TEN
MILLION IS LESS THAN ONE HALF
OF 1% OF THAT NUMBER. BY
LIMITING COST SHARING FOR
INSULIN A. B. NINETY SEVEN WILL
MAKE INSULIN MORE AFFORDABLE
FOR ONE THIRD OF THOSE USING
INSULIN ON STATE REGULATED
PLANS DECREASE OUT OF POCKET
EXPENSES BY AN AVERAGE OF FIFTY
PERCENT. A DECREASE HOSPITAL
VISITS AND INCREASE
UNNECESSARY- I'M SORRY DECREASE
HOSPITAL VISITS THAT CAN
INCREASE UNNECESSARY EXPOSURE
TO VIRUSES AND OTHER
CONTAGIOUS- AND DECREASE IN
MEDICAL HOSPITAL. EMERGENCY
HOSPITAL VISITS AND AS
MENTIONED EARLIER WITHOUT
RAISING THE COST PREMIUMS BY
MORE THAN. ONE DOLLAR JUST THE
ONE LESS THAN A ONE DOLLAR
INCREASE. A JOINING ME TODAY IS
THE LOWER IS OF A RADO CEO OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH PARTNERSHIP.
AND POSSIBLY IN THE KITA HARUS
CHAIR OF THE ELLIE CHAPTER OF
THE AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION I KNOW SHE WASN'T
GOING TO BE ABLE TO STAY PAST
SIX TODAY. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND MY
NAME IS THE TYPICAL ON HARRIS
AND I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND I'M AN ACTRESS AND A
PRODUCER PHOTOGRAPHER. AND I'VE
BEEN LIVING WITH TYPE ONE
DIABETES FOUR EIGHT THOUSAND
BABIES AND I PREFER NOT A
THINKER FORTY THREE THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY TIMES. I
CHANGED MY INSULIN PUMP FIVE
NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTY FOUR
TIMES AND I REQUIRE INSULIN
EVERY DAY EVERY MINUTE AN HOUR
TO LIVE. IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN I WOULD WITHOUT
INSULIN PROJECT FOR HOURS AND
NOT FOR OUR PRETTY AN INTENSIVE
CARE UNIT FOR TWO WEEKS. AND A
GROWING HERE NOT BEING ON THE
RIGHT KIND OF INSULIN AND
FIGHTING THE INSURANCE COMPANY
FOR BASIC TOOLS TO MANAGE MY
DIABETES. HAS GIVEN YOU COULD
COMPLICATIONS RELATED TO
DIABETES RAFI LISTENER DAMAGE
IN MY LEGS AND FEET AND
GASTROPARESIS. WHICH IS NERVE
DAMAGE IN MY STOMACH. THE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE LIVING WITH
TYPE ONE AND TYPE TWO DIABETES
NEED INSULIN JUST TO LIVE AND
THE CASHIER MAKING SURE I HAD
ACCESS TO INCLUDES EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT TO ME. PERSONALLY
BECAUSE ON MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
MY HUSBAND AND I LEARNED THAT
WE EXPECTING OUR FIRST BABY.
AND ALLOW WOMEN WITH DIABETES
CAN. HAVE A HEALTHY PREGNANCY
IT DOES TAKE GREAT EFFORT AND
ACCESS TO CARE AS WERE HIGH
RISK PREGNANCIES. AND I
REMEMBER ONE OF THE DOCTORS IN
THE DELIVERY ROOM SAYING.
ANYTHING HE- COULD HEAR IT
EVERY TIME HE THOUGHT TYPE ONE
HAVING HEALTHY BABIES BECAUSE
EARLY IN HIS CAREER HE WAS
ENCOURAGED TO TELL WOMEN LIKE
ME NOT TO HAVE BABIES. BECAUSE
OF THE LIFE THREATENING
POSSIBILITIES OF THE DIABETES
CAN CAUSE SEVERE AND LIFE
THREATENING COMPLICATIONS IN
DELIVERY HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE
AND FREQUENCY OF PRETERM
DELIVERY. MISCARRIAGE AND EVEN
STILL BIRTH- DIABETES INCREASES
THE RISK OF THE PROBLEM EVEN
WITH GOOD MANAGEMENT. SO I GAVE
BIRTH TO MY BEAUTIFUL BABY GIRL
DECEMBER FIFTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY AND I'M BLESSED TO SAY
THAT. WE ARE BOTH VERY HEALTHY.
BUT I KNOW BUT I TO GET. TO
HAVE ACCESS TO INSULIN DAY. FOR
THE REST OF MY IN ORDER THAT
FOR TO KEEP HAPPENING. AND
THAT'S A BIG. HANGING OVER MY
HEAD AND I WERE TO BE HERE FOR
MY DOG AND HUSBAND. AND THE
COST OF INSTALLING. A LIVING
WITH. HELPING BIG BABY. HELP HI
A LOT OF PEOPLE WITH. PEOPLE
ARE CHOOSING TO AND GETTING PRO.
FOR THEIR- OR CUT THEIR DOES IN
HALF JUST TO PAY RENT. IN THAT
SITUATION AS WELL. IT YOU HAVE
TO. DEAL ABOUT THINK ABOUT I'M
HERE TO. AND. YOU'RE EXTREMELY
HIGH- PEOPLE ARE LEAVING THE-
TO BUY THEM. R. E. REMOTE-
WHERE THEY'RE HEALTHY. ARE
AFFORDABLE MORE ACCESSIBLE- ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION AND THE THREE
MILLION PEOPLE LIVING WITH
DIABETES IN CALIFORNIA I ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT. THIS STEP
TOWARD MAKING INSULIN
AFFORDABLE. BECAUSE OF ITS HIGH
FOR YOU IT'S LIFE AND DEATH FOR
US. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- NEXT
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY.
MY NAME IS DORIS ALVARADO I'M
THE CEO OF THE COMMUNITY HEALTH
PARTNERSHIP WE ARE THE
SUSPICION OF CLINICS IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY WE ADVOCATE FOR
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR ALL
WHO PUT ALL DIVERSE
MULTICULTURAL COMMUNITIES
REGARDLESS OF SOCIOECONOMIC
ETHNIC RELIGIOUS CULTURAL
BACKGROUND. I WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER SORRY FOR
CARRYING ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY
SEVEN AND FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY AND WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL WHICH WILL
MAKE INSULIN MORE AFFORDABLE
FOR THOSE DIAGNOSED WITH
DIABETES. IN CALIFORNIA. EIGHTY
NINE SEVEN PROVIDE A REASON
COST IF APPROACH FOR THE SOCIO
ECONOMIC IMPACT. OF DIABETES
AND WILL IMPROVE THE LIVES OF
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIANS BIKES INCLUDING
INSULIN COUNTRY DOCTOR
REQUIREMENTS IMPOSED BY HEALTH
PLANS. IN SANTA CLARA THERE'S A
PROPORTIONATE IMPACT
DISPROPORTIONATE EXCUSE ME
IMPACT OF DIABETES. POPULATIONS
I'M VERY KEEN TO THE FACT IT
DIABETES RATES FOR LATINO
SEPARATE CHINA PART OF THAT
COMMUNITY ARE TWICE THE RATE OF
NON LATINO WHITES. DIABETES IS
ALSO A THREAT TO THOSE IN OUR
AGING COMMUNITIES WITH 25% OF
THOSE OVER. SIXTY DIAGNOSED
WITH DIABETES. AN UNFORTUNATE
DIED SUGGESTING THE MEETING
CONCEPT. IN THIS COUNTY SANTA
CLARA COUNTY. THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER SPOKE TO BE UNDER USER
INSULIN AND THAT'S A GREAT
CONCERN FOR US THE RESULT ARE
NOT TAKING THE PHOTOS RESULTING
GLYCEMIC- NOT BEING ABLE TO
CONTROL YOUR GLYCEMIC. ARE
GREAT. POTENTIAL HELP
COMPLICATE IMPLICATIONS INCLUDE
HEART DISEASE STROKE A STROKE
AMPUTATION. AND H. COULD MAKE
DECISIONS AND BLANCA THESE
COMPLICATIONS OFTEN LEAD TO
HIGHER COSTS FOR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. WHICH AT THE END OF THE
DAY- YOU KNOW REALLY YOU READ
UP SPENDING FOR THE INSULIN PEN
YOU CAN'T EXTEND. FOR TREATING
THE PATIENT. INSULA RATIONING
CALM FOR LOWER INCOME PATIENTS
WE FOR THAT OVER AND AGAIN. FOR
STATE QUICKER TO SEE TO
PURCHASE PURCHASE EITHER THE
MEDICATION. OR FOR THEIR FOR.
OR THE RENT OR YOU. THE FIFTY
TRUE DURING THE FIRST SEVERAL
MONTHS OF IN YOUR CALENDAR HERE
ALL AND YOU PLAN YEAR. OF
COURSE THERE ARE BENEFITS TO
HEIDI HEALTH INSURANCE SUCH AS
LOWER MONTHLY PREMIUMS HOWEVER
FOR THOSE IN NEED OF LIFE
SAVING MEDICATIONS SUCH AS
INSULIN. THIS TRADE OFF CAN BE
DANGEROUS IF EIGHT DIABETICS
FINANCIAL RESOURCE TO TERMINATE
IT AND IT TAKES MONTHS TO MEET
THAT DEDUCTIBLE REQUIREMENTS IF
AT ALL. OKAY ACCEPTING INSULT
OF THE QUICKLIME IF THE RIGHT
THING DO. THE COMMUNITY HEALTH
PARTNERSHIP ENCOURAGES YOU TO
LEAD ON THIS ISSUE. AND VOTE I
ON ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY SEVEN.
THANK YOU- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STARTING IN I THINK YOU COULD
CREATE A COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDERING I REQUEST. HAVE A
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT WITNESS IN SOME. BOTH
SUCH ACTUALLY THIS WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION EXCUSE ME I'M SORRY.
TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU FOR. M. ET. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- AND CUT
NICKEL WITH THOSE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS- WE ARE OPPOSED
TO- MAYBE NINETY SEVEN- MEMBERS
INSULIN A LIFESAVING MEDICATION
THAT MILLIONS OF AMERICANS RELY
ON DAILY. AND SADLY HOWEVER AND
WE AGREE WITH THE AUTHORS
COMMENTS ON THIS ON THIS IS
JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF THE HIGH
PRICE DRUG CRISIS. ON IF WE DO
NOT ADDRESS THE SKY HIGH PRICES
LOGICALLY WILL CONTINUE TO
BURDEN OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
AND PUT PATIENTS AT RISK.
REGRETTABLY EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN
DOES NOT HELP THE UNDERLYING
PROBLEM INSTEAD THIS BILL AND
BILLS LIKE THIS WILL INCREASE
PREMIUMS ON INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES AND EMPLOYERS IN YOUR
DISTRICTS AND THIS WOULD BE AN
UNFORTUNATE OUTCOME IF IT'S AS
WE HAVE SEEN REMARKABLY LOW
PREMIUM INCREASES ARE COVERED
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS. NOW GRANTED THE
ESTIMATED IMPACT IN PRICING OF
THIS PARTICULAR BILL IS
RELATIVELY MODEST BUT WE CANNOT
LOOK AT THIS PROPOSAL IN A
VACUUM. AS THERE ARE SEVERAL
MANDATE BILLS. ON THAT HAVE
BEEN INTRODUCED THIS YEAR.
SECONDLY BILLS LAKE EIGHTY
NINETY SEVEN COULD THROW OUR
PLAN PRODUCTS OUT OF COMPLIANCE
WITH FEDERAL AND STATE RULES
AROUND BENEFIT DESIGN. AND DOES
REQUIRE PLANS TO INCREASE THE
OUT OF POCKET COSTS FOR OTHER
SERVICES. GIVEN SECOND OUTCOME
COMES TO PASS TO THE SUPPORTERS
OF THE B. NINETY SEVEN. SHOULD
BE PREPARED TO TELL
POLICYMAKERS WHICH SERVICES TO
SEE AN INCREASE IN OUT OF
POCKET COST IF THIS BILL IS
IMPLEMENTED AND END UP PUTTING
OUR PRODUCTS OUT OF COMPLIANCE
WITH THE ACA AND CORRESPONDING
STATE RULES- NO THERE'S NO
CORRESPONDING AFFECTED OF THIS
PROPOSAL THAT WILL LEAD TO ANY
REDUCTION IN THE PRICE OF
INSULIN MANUFACTURERS CURLED.
CURTAIL PLANS OR OTHER
PURCHASERS FOR THEIR PRODUCTS.
THE BILL PASSES THE
MANUFACTURES ARE STILL. FREE TO
PRICE OUR PRODUCTS AT WHATEVER
LEVEL IN INCREASE THE PRICE ON
EXISTING PRODUCTS. IN
CONSISTENT PRICE SCIENTIST BY
THE DRUG COMPANIES INCLUDING A
55% AVERAGE RISE IN THE COST OF
INSULIN SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN. IN THESE PRICES
CONTINUE TO INCREASE WITHOUT
ANY MAJOR MEDICAL IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE DRUG- THE DATA ALSO
SUGGESTS THAT ONE ONE INSULIN
MANUFACTURER INCREASES THE
PRICE FOR A GIVEN INSULIN
FORMULATION IN THE OTHER
INSULIN MANUFACTURERS OFTEN
INCREASE THEIR PRICES BY A
SIMILAR AMOUNT. SHORTLY
THEREAFTER ACCORDING TO THE
AMERICAN DIABETES ASSOCIATION.
ELIMINATING THE DEDUCTIBLE DOES
NOTHING TO HELP THE UNDERLYING
AND LARGER PROBLEM. ALL IT DOES
REQUIRE THE COST BE MEET UP
SOMEWHERE ELSE IN THE BENEFIT
DESIGN. IN AGAIN IN THE FORM OF
INCREASED PREMIUMS OR PERHAPS-
IN THE FORM OF AN INCREASE
ACOSTA SHARE FOR OTHER
SERVICES. MORE COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTIONS IN OUR OPINION OR
NEEDED WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE
SUPPORTED GREATER TRANSPARENCY
LAS IN THIS AREA. ANY EFFORTS
LAST YEAR TO BRING MORE GENERIC
OPTIONS ON THE INSULIN MARKET
TO HELP ADDRESS THE HIGH PRICES
CONSUMERS ARE CURRENTLY PAYING
FOR THESE DRUGS. SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE AB NINETY SEVEN-
YOU KNOW DOES NOT SOLVE THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEM IN ONE STATE
HAVE UNINTENDED NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THESE REASONS
WE OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD EVENING MR
MEMBERS PRESTON YOUNG FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE TONIGHT IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION AB NINETY SEVEN.
WELL THE BILL IS CERTAINLY WELL
INTENTIONED IT DOES CAUSE US
SOME CONCERNS WHICH IS THE
REASON FOR THE OPPOSITION THE
PRIMARY CONCERN THAT WE HAVE
WITH THE B. NINETY SEVEN. THE
FACT THAT THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT WILL MAKE PREMIUMS
RISE DESPITE THE PRESIDENT'S
PLAN REMAINING OUT OF POCKET.
WE HEARD EARLIER ABOUT THE
SUBURBAN HOUSES. AND GIVEN THE
OFFSET THE CALCULATION BUT THEY
HAVE IN THEIR IT INDICATED THAT
FOR YOUR PREMIUMS COULD RISE
THE BIG HALF MILLION DOLLARS
JUNCTION OF THE BILL AN
EMPLOYEE PREMIUMS A PRIVATE
PRODUCT LIKE THREE AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS. IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE B. NINETY SEVEN. AGAIN
WILL BE INCREASES ALONE ARE
TOLERABLE THEY HAVE TO BE TAKEN
IN CONTEXT THERE HAVE BEEN
NUMEROUS BENEFIT MANDATES
INTRODUCED THIS YEAR INCLUDING
ONE WE DISCUSSED EARLIER.
PERTAINING TO A POTENTIAL
PREMIUM INCREASE OF NEARLY
EIGHT HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO COLLECTIVELY THESE
PREMIUMS- INCREASE. IN RELATION
TO THESE MANDATE. AND PRIVATE
HEALTHCARE COSTS UPWARDS FOR
PLAYERS AND EMPLOYING OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS THE AVERAGE
FAMILY HEALTH PLAN PREMIUM HAS
INCREASED. TWENTY TWO PERCENT.
SO WILL IT BE. NINETY SEVEN
CERTAINLY ADDRESS WITH AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE- WE'RE HOPING
IN AND MAINTAIN THAT WE NEED TO
REMAIN CALM. OF THE QUEUE. IN
ITS MANDATE HOW A DRIVER
HEALTHCARE UP. CERVANTES
REASONS POLICY BE NINETY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY WE
WILL NOW I'M TO THE LINE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION- JUST YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE ON YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL. PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES- MADAM OPERATOR. THANK
YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THENZERO
FOR OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT. AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE ON AT SEVEN
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
SHARE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO A LINE OF
FIVE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
BREAK UP IN THE IN THE HOW
CALIFORNIANS HAD AN EXTREMELY
POSITIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU BETTER GO TO LINE OF
SEVEN FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
THEIR BRIDGE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU WILL GO TO A LINE OF
SEVEN SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I WAS VERY MEMBERS JOHN WHEN
YOU'RE ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE OF FIVE EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIVE
EIGHT THANK YOU KAREN THANK YOU
FOR MEMBERS ANDRE GOOD PARENTS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU ABOUT
THE LINE OF SEVEN SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS ERIN
BY BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ABOUT THE
LINE OF SEVEN THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MISTER CHAIR KATHY
DOWN OFTEN- REPRESENTING THE
HEALTH TRUSTS WERE PRACTICE
BONSER AT EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN
AND- DRIVERS. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE OF FOUR SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BRENT SPENCER
WITH THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBGYN THIS DISTRICT NINE AND
THE CALIFORNIA PODIATRIC
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION OPEN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. AGAIN WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORTER OPPOSITION.
YOUR COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. I
HAVE A COUPLE- PERSONAL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PERSISTENCE IN
THIS AREA MISTER NAZARIAN- I
KNOW WE'VE HAD A BILL LAST YEAR
AND- I APPRECIATE APPRECIATE%
YOUR WORK ON THIS. I HAVE TO
REFLECT ENOUGH INSULIN WAS
INVENTED IN NINETEEN TWENTY ONE
FIRST USED IN NINETEEN TWENTY
TO NINETY NINE YEARS AGO. THE
FACT THAT IT ISN'T AFFORDABLE
FOR PEOPLE TODAY. IS A TRAVESTY
IN MY OPINION THE FACT THAT
YOUR BILL WOULD CAUSE A
POTENTIAL ONE DOLLAR INCREASE
IN MONTHLY PREMIUMS FOR HEALTH
PLANS IS A SMALL PRICE TO PAY I
BELIEVE. I AGREE WITH THE
OPPOSITION THAT IT DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING TO DEAL WITH THE
UNDERLYING COSTS- MET OF
PHARMACEUTICALS. BUT WE'RE
WORKING ON THAT. THROUGH A BILL
CALLED THE OFFICE THAT THAT'S
GONNA IS TOTALLY ESTABLISHED
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY. FOR EVERYONE
WILL BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE CAR
THE INCREASING COSTS IN HEALTH
CARE. SO I DO QUESTION TO.
WHILE I UNDERSTAND THE
CUMULATIVE EFFECT OF MANDATES
AND THAT AS WE'VE HEARD THAT
MESSAGE OVER AND OVER AGAIN
TODAY- WE WERE OPPOSED BECAUSE
OF THE CUMULATIVE EFFECT OF
MANDATES- I DO WONDER YOU KNOW
THE COST TO THE SYSTEM OF
SOMEBODY WHO ISN'T ABLE TO
COMPLY WITH THEIR- INSULIN
COSTS AND ENDS UP NEEDING MORE
EXPENSIVE TREATMENT. I DO HAVE
TO WONDER WHAT IF THERE IS IF
THERE IS NOT SOME OFFSET THERE.
SO SO I UNDERSTAND THE
OPPOSITION- WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE THAT ONE OUT. I'M
DISAPPOINTED THAT- THE MARKET
IS WHAT IT IS THEY CHARGE WHAT
THEY CAN BECAUSE THEY CAN- AND
THERE IS NO PUSH BACK BUT-
WE'RE TRYING. AND I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A SOLUTION IN THE MEANTIME
A SOLUTION LIKE THIS. IS BETTER
THAN NO SOLUTION AT ALL. AND I
I'M- I'D LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR TO YOUR BILL IF YOU
HAVE ANY. IDEA I'D BE HONORED
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. AND
YET. YOU DO A QUICK GOOGLE
SEARCH- IT'S VERY EASY TO SEE
IF YOU JUST RIGHT NOW I JUST
DID A GOOGLE SEARCH JUST SO
THAT I CAN SPOT A FEW NUMBERS-
MINIMUM NIGHTLY COST ENOUGH
HOSPITAL IS TEN THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS GOES UP TO
FIFTEEN THOUSAND I EVEN SAW
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND- AND IT
DEPENDS ON THE STUDY OF THE
YEAR AS WELL THE ONE THAT I
LOOKED THAT WAS IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ANOTHER ONE WAS A TWO
TWENTY. TWENTY TWENTY. WE KNOW
WHAT THE COSTS ARE. AND WE KNOW
HOW EXPENSIVE IT IS. SO IT'S A
BASIC SIMPLE MATH FOR ME YOU
HAVE A LARGE NUMBER OF CLIENTS
WHO NEED THIS. A SUBSET OF THAT
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA'S NEED THIS HAVE
DIABETES AND NEEDED 10% OF IT
WILL DIE IF THEY DON'T USE
INSULIN. AND IF WE CAN PROVIDE
FOR THEM. THIS DRUG. IN A WAY
WHERE IT'S AFFORDABLE. AND IT
DOESN'T OVERALL RAISE THE COST
TOO MUCH I WOULDBE HAPPY TO
PAY A ONE DOLLAR EXTRA MONTH.
IF THAT MEANS A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF THAT FORTY
THOUSAND PATIENTS DON'T RATION
THE DRUGS. AND DON'T END UP IN
AN EMERGENCY ROOM BECAUSE
PAYING TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
NINETY IN AN EMERGENCY ROOM. IS
GOING TO INCREASE OUR COSTS AND
PREMIUMS AND OVERALL HEALTH
CARE COSTS MUCH MORE. THAN ONE
DOLLAR INCREASE IN SOCIALIZING
THE COST OF THE MEDICINE. TRIP
TO ME IT IT'S A VERY SIMPLE
MATHEMATICAL EQUATION THAT
MAKES SENSE I KNOW IT DOES TO
YOU AS WELL I DO HOPE THAT YOU
ALL AGREE WITH THAT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU MR ASSYRIAN-
DO WE HAVE A MOTION. THE MOTION
BY MISS CARILLO A SECOND BY
MISS BURKE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WHAT I WOULD I AM MAYES. MAYES
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE BIGELOW. BURKE BURKE FIVE
CARILLO THANK YOU CARILLO EIN
FLORA. MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN AYE
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS RIVERSIDE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ FIVE
SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON I
CALDERON CALDERON HIGH. NO ONE
HAS ELEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO YOUR%
BILL IS OUT LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR OTHERS THAT ON THANK YOU
MISTER NAZARIAN YOU HAVE
ANOTHER BILL AB FIVE TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES AND MISTER CHAIR-
AB. FIVE TWENTY THREE I'D LIKE
TO FIRST THANK THE CHAIR AND
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE STAFF FOR-
FURTHER WORKING THIS
LEGISLATION TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF PACE ORGANIZATIONS AND THEIR
PATIENTS- THE BILL ANALYSIS
REFLECT THE BILL. MOVING
FORWARD WITH AMENDMENTS. AB
FIVE TWENTY THREE MAKES
PERMANENT THE FLEXIBILITIES
THAT HAVE ALLOWED. CASE
ORGANIZATIONS TO RESPOND TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN CRISIS AND AT
THE SAME TIME. PROVIDE CARE FOR
MORE PARTICIPANTS. THE
STATUTORY CHANGES PROPOSED BY
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THESE
FLEXIBILITIES TO CONTINUE-
FOLLOWING THE END OF THE HEALTH
EMERGENCY. PACE PARTICIPANTS
HAVE CONTINUE TO RECEIVE THE
HIGHEST STANDARD OF CARE.
DURING COVERT AND HAVE FARED
BETTER THAN THEIR COUNTERPARTS
LIVING IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. SIMPLY PASTE IS THE
STANDOUT MODEL AS WE REIMAGINE
HEALTHCARE IN CALIFORNIA. CASES
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FRAIL SENIORS. AND
ALLOW THEM TO REMAIN LIVING IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES RATHER THAN
IN INSTITUTIONS. PACE PROGRAMS
COORDINATE AND DELIVER
PREVENTATIVE. PRIMARY ACUTE AND
LONG TERM CARE SERVICES TO
OLDER ADULTS WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE BE IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. DURING THE CALL THE
NINETEEN HEALTH EMERGENCY PACE
ORGANIZATIONS. MODIFIED THE
WAYS IN WHICH THEY DELIVER CARE
TO THEIR PARTICIPANTS IN ORDER
TO KEEP. THEIR PARTICIPANTS
SAFE. PACE ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY RESPONDED TO
COVERT NINETEEN HEALTH
EMERGENCY BY IMPLEMENTING
RIGOROUS INFECTION CONTROL.
MEASURES AND QUICKLY
TRANSITIONING FROM PROVIDING
CENTER FOCUSED CARE. TO HOME
BASED CARE THESE MODIFICATIONS
HAVE BEEN DONE WITH THE STATE
AND FEDERAL REGULATORS. OF
PEACE ORGANIZATIONS THESE
FLEXIBILITIES HAVE INCLUDED
MORE EXTENSIVE USE OF
TELEHEALTH FOR PARTICIPANT
ASSESSMENTS. MONITORING AND
COMMUNICATION DEPLOYMENT OF
PEACE CENTER NURSES INTO
PARTICIPANTS HOMES. AND
ALLOWING REFERRALS FROM
HOSPITAL AND NURSING HOME
DISCHARGE PLANNERS. WITH ME ON
THE PHONE LINES TODAY
SUPPORTING AB FIVE TWENTY THREE
ARE. MELISSA HOPE CEO OF
REDWOOD PACE AND MARIA'S AMORA
pINDEPENDENCE AND CHAIR OF THE
NATIONAL PACE ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN WILL
GO TO A TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT-
WITH THE FIRST WITNESS. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ARE REALLY HAVE THE
DIRECTOR THE REDWOOD COAST
PACE. PROGRAM LOCATED IN SECOND
DISTRICT OF CARE WHAT. THAT
WOULD HELP PAY FOR THE FIRST
ROLE PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE BEEN OPEN FIFTY YEARS
HAVE TO FIGHT TO DOUBLE COUNTY.
CURRENTLY ARE. THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY PARTICIPANTS.
HEY ORGANIZATION SEVEN IN A ROW.
FLEXIBILITY ARE OUTLINED IN AB
FIVE TWENTY THREE BECAUSE THEY
WERE PUT INTO PLACE LAST YEAR
AS PART OF THE STATE RESPONSE
TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY.
EXTENDING THE FLEXIBILITY BROWN
ABLE TO PAY FOR CONTINUE TO
MORE SAFELY AND. MORE
EFFECTIVELY REACH ANSWER. YOU
CAN FROM K. ALLOWING CAN BUT-
IN THE USE OF TELEHEALTH FOR
EXAMPLE FOR NAVAL PAPERWORK AS
THEY CAN TO REACH. THAT PERSON
WHO HAD DIFFICULTY MAKING
ARRANGEMENTS FOR HIM PERSONALLY.
SIMILARLY ALLOWING CONTINUED
FLEXIBILITY TO ENROLL PERSON
GIVING VERBAL AGREEMENT
TRAINLINE THE ENROLLMENT
PROCESS AND MAKE IT WILL MAKE
IT EASIER FOR THAT PERSON.
ALLOWING PAY CENTER NURSES TO
PROVIDE NURSING SERVICES THAT
THEY ARE OTHERWISE AUTHORIZED
UNDER THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE
PROVIDE CAN PARTICIPATE. THE
RESULT IN MORE EFFECTIVE USE OF
RESOURCES AND IMPROVE ACCESS TO
SERVICES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
HAVE DIFFICULTY MAKING VISIT
OKAY CENTER. PROVIDING
FLEXIBILITY. FOR PAID
PARTICIPATION. TO CONTACT THE
FISHERY GOING THROUGH. FOR IS
CHARGED WITH CONSENT FOR NAVAL
MORE PEOPLE TO AVOID PLACEMENT
GATHERED IT SO THE ANSWER
RETURNED TO THE COMMUNITY YEAH
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE HAPPY
TO SUPPORT AB FIVE TWO THREE
ONE THANK. THE AUTHOR FOR
CANADA IN THE BILL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH OF A MOOD SECOND
WITNESS TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS I'M NOT IN THE MADA
CEO FOR THE CENTER FOR ELDERS
INDEPENDENT. ORGANIZATION IS
HEADQUARTERED IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND HAD THIRTY THREE
EIGHTEEN YEARS FOR OVER THIRTY
FIVE YEARS. TODAY WE HELP
SENIORS IN ALAMEDA AND CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY. REMAIN IN THEIR
HOMES IN COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
SUPPORTED SERVICES. WE OPERATE
FIVE PAGE CENTER AND SERVE
NEARLY NINE HUNDRED SENIORS.
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE HAVE STEPPED UP DURING
THE COLD NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE
OFFER MULTIPLE SENIORS A SAFE
ALTERNATIVE TO NURSING HOME
PLACEMENT. THE NUMBER OF
COMPLICATED AMONG PAPER
SHIPMENTS AS FAR LESS THAN THAT
EXPERIENCING CALIFORNIA NURSING
FACILITIES. AS A WAY TO KEEP
SAID FRAIL SENIORS STATE AND
ENABLE THEM IN THE COMMUNITY TO
REMAIN IN THEIR HOMES AND
COMMUNITY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES GRANTED
SEVERAL REGULATORY FLEXIBILITY
TO PAY FOR INFLATION LAST YEAR.
AS PART OF ITS RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC WHICH WE GREATLY VALUE.
RESPECTABILITY ARE WORKING
WHILE THE PAPERWORK INNOVATION.
AND HAVE PROVEN. VERY AFFECTED
ME BOTH. BOTH SAFELY SERVE
CURRENTLY PARTICIPANTS AS WELL
AS REACH AND INVOLVE NEW PARTS
OF THE TWO. INCLUDED IT
FLEXIBILITY IN THE USE OF
TELEHEALTH SERVICES FOR
PARTICIPATE ASSESSMENT
MONITORING AND COMMUNICATION.
AND THE ABILITY TO USE VERBAL
AGREEMENT AND LOW PARTICIPANTS
SIGNATURES FOR PACE ENROLLMENT
AGREEMENT. EXTENDING THE
FLEXIBILITY BEYOND THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY ONE ABLE
PAPERWORK INNOVATION TO
CONTINUE TO MORE EFFECTIVELY
REACH ANSWER PARTICIPANTS AND
ADDS POTENTIAL ENROLLEES. WE
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING THE BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SO LET'S GO
TO IF THERE'S ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. HEARING NONE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES SOME
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR ANY. ANY
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION THIS IS
JUST THE ADD ONS AS SO- YOUR
SUPPORT YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR NAME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. OF AB
FIVE TWENTY THREE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE OF THEM
ZERO FOR ANY OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
OF SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. KAREN MEMBERS BARBARA
PLAYED THROUGH A CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
SUPPORT AND EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT RICARDO LINE OF FOUR
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHOWS
AND EVEN EVEN WHEN PEOPLE ARE
GONNA HAPPEN WELL BE HEALTH
STRONG SUPPORT AT THE FACT
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AN ACTUAL PHOTO
LINE UP FOR THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
A MONTH IN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE H. CALIFORNIA TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR A BI FIVE
HUNDRED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AN EXTRA COAT SO LINE
OF SEVEN SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS BURNING A
TON ON BEHALF OF ANY FUTURE
HEALTH AND SAN DIEGO KATE WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FIVE TWENTY THREE AND THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCED IN THE
HOUSE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. AND
MEXICO TO LINE OF SEVEN SIXTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS ISSUE THE FISH
ABOU I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF%
THE LOS ANGELES YOU WISH HOME
GRAHAM INSPECTORS FOR SENIOR
CARE PLEASE PROGRAM. AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND NEXT OVER TO
LINE OF SIX FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. RIGHT. NINE FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME OKAY WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE I WANT TO MAKE SURE TO ASK
THE AUTHOR IF HE ACCEPTS THE
AMENDMENTS. I DID MENTION IN MY
COMMENTS THAT WE WILL BE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE AMENDMENT
SALAS FANTASTIC THANK YOU SO
MUCH IT IS ALL BE ENTERTAINING
A MOTION WHICH THE MOTION WOULD
BE TOO DEEP TO BE TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
HOUSE FIVE BELIEVE THAT MISS
CARILLO HAD MADE THE MOTION AND
I SAW A COUPLE OF OTHER HEADS.
NOT AS OUR SECOND- THE MISS
CALDERON SECONDS THAT- THE
CLERK WAS IT WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WHAT MAYES AYE
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE BIGELOW. BURKE
BURKE I CARILLO. I LARA.
MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY MCCARTY I
NAZARIAN HI NAZARIAN I REQUEST.
RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
HI SANTIAGO WALDRON WALDRON AYE
CALDERON CALDERON HI. IT'S TEN
ZERO. IS IT IS THERE ANY GOT
TEN VOTES THE BILL'S OUT WE'RE
GOING TO LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ADD ONS AND THEN WE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ITEM FROM
MISTER RODRIGUEZ I THINK- FOR
FIFTY FOUR WAS ALREADY TAKEN
CARE OF- SO MOVE ON TO AB EIGHT
TWENTY TWO IF THAT'S OKAY. YES.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ARRIVED TODAY PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT TWENTY TWO. A
MEASURE THAT SEEKS TO FILL AN
IMPORTANT GAP IN THE MEDICAL.
OR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM TO
ENSURE COVERAGE FOR EMERGENCY
PSYCHIATRIC SERVICES. UNDER
FEDERAL LAW PSYCHIATRIC MERCIES
ARE LEGALLY EQUIVALENT TO ALL
OTHER MEDICAL EMERGENCIES MANY.
THAT EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS ARE
REQUIRED TO ATTEMPT TO ASSESS
AND STABILIZE. A PSYCHIATRIC
PATIENT AS IF THEY WOULD ANY
OTHER PATIENT WITH A PHYSICAL
INJURY. ANY BURDENSOME
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS THE STATE
EXPERTS EXTENSIVE BOARDING
TIMES WITH PSYCHIATRIC PATIENTS
ARE OFTEN SPEND SEVERAL HOURS
AND SOMETIMES DAYS WAITING TO
TRANSPORT TO INPATIENT.
PSYCHIATRIC CARE IN BEDS WITH
MY PERSONAL TO PROTECT A TEST
OF THE LONG HOURS OF BOARDING
TIMES WAITING FOR MERGING BED
OPEN UP SO THEY CAN ACCEPT
PATIENTS ARRIVING IN AN
AMBULANCE. THIS RELY RELY
RESULTS IN DELAY OF CRITICAL
PATIENT CARE. DELIVERY BOARDING
TIMES AND TO BETTER SERVE
MENTAL HEALTH PATIENTS THERE
ARE HOSPITALS THAT HAVE CREATED
THERAPEUTIC HOME LIKE
ENVIRONMENTS KNOWN AS
PSYCHIATRIC OBSERVATION UNITS.
THESE UNITS ARE PRODUCED
BOARDING TIMES IMPROVE CARE FOR
MERCY PSYCHIATRIC PATIENTS AND
MAKE MORE OUTPATIENT EMERGENCY
BEDS AVAILABLE FOR ALL
PATIENTS. HOWEVER DUE TO LACK
OF REIMBURSEMENT UNDER THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM FOR THE
MERCHANT SERVICES LIKE
PSYCHIATRIC OBSERVATION UNITS
PROVIDE THE EXISTENCE OF THESE
UNITS ARE AT RISK BECAUSE
HOSPITALS TAKE ON MOST OF THE
COST. AB TWENTY TWO WOULD
CONFIRM MEDICARE REIMBURSEMENT
FOR OBSERVATION SERVICES. THAT
ARE PROVIDED A PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCY SERVICES WITHIN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT INCREASE
COORDINATION OF PATIENT CARE
BETWEEN MENTAL HEALTH PLANS.
AND MANAGED CARE PLANS TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TODAY. THE
DOCTOR SCOTT ZELLER WHO SHOULD
BE ON THE LINE. THANK YOU
MISTER RODRIGUEZ WILL MOVE TO A
DOCTOR ZELLER. HELLO HI AND
GOOD EVENING- CHAIRMAN WOULD
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S DR SCOTT SELLER OF A
POSITION WITH. THIRTY FIVE
YEARS PRACTICING EMERGENCY
PSYCHIATRY OF OFFER AUTHORED
BOTH FULL EMERGENCY PSYCHIATRY
TEXTBOOKS AND MY UC PROFESSOR
OF CLINICAL PSYCHIATRY ALSO
PAST PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION FOR EMERGENCY
PSYCHIATRY. THANKS SPEAKING
HERE TODAY TO URGE THE PASSAGE
OF AB EIGHT TWENTY TWO WHICH
SEEMS TO ADDRESS THE LONG
STANDING ISSUE OF PSYCHIATRIC
PATIENTS BOARDING FOR LONG
HOURS IN HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS. AND DESPITE THE
CREATION OVER THE PAST DECADE
OR SO OF MANY WONDERFUL
COMMUNITY OUTPATIENT CRISIS
PROGRAMS- OVER THE PAST DECADE.
THERE'S JUST SOME PATIENTS WHO
ARE JUST TOO ACUTE AN ERROR
DANGERS THEMSELVES OR OTHERS
WHO ARE GOING TO STILL END UP
IN HOSPITAL ER'S AND THOSE
NUMBERS CONTINUE TO CLIMB AND
NOW COMPRISE ONE IN EVERY SEVEN
PATIENTS. WERE SEEN IN HOSPITAL
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS ACROSS
THE STATE. DEPARTMENT
RECOGNIZED THAT THE FEDERAL
IMPALA LAW DEFINES THE
PSYCHIATRIC EMERGENCY AS AN
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CONDITION
JUST LIKE THAT PERSONALLY
HAVING A HEART ATTACK OR BURKE
FROM. THE EMERGENCY ROOM IS
LEGALLY OBLIGATED TO STABILIZE
THESE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
CONDITIONS OR ADMITTED
IMPATIENT. THE BOARDING CRISIS
IS HAPPENING BECAUSE EMERGENCY
ROOMS HISTORICALLY HAVE NOT
BEEN COMPENSATED FOR
PSYCHIATRIC CARE. SO THEY WOULD
ONLY HAVE THE OPTION OF HOLDING
PATIENTS TO ADMIT THEM OR
TRANSFER THEM TO THE INPATIENT
BEDS. WHICH OFTEN ENDS UP BEING
LONG HOURS OR EVEN DAYS. SO
IMAGINE IF YOU WENT TO AN E. R.
WITH AN ASTHMA ATTACK. AND YOU
WERE JUST STRUGGLING TO BREATHE
AND ALL THEY COULD DO WAS WALK
YOU TO THE BACK OF THE YARDS AT
SIT TIGHT FOR A FEW HOURS WHILE
WE TRY TO FIND YOU AN ASTHMA
HOSPITAL. WHERE MEDICARE WILL
REIMBURSE FOR YOUR CARE THAT
SOUNDS PRETTY RIDICULOUS BUT
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS
WITH PEOPLE WITH PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCIES. WHICH CAN BE
REALLY DEBILITATING OR OR
ACTUALLY HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUFFERING FROM ACUTE
SUICIDALITY OR OR HEARING
AUDITORY HALLUCINATIONS TELLING
THEM TO HURT OTHERS. THE GOOD
NEWS IS WE HAVE EVIDENCE BASED
SOLUTIONS IF WE ACTUALLY START
TREATMENT AT THE EMERGENCY
LEVEL OF CARE. WE'RE GOING JUST
LIKE YOU WOULDN'T BE THE
EMERGENCY LEVEL OF CARE
TREATMENT FOR AN ASTHMA ATTACK
WE ACTUALLY HAVE REALLY GREAT
OUTCOMES. IN WHAT WE CAN DO IS
SOMETHING THAT'S KNOWN AS
PSYCHIATRIC OBSERVATION CARE.
IN EMERGENCY SETTINGS AND WE
KNOW THAT IF WE DO THIS WE CAN
STABILIZE UP 280% OF PATIENTS
WHO HAVE PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCIES IN LESS THAN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS. WE CAN PROBABLY
HELP THESE FOLKS FOR A FRACTION
OF THE COST OF WHAT IN PATIENT
CARE AREAS. AND THEN THAT'S
GOING TO SAVE THOSE PRECIOUS
INPATIENT BEDS FOR THOSE FOLKS
WHO TRULY HAVE NO ALTERNATIVE.
SO PSYCHIATRIC OBSERVATION
UNITS ARE ALSO KNOWN AS EMPAT
UNITS IN IMPACT IS AN ACRONYM
THAT STANDS FOR EMERGENCY
PSYCHIATRY ASSESSMENT TREATMENT
AND HEALING UNITS. THAT'S
MOVING PATIENTS QUICKLY OUT OF
THE E. R. TO A MORE HOME LIKE
THERAPEUTIC. CALMING
ENVIRONMENT WITH RAPID ACCESS
TO A PSYCHIATRIC PROVIDER AND
PROMPT INITIATION OF TREATMENT
PLANT. AND THIS IS ALL VERY
COLLABORATIVE AND NON COERCIVE
THERE'S CLOSE TO ZERO USE OF
PHYSICAL RESTRAINTS IN THESE
ENVIRONMENTS COMPARED TO THE
REGULAR ER. AND THERE'S VERY
VERY HIGH PATIENT SATISFACTION.
AND WHAT WE'VE ALSO SEEN AS WE
CAN EVEN DRAMATICALLY IMPROVED-
THE CARE IN JUST GENERAL ER'S
WHO DON'T HAVE A PSYCHIATRIC
OBSERVATION UNIT. BY
IMPLEMENTING REIMBURSEMENT. FOR
PSYCHIATRIC OBSERVATION CARE
AND THE RESULTS OF ARE VERY AS-
IN PSYCHIATRIC OBSERVATIONS
ALREADY COVERED BY MEDICARE AND
PRIVATE INSURANCE AND MANY
OTHER STATES MEDICAID. BUT THE
PROBLEM HAS BEEN IN CALIFORNIA
FOR MEDIC CAL WHICH IS WHAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE COVERAGES FOR
THE PATIENTS. SEEN WITH
PSYCHIATRIC EMERGENCIES BOTH
THE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS
AND MANAGED MEDICARE PLANS.
BOTH SEEM TO FEEL THAT THE
OTHER- AND HE SHOULD UNDERSELL
THINKABLE FOR. YEAH DR ZELLER
OF THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
VERY NFORMATIVE I THINK WE'LL
KEEP YOU ON THE LINE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS BUT I THINK YOUR TIME
IS- IS. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE- I
THINK WE'VE GOT THERE'S NO MORE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT I BELIEVE
MR RODRIGUEZ WE'RE GONNA MOVE-
TO THE TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
AND I BELIEVE WE'VE GOT A
MICHELLE CABRERA. MRS CABRERA
MAY KNOW YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
APOLOGY CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW.
WE'VE GOT. TO OKAY PERFECT A
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
MACHEL CABINET OUT WITH EDTA
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION HE B. H.
D. A. AS OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
EIGHT TWENTY TWO UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED TO ENSURE THAT MEDICAL
BENEFICIARIES WERE AWAITING
TRANSFER FOR IN AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT ARE IN FACT
RECEIVING A MINIMUM DEFINED SET
OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AS
DOCTORS SELLER DESCRIBED IN HIS
TESTIMONY. WHILE HOSPITALS DO
HAVE THE OBLIGATION TO
STABILIZE TREAT TO THEIR
CAPACITY AND TRANSFER ALL
PATIENTS WHETHER THE EMERGENCY
IS A PHYSICAL HEALTH EMERGENCY
OR A PSYCHIATRIC EMERGENCY ALL
TOO OFTEN INDIVIDUAL PURPORTED
IN P. D. BECAUSE HOSPITALS HAVE
NOT INVESTED IN PROVIDING
ACCESS TO SPECIALTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES INCLUDING. ON
CALL PSYCHIATRIST. KERN BOB
SERVICE ARE IS HEALTH SERVICES
PROVIDED IN EDIE'S AND ARE NOT
REIMBURSED BE A MEDIC CAL. IN
ADDITION COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PLAN CAN AND DO
REIMBURSED FOR A VARIETY OF
HOSPITAL BASE SITE PSYCHIATRIC
SERVICES INCLUDING CRISIS
STABILIZATION AND PSYCHIATRY
CONSUL. AND OTHERS THAT ARE
WITH IN OUR SPECIALTY MEDIC HOW
HOPE OF BENEFITS. IF THIS BILL
SEEKS TO ESTABLISH A NEW MEDIC
HOW BENEFIT TO IMPROVE ACCESS
TO PSYCHIATRIC ORIENTED
OBSERVATION SERVICES IN HE
BEANS WE WOULD ASK THAT THE
BILL BE AMENDED TO REFLECT. HOW
THE SERVICES ARE NEW AND
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT WE'RE ABLE
TO BILL FOR TWO DAYS AND
CLARIFY A MINIMUM REQUIRED SET
OF STANDARDS PSYCHIATRIC
SERVICES. CURRENTLY THE BILL
REFERENCES A NON PSYCHIATRIC
OBSERVATION CODE IN THIS IS
THAT PHYSICAL HEALTH
OBSERVATION CODES AND SO IT
WOULD NOT BE APPROPRIATE FOR
OUR SPECIALTY. MENTAL HEALTH
PLAN- IF THE AUTHOR IS
INTENDING TO REIMBURSE
HOSPITALS FOR EMERGENCY OR
POLITICALLY STATION SERVICES
THAT DID NOT BY DEFINITION
INCLUDES PSYCHIATRIC SERVICES
THAN THOSE WOULD BE BETH EL
BILL TO THE MANAGED CARE PLAN
AS ORIGINALLY PROPOSED IN THIS
BILL. AND IT'S DUE TO THE LACK
OF CLARITY THAT WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY REMAIN OPPOSED TO
EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY TWO UNLESS
IT IS AMENDED THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISKA CABRERA AND NOW
MODERATOR GONNA GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR ANY- ADELINES- THOSE
WHO WISH TO. BE IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
EITHER YOU- SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THANK APPEARANCE UP
OUR- OF A EIGHT TWENTY TWO. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO IF
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND
WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
BARBARA GLAZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB. EIGHT
TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU ACROSS
THE LINE OF SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHARE
MEMBERS KATHY MUSTERED UP WE
HAVE THE LOCAL HEALTH PLAN TO
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OFFICE OFFICE. THANK YOU THANK
THANK YOU WILL GO TO LINE OF
FIVE NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I TEXTURES MEMBERS TEN
BATON REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS
AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT. GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO A LINE OF SEVEN
TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RANDALL HAGER FOR THE
PSYCHIATRIC POSITIONS ALLIANCE
IN CALIFORNIA WE DON'T HAVE A
FORMAL SUPPORT POSITION BUT
WE'RE LEANING THAT WAY WE THINK
THIS HAS MERIT AND SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH OF MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE QUEUES THAT
CORRECT MODERATOR. CORRECT THEY
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. HERE HEARING NONE- MR
I REGUS WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE-
ALSO CONTINUE WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS OF THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD TO RESPECT US RIVAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH-
AND- DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THIS BILL. WHO I'M GONNA HAVE
TO GO WITH- MOTION FROM AUTUMN
I'M SORRY SOME ARE BURKE IN A
SECOND I'M A SOME OF OUR CREE
WHO. AND WITH THAT- IF THE IF
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD. MAYES HI
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. HE.
TWENTY TWO. BIGELOW BURKE BURKE
I CARILLO. HI FLORA FLORA I
MAIENSCHEIN. MCCARTY. NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS. RIVERSIDE
RODRIGUEZ HI RODRIGUEZ EYES
SANTIAGO. WALDRON WALDRON I
CALDERON CALDERON I WOULD WOULD
I AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I.
BIGELOW BIGELOW I. TWENTY ZERO
ZERO FILMS ON THE ROLE OF
BROTHERS AND- MOVE ON TO NOW-
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX AB
TWELVE TWENTY NINE MISTER
RODRIGUEZ. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN REPRESENT AB TWELVE
TWENTY NINE AND URGENCY BILL
RELATIVE TO AMBULANCE PATIENT
OFFLOAD DELAYS ALSO KNOWN AS
WALL TIME. THIS BILL REQUIRED
THE DIRECTOR OF M. SUCH
ESTABLISH A TASK FORCE TO
ADDRESS LOCAL EMS CHALLENGES
RESULTING FROM EXTENSIVE WALL
TIMES THE TASK FORCE FOR
HOWEVER PROJECT PLAN THAT
INCLUDES ENOUGH VALUATION OF
ADOPTING EMS DIRECTIVES AIMED
TO LIVE YET DOUBLETS PATIENT
OFFLOAD DELAYS. DURING COVERT
NINETEEN AND REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE PROGRESS I
SUSPECT WE ASK FOR A ROOM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
MOVE ON TO- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. SORRY I'M LOOKING FOR
THE- SO A MOVE TO THE FOUR
THERE ARE NO WITNESSES SO OKAY
BRING IT BACK TO- FILLED. WITH
WITH THE RIGHT PEOPLE THERE
MIGHT BE-THERE MIGHT BE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY SO LET'S LET THE
OPERATOR SEE IF. THERE IS
ANYBODY ON THE LINE AND LIKE TO
TESTIFY JUST THEIR NAME
POSITION ORGANIZATION IF THEY
REPRESENT ONE. WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISTER MAYES A SECOND BY
MISTER FLORA. THANK YOU
REPORTER OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE TWENTY NINE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
ZERO APPEARED SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE THE BILL
DOES HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OR MOTION BY
MISTER MAYES A SECOND BY MR FOR
A- MOTION TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS ONCE AGAIN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I WOULD I WOULD I'D MAYES MAYES
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. BIGELOW
BIGELOW AYE BURKE BURKE I
CARILLO. CARILLO I'D FLORA. FOR
AYE MAIENSCHEIN MCCARTY.
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE REBUS.
RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I
SANTIAGO WALDRON WALDRON AYE
CALDERON CALDERON HI. ELEVEN
ZERO ELEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON. MISS WALDRON.
A. B. TWELVE FOURTEEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU THE DOCTOR WOULD AND
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON AMENDMENTS
THAT ADDRESS THE POINTS MADE IN
THE ANALYSIS OF THEIR PRIME
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS. AB
TWELVE FOURTEEN DIRECTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. TO SEEK WAIVER
APPROVAL FROM THE CENTERS FOR
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID SERVICES
CMS. TO ALLOW JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDI CAL COVERAGE DURING THE
THIRTY DAYS PRIOR TO RELEASE
FROM A CORRECTIONAL FACILITY.
NATIONAL DATA HAS SHOWN THAT
THE JUSTICE INVOLVED POPULATION
CONTAINED TO THIS PUT
DISPROPORTIONATE AMOUNT OF
PERSONS UP 280% THE HAVE
BEHAVIORAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS AND OTHER CHRONIC
DISEASES WHILE ABOUT HALF
STRUGGLE WITH SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS. IN TWENTY ELEVEN TO
TWENTY TWELVE. HALF OF PEOPLE
IN STATE FEDERAL PRISON THE
LOCAL SHERIFF. HAVING A CHRONIC
CONDITION. DUE TO LONGER
SENTENCES IN PRISONS. JUSTICE
INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCE
HIGHER RATES OF CHRONIC DISEASE
DIABETES HEART AND OTHER
CONDITIONS ON THE AVERAGE
POPULATION BY TWENTY THIRTY
PEOPLE AGE FIFTY AND OLDER IS
PROJECTED TO ACCOUNT FOR ONE
THIRD OF ALL INCARCERATED
PEOPLE IN THE UNITED STATES.
JUSTICE INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCE AND THREE TO EIGHT
TIMES INCREASED RISK OF
OVERDOSE DEATHS WITHIN THE
FIRST TWO WEEKS AFTER RELEASE.
THIS CAN BE PREVENTED WITH
CONTINUITY OF CARE AND
TREATMENT AFTER REENTRY.
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ARE ELIGIBLE TO
SIGN UP FOR MEDICARE L. AS PART
OF THE JUST DISCHARGE A RELEASE
PLAN. BUT THEY ARE NOT ELIGIBLE
FOR MEDICARE- UNTIL RELEASE
THIS GAP CAN MAKE IT DIFFICULT
TO BOOK APPOINTMENTS ACCESS
PROVIDE THE CONTINUITY OF CARE
THAT THIS POPULATION
DESPERATELY NEEDS BY PROVIDING
PRISONERS WITH ACTUAL MEDICAL
COVERAGE WHEN THEY'RE WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS OF RELEASE. THE
STATE CAN INSURE THE PEOPLE DO
NOT EXPERIENCE ANY GAP IN
COVERAGE. AFTER THEY LEAVE
PRISON AND TREATMENT STOPS. AB
TWELVE FOURTEEN WILL PROVIDE
UNINTERRUPTED HEALTH COVERAGE
TO ENSURE THE HIGH RISK HIGH
NEED JUSTICE INVOLVED
POPULATIONS WILL RECEIVE MUCH
NEEDED CARE AS THEY TRANSITION
BACK TO THEIR COMMUNITIES.
JOINING ME TODAY ON THE PHONE
IS DR KEITH HUMPHREYS A
PROFESSOR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF PSYCHIATRY AND BEHAVIORAL
SCIENCES AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY. WHO HAS BEEN
INVOLVED ON THE WHITE HOUSE
COMMISSION ON DRUG FREE
COMMUNITIES NATIONAL ADVISORY
COUNCIL OF THE US SUBSTANCE
ABUSE. MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION WITHOUT FURTHER
ADO I HANDED OVER TO DR
HUMPHRIES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE LINE FOR OUR WITNESS IN
SUPPORT WHEN YOU'RE READY DR
HUMPHRIES. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
DOCTOR THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YES SIR.
OKAY FANTASTIC. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN CHAIRMAN WOULD THANK
YOU TO HOLD COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT THE
MINORITY LEADER HAS HAS RAISED
AS MENTIONED I'M A PROFESSOR AT
STANFORD I STUDY DICTION FOR
ABOUT THIRTY YEARS I'VE ALSO
BEEN AN INSPECTOR OF MENTAL
HEALTH AND ADDICTION SERVICES
IN CALIFORNIA. CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES. TO UNDERSTAND THE-
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT IF YOU CAN
YOU CAN RELATE IF YOU'VE EVER
HAD YOUR HEALTH INSURANCE WHICH
BECAUSE YOU CHOSE A DIFFERENT
PLAN OR YOUR EMPLOYER GET AND
THEN YOU FOUND THAT. YOUR CARE
WAS DISRUPTED IN SOME WAY
SOMETHING THAT APPOINTMENT AND
I GOT CANCELED SOME PAPERWORK
WENT AWRY. ON YOUR CUT YOUR
CARE WAS CHANGED- THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE IN THE
CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM BECAUSE
MEDICAID SHOT STOPPER DOUBLES
WHEN THEY GO IN A CORRECTIONAL.
FACILITY AND FOR THEM IT'S NOT
AN ANNOYANCE. IT SO OFTEN A
MATTER OF LIFE OR DEATH. YEAH
THERE'S A VERY STUDY IN THE NEW
ENGLAND JOURNAL OF MEDICINE
THAT SHOWS IN THE FIRST TWO
WEEKS BACK RELEASED. THE RISK
OF DEATH OF A FORMER INMATE IS
ABOUT THIRTEEN TIMES THAT. OF
THE GENERAL POPULATION-
BIPARTISAN LEGISLATORS IN
CONGRESS HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THAT AND BAKER GETTING STATES
TO- AND MEDICAID TO EXPERIMENT
WITH WITH EXTENDING COVERAGE
INTO CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
AND I APPLIED. ASSEMBLY WILL
AND WALDRON FOR WANTING
CALIFORNIA TO BE ONE OF THOSE
STATES. THE BIGGEST BENEFACTORS
OF THIS R. R. ANYONE WITH A
CHRONIC ILLNESS WILL BENEFIT
BUT THE BIGGEST ONES ARE ARE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE ADDICTIONS AND
MENTAL HEALTH WHO ARE PROBABLY
YOU KNOW. 758085% OF PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES. I DON'T HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT THAT APPALLING
DEATH RATE AFTER PRISON THE
BIGGEST COUNTRY CONTRIBUTOR IS
DRUG OVERDOSE AND NOT FAR
BEHIND THAT. IS SUICIDE SO AND
WHEN PEOPLE DO NOT HAVE
SERVICES WHEN THEY LEAVE. AND
THEY'RE NOT IN THERE THEY'VE
NOT HEARD CONTINUITY IS JUST
EXTRAORDINARILY VULNERABLE TIME
FOR THEM AND THEY AND THEY WILL
BENEFIT FROM HAVING THAT THE
TIME FOR THAT TO BE PREPARED
FOR PRISONS TO GET. STANDING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS THEY CAN PROVIDE THAT
CONTINUITY I WOULD SAY ALSO
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE PRISONERS
IT'S ALSO TRUE EVERY STUDY
WE'VE DONE SHOWS THAT PEOPLE
WHO LEAD CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES. AND GO BACK TO
SUBSTANCE USE OR HAVE A
PSYCHIATRIC CRISIS. ARE MORE
LIKELY TO COMMIT CRIMES WHICH
AFFECTS THE REST OF THE PUBLIC.
AND THEN THE MORE LIKELY AND
BACK UP IN PRISON WHICH WE ALL.
WE ALL PAID FOR SO THERE'S ALSO
A PUBLIC. SAFETY BENEFIT HERE.
I WOULD JUST AND BY GIVING YOU
ONE EXAMPLE OF WHAT'S POSSIBLE
AND TEAM OF US FROM OUR
STANFORD GROUP VISITED RHODE
ISLAND. WHICH WENT AHEAD AND
DID THIS ON THEIR OWN THE USING
STATE DOLLARS ENTIRELY IN JUST
FOR ONE POPULATION. THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ADDICTED TO OPIOIDS
WHEN THEY CAME INTO PRESENT.
DAY PAID FOR ALL THEIR CARE ALL
THE WAY THROUGH THE GOT
MEDICATED ASSISTED MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT. BROUGH THE
PRESENT AND THE SAME PROVIDER
WAS PAID- INTO THE COMMUNITY.
AND THEY DROPPED THE RATE OF
OVERDOSE DEATHS FROM THEIR
PRISONERS BY SIXTY PERCENT. AND
SO MANY OF THEIR OVERDOSES IN
THAT STATE FOR FROM PRESENT THE
ENTIRE STATEWIDE RATE DROPPED
212% SO THIS CAN BE A
TRANSFORMATIVE. ON PROBE FOR
VERY LONG POPULACE AND I URGE
YOU. TO SEE. IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE
DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SO WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES AND ASK FOR-
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME- YOUR
ORGANIZATION IF YOU REPRESENT
ONE AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL SO MADAM OPERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINES. GIVE HER
A PART OR OPPOSITION OF AB
TWELVE FOURTEEN. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND OR
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE AT SEVEN FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND ALSO
ALKERMES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THANK YOUR NECK. NEXT OVER TO
LINE UP FIVE OH ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
JANITORIAL ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU OVER TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING IT'S RETURN
NUMBERS COUNTY DELGADO ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO LINE- SIX THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWENTY SIX
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SORRY
GOOD EVENING CAMERAS THE MENACE
ON BEHALF OF THE ANAHEIM
LIGHTHOUSE LIGHTHOUSE TREATMENT
CENTER AND THE ORANGE COUNTY
RECOVERY COLLABORATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THIS WATER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
AND- SHOULD THE BILL PASS OUT
OF COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS. ON
THE SUBJECT. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
THANK YOU TO ALL OF SUPPORTERS
OF WORKED WITH US ON THIS- IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE REMOVE
ONE MORE BARRIER TO REENTRY AND
HAVE A MORE SEAMLESS REENTRY.
AND HELP PEOPLE SAVE LIVES- I
ORIGINAL VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- DID WE HAVE A
MORE. WHAT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER MAYES. A SECOND AYE MR
FLOOR. MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS. I'M
SORRY DID YOU DID DID I MISS
THAT. ARE YOU ARE YOU
EXERCISING OR- DID I MISS
SOMETHING I'M SORRY THE. I
CAN'T HEAR I'M SORRY I'M. HOW
GOOD OF A VERY VERY GOOD WELL
YOU'LL GET A CHANCE IN THE
SECOND VOTE I THINK MATH SECOND
WHAT I WOULD AYE MAYES. MAYES
AYE AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT VOTING.
BURKE BURKE I CARILLO. CARILLO
AYE FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN.
MCCARTY MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN HI RIVAS RIVERSIDE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO
WALDRON WALDRON AYE CALDERON
CALDERON HI. TWENTY ZERO TWELVE
ZERO LEAVE THE BIT THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK
YOU VERY VERY MUCH. WELL NOW
MOVE ON TO AB. EIGHT SEVENTY
FIVE. THANK YOU WELL- WHAT'S
WAITING WAITING FOR SOMEONE TO
HELP ME HERE SO IT'S COMING A
GOOD PARENT SAYS. PROBABLY
RULES AGAINST SHARING YOUR OWN
BILL SO. I WON'T DO THAT SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS- BEFORE I TALK
ABOUT WHAT THE BILL DOES I WANT
TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT CALIFORNIA
ADVANCING AND INNOVATING MEDIC
CAL OR CAL AIM AS IT'S KNOWN.
CALLIE IS FAR REACHING AND IS A
FAR REACHING AND AMBITIOUS
PROPOSAL FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND
REPRESENTS COUNTLESS HOURS OF
WORK OVER SEVERAL YEARS TO
IMPROVE THE MEDICARE PROGRAM.
AS YOU KNOW WE HAD THREE
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS ON
CALENDAR EARLIER THIS YEAR AND
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
IMPLEMENT CALLIN. FOR LOTS OF
REASONS WE THINK WE SHOULD BE
HEARING THESE PROPOSALS THROUGH
THE POLICY PROCESS A DOCTOR PAN
AND I DIVIDE UP THE MULTIPLE
CALLIN PROVISIONS IN FIVE
DIFFERENT BILLS AND USE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S LANGUAGE AS A
STARTING POINT. WHEN ISSUES ARE
VETTED AND ADDRESSED IN THE
LANGUAGE IS WORKED OUT THE
LANGUAGE MAY GO BACK INTO THE
TRAILER BILL- THIS BILL- IS THE
FIRST OF THE THREE KALYAN BILLS
WE'RE HEARING TODAY WILL
CONTINUE A PROGRAM CREATED IN
THE PREVIOUS MEDICARE WAIVER
PROGRAM CALLED THE GLOBAL
PAYMENT PROGRAM THAT REPURPOSES
WHAT ARE KNOWN AS FEDERAL
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE FUNDS.
TO PROVIDE CARE FOR THE
REMAINING UNINSURED IN LOWER
COST SETTINGS AND DON'T WORRY
THIS GETS MORE COMPLICATED.
SECOND THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
EXTEND THE HOSPITAL QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES QUALITY INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS TO PUBLIC HOSPITALS.
TO INCLUDE DISTRICT HOSPITALS
HE'S PAYMENTS ARE TO IMPROVE
QUALITY AND MAKE UP FOR THE
LOSS OF EXPIRING FEDERAL FUNDS
FROM THE LAST WAIVER THAT ARE
NO LONGER AVAILABLE. THE BILL
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE COUNTY
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES TO HELP
INMATES LEAVING THOSE
FACILITIES APPLY TO MEDICARE.
WILL COVER CALIFORNIA SO THAT
THEY CAN BE ENROLLED IN HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE UPON RELEASE. AND
LAST THIS BILL WOULD RESTART
DISCUSSIONS AROUND COUNTY
ELIGIBILITY DETERMINE PROPER
TERMINATION PROCESS FOR
MEDICARE. AND HOW TO IMPROVE
CONTACT INFORMATION FOR
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES. WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
HAVE A WHOLE PERSON CARE. WE
NEED TO HAVE BETTER WAYS OF
REACHING PEOPLE WHO MAY MOVE A
LOT. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
WORKING GROUP WILL LOOK AT.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL SARAH HESKETH OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS. AND CHARRETTE ELENA
THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM. THANK DOCTOR
WOULD ALL GO- TO FIRST TEST
MONEY SUPPORT. GOOD EVENING THE
ERICA MARIE I'M ACTUALLY THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS WE REPRESENTED TWENTY
ONE COUNTY OWNED OR AFFILIATED
IN UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HELP AT THE PROPERTY. AS YOU
ALL KNOW PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM SERVE AS POTENTIAL
THINKING THAT HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS MOST PATIENTS SEEN IN
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS
ARRIVE AUTOMATIC CAL REMAIN
UNINSURED MANY SPEAK A LANGUAGE
OTHER THAN ENGLISH AND MANY
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS. AND
OTHER CHALLENGING SITUATIONS.
OVER THE YEARS PUBLIC HEALTH
CARE SYSTEMS HAVE DEVELOPED
DEEP EXPERTISE IN TREATING
PATIENTS IN BETTER AND MORE
EFFECTIVE WAYS OFTEN BY MEETING
CHALLENGING PERFORMANCE
MILESTONES SECTION ELEVEN
FIFTEEN WAIVER PROGRAM. FOR
EXAMPLE BECAUSE OF THE WAY
FIRST PRIME PROGRAM AN ACRONYM
THAT STANDS FOR PUBLIC HOSPITAL
REDESIGN AND EFFECTIVE BEEN
MEDIC COW BETWEEN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
PATIENTS ACHIEVE BLOOD
PRESSURE. KEEPING BLOOD
PRESSURE CONTROL AND AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND PATIENTS WERE
SCREENED FOR DEPRESSION AMONG A
NUMBER OF OTHER IMPROVEMENTS. I
HAVE CURRENT WAIVER EXPIRES
EIGHTY EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE OF
WOULD HELP PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM TWO IMPORTANT THINGS.
FIRST ROLE CRIME INTO A
DIFFERENT AND MORE CHALLENGING
PROGRAM AS A CHAIRMAN WOULD.
DESCRIBE THE QUALITY INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS OR Q. I. P. IN SO
DOING PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS WOULD MOVE THE NEEDLE
EVEN FURTHER IN AREAS SUCH AS
DIABETES CARE AND BEHAVIORAL
MATERNAL AND PERINATAL CARE.
SECOND EXTEND AN EXISTING
WAIVER PROGRAM FOR THE
REMAINING AND SHORT AT THE
CHAIRMAN WOULD SAID THE GLOBAL
PAYMENT PROGRAM FOR ANOTHER
FIVE YEARS AND MAKE IT MORE
CHALLENGING BY OFFERING PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EARN MORE
FUNDING IF THEY PROVIDE MORE
HOLISTIC SERVICES TO THE
REMAINING UNINSURED. WHICH AS
WE'VE ALL SEEN WITH THE WHOLE
PERSON CARE PROGRAM REDUCES
EMERGENCY BRING YOU THROUGH
BETTER COORDINATION BY NEEDING.
A BROADER SET OF PATIENTS ME.
THESE PRODUCTS. I THINK
PROGRAMS EIGHTY EIGHT SEVENTY
FIVE WILL PROVIDE CRITICAL
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING TO HELP
BRIDGE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE COST OF SERVICES AND WHAT
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS
ACTUALLY RECEIVED FOR THESE
REASONS AND THE TREMENDOUS
THANK THE CHAIRMAN WHAT AND HIS
STAFF WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR MURRAY WILL MOVE TO-
STRADDLING. GOOD EVENING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M SURELY
THE LANE WITH THE DISTRICT
HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP FORUM HERE
TODAY REPRESENTING THE STATE
THIRTY THREE DISTRICT AND
MUNICIPAL HOSPITALS WE'RE VERY
PLEASED TO SUPPORT ALL ASPECTS.
OF EIGHTY EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE
AND I'M GOING TO SPEAK
PRIMARILY ABOUT THE QUALITY
INCENTIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM BUT
MISS MURRAY- MENTION. THE
THIRTY THREE DISTRICT MUNICIPAL
PUBLIC HOSPITALS ARE A DIVERSE
GROUP TWO THIRDS- IN WAL
CALIFORNIA AND MORE THAN HALF
HAVE A CRITICAL ACCESS HOSPITAL
DESIGNATION. MEANING THEY'RE
THE MOST REMOTE AND SMALL OF A
POSSIBLE. OTHER DISTRICT ARE
LARGE AND THEY'RE LOCATED IN
URBAN AND SUBURBAN AREAS. ALL
PROVIDE NEEDED HOSPITAL AND
HEALTH SERVICES BASED ON THEIR
COMMUNITIES NEED. BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN AND TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY THESE
HOSPITALS SUCCESSFULLY
PARTICIPATED AND THE PRIME
PROGRAM THAT MEMORY JUST
MENTION AND ARE PLEASED TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE THE WORK- ARE
THE TYPE OF WORK AND BUILD UPON
IT. IN THE QUALITY IMPROVEMENT-
I PURCHASED A QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PAYMENT PROGRAM DO
YOU THINK WE QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS
TO PROMOTE VALUE BASED
PURCHASING AND IMPROVING CARE
TO PAY- CARE PROVIDED TO
PATIENTS AND COMMUNITY. THE
INCENTIVE FUNDING TIED TO SIX-
IS TIED TO SUCCESSFUL OUTCOMES
ON METRICS. AND IT WILL ALLOW
THE DISTRICT HOSPITALS TO FOCUS
EFFORTS ON THE GOLDEN
PRIORITIES ONLY. WHICH IN TURN
ONLY BENEFITS THE COMMUNITIES
AND THE PATIENT SIR- WERE VERY
SUCCESSFUL AND- TIME HOSPITALS
WHAT SERVICES TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE WILL NOT.
NOT THERE PREVIOUSLY THESE
INCLUDED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ONCOLOGY AT CETERA OTHER SMALL
HOSPITALS CAN POINT TO A VERY
SPECIFIC LIFE STAGE BECAUSE OF
IMPROVED CANCER SCREENING. AND
OTHER- CAN POINT TO. THE WORK
THEY DID IN CHRONIC CARE
MANAGEMENT WHICH ONLY BENEFITED
THE CURE- OF THE HEALTH OF THE
PATIENTS WHICH RESULTED IN YOU
KNOW FEWER EMERGENCY.
DEPARTMENT VISITS ETCETERA. ALL
I ALL OF THE DISTRICT MUNICIPAL
HOSPITAL TO BE SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE DIRECT
RESULTS OF CRIME AND THESE WILL
BE EXPANDED AS PART OF Q. I. P.
WE- WORKED WITH THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTHCARE SERVICES. SO THAT
THE PROPOSED Q. I. P. FOR
DISTRICT HOSPITAL AND FIELD AND
OTHER WHITE PROJECTED TO
CONSIDER THE UNIQUENESS OF JUST
BURKE AND THE DIFFERENCES FROM
OUR COUNTY AND UC CALLING. M.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE COBEN HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED THESE
HOSPITALS AND TEMPORARILY
DIVERTED QUALITY EFFORTS BUT
ALL EAGER TO GET UP TO WHITE P.
EFFORTS INCLUDING BETTER
PLANNING DATA MINING ETCETERA.
BACK ON TRACK AS NOTED WE- IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
SEVENTY FIVE AND ARE VERY
GRATEFUL TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD FOR- FOR HIS EFFORTS
ALONG WITH A LONG DECLINE THANK
YOU THANK YOU MRS LANE AND
WE'LL SEE IF THEY'RE I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANYBODY ANY
TESTIMONY. IN OPPOSITION IS
THAT ACCURATE. IF THAT IS
ACCURATE THEN WE WILL MOVE TO-
OPEN UP THE- TELEPHONE LINES TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY. ADD ONS- IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION.
MADAME MODERATOR GIVE HERE. IT
HERE IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB EIGHT SEVEN FIVE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE OF
THEIR FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
AND WE HAVE AUTO LINE OF SIX
TWENTY FIVE AIRLINES OPEN.
THANK YOU MR BY CHURCH MEMBERS
I'M THERE ON THE STATE OF THE
ART FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AN EXTROVERT TO LINE SEVEN
SEVENTY OR ONE OF THE OPEN.
GOOD EVENING LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT HE- THANK
YOU. DO NOT HAVE A LINE OF
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD EVENING
AND YET ON BEHALF OF ESCAPE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT OVER THE LINE
SEVEN SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING DIANA
DOUGLAS WITH HEALTH ACCESS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS OF A LINE OF FIVE FORTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KELLY
BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTY FOR CALIFORNIA AND THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU WOULD
LIKE TO GO TO LINE OF SEVEN
SEVENTY THREE YEAR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING SHARON MEMBERS.
THIS IS ANDREA HAD STRUM
SPEAKING IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO AB EIGHT SEVEN FIVE BY JIM
WOOD. THANK YOU THANK YOU AND
MADAME MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE. THERE'S NOBODY
ELSE THANK YOU AT THE TIME WITH
THAT THEN WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE- I DO BELIEVE THAT WE HAD
IN MOTION- BY- AGUIAR-CURRY AND
A SECOND BY CARILLO IS THAT
ACCURATE. THAT IS ACCURATE WITH
THAT THEN- DOCTOR WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THAT WAS A FANTASTIC
CLOSE- CLEAR COULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WOULD I
WOULD I MAYES HI MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT VOTING.
BURKE BURKE I CARILLO. CARILLO
HI FLORA FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN HI RIVAS RIVERSIDE
RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO.
WALDRON WALDRON AYE CALDERON
CALDERON AYE. THIRTEEN ZERO
THIRTY WOULD IT IS THIRTEEN
ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT BELIEVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS- MOVING ONTO YOUR NEXT
ITEM- WHICH IS- EIGHTY NINE
FORTY TWO I BELIEVE YES THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. THIS
IS THE SECOND CAL AIM A BILL
AND IT DEALS WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CHANGES IT CONTAINS
SEVERAL PROFIT PROVISIONS BUT
OUR FOCUS ON THE THREE BIGGEST
CHANGES. FIRST THIS BILL
CHANGES HOW COUNTIES CLAIM
FEDERAL MEDICAID MATCHING FUNDS
COUNTIES USE REALIGNMENT FUNDS
TO DRAW DOWN FEDERAL FUNDS ON
THE BASIS OF WHAT ARE CALLED
CERTIFIED PUBLIC EXPENDITURES
OR CPD'S. CITY EASE OUR COST
BASE METHOD OF CLAIMING FEDERAL
FUNDS AND THIS METHOD OF CLIENT
CLAIMING CREATES A LOT OF WORK
ON THE WORKLOAD FOR COUNTIES
AND PROVIDERS TO DOCUMENT COSTS.
THEY ALSO CREATE FINANCIAL
UNCERTAINTY BECAUSE IT CAN TAKE
YEARS FOR THE COST
RECONCILIATION PROCESS TO BE
MADE FINAL AND IT RESULTS IN
AUDIT RISKS FOR COUNTIES AND
PROVIDERS AND THE THREAT OF
HAVING TO PAY BACK FUNDS. THIS
BILL WOULD INSTEAD SHIFT OUT
COUNTIES CLAIM WHAT ARE CALLED
INTER GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENTAL
TRANSFERS- I. G. T.'S. THIS
SHIFT IN HOW FUNDS ARE CLAIM OF
FREE CUNTIES AND PROVIDERS
FROM TREATING THE CHART. AND
WILL FREE UP TIME SO THAT
PROVIDERS CAN TREAT. PATIENTS
IT WILL ALSO ENABLE COUNTIES TO
PAY FOR PROVIDERS DIFFERENTLY
INCLUDING BUT ABOVE COSTS.
SECONDLY THIS BILL WILL IT
WOULD LIFT THE NUMBER OF
RESTRICTIONS WE HAVE IN STATE
REGULATIONS THAT LIMIT WHEN
TREATMENT AND CARE CAN BE
PROVIDED BY COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLANS. FOR EXAMPLE UNDER
EXISTING REGULATIONS A PROVIDER
CAN'T BE REIMBURSED NOW. UNTIL
THE PATIENT HAS BEEN DIAGNOSED
WITH A MENTAL ILLNESS WHICH
PROVIDERS REPORT CAN TAKE
SEVERAL SEVEN SESSIONS WITH A
PATIENT. THIRD THE BILL WOULD
CODIFY THE PROPOSED BEHAVIORAL.
HEALTH QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAMS TO HELP COUNTIES
PREPARE FOR THE MULTIPLE
CHANGES THAT ARE PART OF
CALTRAIN. TESTIFYING TODAY ON
THE BILL CAMILLE SCHRADER WHO
IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
POLICY AND PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT
OF REDWOOD COMMUNITY SERVICES.
AND MICHELLE CABRERA WHO IS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD WILL
GO TO- MISS SCHRAEDER.
MODERATOR HELLO. GOOD EVENING
CHAIRMAN WOULD AND HE
REMEMBERED. MY NAME IS CAMILLE
STRAIGHTER I AM THE VICTIM
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY AND
PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT AT REDWOOD
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE FORTY TWO. OUR MISSION OF
REDWOOD COMMUNITY SERVICES IT'S
ONE POWER COMMUNITY FOR LONG
TERM SUCCESS WE HAVE BUILT A
CONTINUUM OF PROGRAMS. BOB
BARKER CARE TO MENTAL HEALTH
SOME BEERS COMMITTEE BASED
SERVICES AND RECORD OF PROPERLY.
RTF PROGRAM THE BILL TO YOU
COULD AND OUR CLIENTS WHILE
PROVIDING CARE AND POSSIBLY
COMMUNITY CONNECTION. THAT
WOULD SERVICE IS ALL A NUMBER
OF THE CAL LINE FOR CHILD AND
FAMILY AND THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL BE HEALTH. AND
ORGANIZATION ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
HIM BILL NOW. FORTY THIS
CRITICAL IT'S CRITICAL BILL
PHOTO BY FORTY CHANGE IN CLEAR.
TO THE MEDIC HELPING HEALTH
SERVICES TO BE INPUT COULD
CALIFORNIA. AND INNOVATING
MEDICARE OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE-
INITIATIVE WE ARE PARTICULAR
PLEASED WITH THE EFFORT ON
RECOGNIZING THAT WE MIGHT
ADDRESS. CHILDREN IN A HEALTH
NEEDS EARLIER HE BEFORE THERE
MAY BE A TECHNIQUE THAT. AND IN
RECOGNITION OF THE THAT TO IS A-
THAT ALLOW. TO BE ABLE TO HELP
IN. CURRENT DIAGNOSIS REQUIRED
CAN PREVENT THOSE WE SERVE
PROJECTS MANY NECESSARY
SERVICES THEY NEED. IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT CHILDREN IN YEARS
DURING HIGH TO THINK THAT
SERVICES. BUT IT IS ALSO A-
IMPORTANCE FOR OUR TO AND OLDER
ADULTS MEDIC OUT. THIS IS A
CRITICAL REQUIREMENT AS THE
INDIVIDUAL CAUGHT IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE TWO SYSTEMS AND WE NEVER
WANT TO BE DELAYED OR DENIED
SERVICES THEY CAN QUITE
LITERALLY SAVE LIVES. THESE
KINDS OF DISPUTES HAPPEN OFTEN
FOR OUR OUR ADULT AND OLDER
ADULT BENEFICIARY WHO
DEFINITELY NEEDS THE MENTAL
HEALTH OR IF YOU D. G.
SERVICES. ALL CHANGES THAT ARE
PROPOSED IN THE CALLIN. ALL OF
THE CHANGES THAT ARE PROPOSING
CALLIN SHOULD BE CODIFIED IN
STATE LAW AND NOT ONLY THROUGH
THE TERMS AND CONDITIONS. OF
THE SECTION ELEVEN FIFTEEN OR
THE NINETEEN FIFTEEN BE
WAIVERS. THIS IS NECESSARY TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT THE THEIR
ONGOING STATE MEDIKAL
OBLIGATION. WE MUST DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENSURE
TRANSPARENCY AND CLARITY FOR
THOSE REQUIREMENTS BOTH DURING
AND AFTER THE WAIVER THAN. ON A
FINAL NOTE AS THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SYSTEM CONTINUES TO
STRUGGLE TO ADDRESS. PROVIDER
EDUCATION AND THE ESPECIALLY
BURDENSOME PAPERWORK REQUIRED
IN THE SPECIALTY SYSTEM WE
CONTINUE TO REQUEST THE CALLIN
HELP AT ST THE CLIENT. I YOU
NEED A AND NOT THE PEOPLE. FOR
ALL THREE IDENTIFIED WE URGE
YOU TO VOTE I'D ON EIGHTY NINE
FOUR TWO. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH
WILL GO TO OUR NEXT WITNESS. HI
GOOD EVENING MICHELLE CAPITA
WITH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
EDTA REPRESENTS THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH EXECUTIVES TO
ADMINISTER MEDIKAL AND THINKING
THAT SERVICES BURKE. MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS AND SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA IN ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES AND TO MUNICIPAL
ENTITIES. EVH MEMBERS STRONGLY
SUPPORT ACCOUNTING PROPOSAL
INCLUDED IN EIGHTY NINE FORTY
TWO INCLUDING THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PAYMENT POLITY. REFORMS
I'M MEDICAL NECESSITY CHANGES
AND THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM BUT
B. H. BUT- AS QUALITY
ADMINISTRATIVE INTEGRATION OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER SERVICES. AND THE DRUG
MEDI CAL ORGANIZED DELIVERY
SYSTEM OR B. AND C. O. D. F.
THREE NEWARK COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PLAN FULLY THAT THESE
REFORMS ARE CRITICAL STEPS
TOWARD LARGE SCALE SYSTEM
TRANSFORMATION FOR COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. IN SEVERAL
CASES THESE CHANGES PROMISED TO
ADDRESS LONGSTANDING
INEFFICIENCIES IN THE WAY THAT
MEDICAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES HAVE BEEN DESIGNED AND
MUST BE DELIVERED IN ORDER FOR
THE EMBARRASSMENT TODAY UNDER
MEDIC HOW. THESE PROPOSAL FORMS
WILL BE CHALLENGING TO
IMPLEMENT BUT SO WORTHWHILE
AND- THERE ARE MANY KEY POLICY
DECISIONS YET TO BE ADDRESSED
BOTH IN THE POLICY DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS AS WELL AS INDIGO
SHIZHEN WITH CMS BUT WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD FOR BRINGING FORWARD
DETAILS- WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST CONSIDERATION OF
SEVERAL. AMENDMENTS TO EIGHTY
NINE FORTY TWO HUNDRED BPH
QUICK FOR THE QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM THIS IS-
PERTAINING TO FUNDING THAT
WOULD COME FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND SUPPORT
IMPLEMENTATION OF VARIOUS
PILING PROPOSAL. WE BELIEVE
IT'S ESSENTIAL TO SUPPORT- THE
EX EXTENSIVE OPERATIONAL
CHANGES THAT ARE GOING TO COME
UNDER CAL EIGHTEEN AND THAT IN
ORDER TO DO SO WE NEED
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY AROUND
WHAT WE CAN FIND. WITH THESE-
BEACH QUICK FUN FOR THE ODS
RENEWAL AND PARTICIPATION WE'RE
JUST LACKING THAT THERE IS
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT
APPEARED TO BE CONTRADICTORY
AND WOULD LIKE FURTHER
CLARIFICATION ON THAT TO BE
CLEAR OUR MEMBERS WOULD SUPPORT
A FULL WIDE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE PM PEOPLE YET HOWEVER MANY
COUNTY BLACK ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WHICH WOULD. BE
NECESSARY TO EXPAND IF AT SOME
OF THE BASE. TODAY MORE THAN
NINE PER OF MANY BUT IF.
BENEFIT FROM OUR CORE DELIVERY
THE- DAMAGE- AND THE THAT HAVE
BEEN LEFT OUR LARGELY IN RURAL-
PARKED THE STATE SO THESE
EDITION INTERESTS. INVESTMENT
BE WORTH. TO RE DEAL THAT ON
THE STATE BY BENNETT BASIS. FOR
MEDICAL THAT THAT WHICH IS SUCH
AN AND SHE- OF WANT FLAG THAT
WE BELIEVE THAT WE WOULD WANT
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS- COULD
CLARIFY THAT- THE WILL OF THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PLAN
ISN'T SERVING ALL CHILDREN. WE
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT WE NEED A
LANGUAGE AROUND SIGNIFICANT
FUNCTIONAL IMPAIRMENT AS AN
ADDITIONAL BARRIER AND WE'VE
ADVOCATED THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE BENEFITS THEY ALSO.
SAID THAT I DID THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY- WE WILL MAKE SURE
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS IF THEY'D- I
WANTED TO GET ANY FURTHER WILL
WILL WILL MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
THERE FOR. A TO PROVIDE ANY
ANSWERS- I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- SO-
MADAME MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE
ADD ONS. OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE WANT TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION JUST YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION. AND WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOUR SUPPORT OR UP. OF AB
NINE FORTY YOU MAY PER ONE AND
THEN. ONE NINE ZERO FOR ANY
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE AND SEVEN THE
SIXTY SEVEN YEAR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING MKTX ON
BEHALF OF ESTATE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
NET SERVER SO I SEVEN SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ADRIN CHOCOLATE THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE A CHILD FAMILY
SERVICES TO SUPPORT ANY OF THE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER
THE LINE OF SEVEN SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
GERMAN WORD THAT ARE IN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MARICA
COLLEGE WITH CONFIDENCE THAT
THE GUY. CENTER FOR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB NINE FOUR TWO THANKS SO
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT THE
LINE OF SEVEN SEVEN FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
MISTER CHAIRMAN WENDY ****
REPRESENTING HALFWAY SYCAMORE
BASED IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINE FOUR
TWO. THANK YOU. MEXICO ONE OF
SIX TWENTY FIVE AIRLINES OPEN.
GOOD EVENING BY MEMBERS THAT
THE PHARMACY IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. A LINE OF
SEVEN SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HIS MERE MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. SACRAMENTO NINE
SEVEN SEVENTY A LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD EVENING ORINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON ON POVERTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND NEXT OF
ADELINE FIVE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING KELLY BROOKS
ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. EXTROVERT TO LINE UP FOR
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BOB LANE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL WOULD BE APRIL AGENCIES
IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT NINE
FORTY. THANK YOU DO YOU HAVE
ANY MORE COLORS. YES WE HAVE TO
LET PEOPLE GO TO LINE SEVEN
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SEVEN SEVENTY VOTER HERE FIVE
ONE THREE. PLEASE GO I HAVEN'T
SEVEN THREE. GOOD EVENING
ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE THIS
IS ANDREA HEDSTROM SPEAKING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHT
NINE FOUR TWO BY JIM WAS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AN EXTRA GO TO
LINE OF FIVE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
MARK THE COMMUNITY ON THE
HAPPENED AT BANBURY INSTITUTE
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE FOURTEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEEDED SO THERE'S ONLY TWO MORE
CALLERS JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT'S CORRECT. ALL RIGHT WILL
BE. CORRECT THERE IS NO MARKET
VIEW THAT'S- WILL BRING IT BACK
THEN TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I THEN-
I DO I THOUGHT THAT- MISS
RODRIGUEZ WAS- MAKING WAS GOING
TO MAKE A MOTION BUT HE'S HE'S
NOT THERE NOW SO- THE MOTION IS
GOING TO BE- BY MISS BURKE- AND
THE SECOND IS GONNA BE BACK
AGUIAR-CURRY- IF THERE ARE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS-
AND THE DOCTOR WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE- THAT IS A WONDERFUL
OF CLOTHES- THE CARD COULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS THE PAST TWO
APPROPRIATIONS WHAT. I WOULD
AYE MAYES AYE MAYES HI
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE BURKE.
BURKE I CARILLO. CARILLO AYE
FLORA FLORA HIGH MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE
RIVAS RIVASAYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. WALDRON
WALDRON HIGH CALDERON CALDERON
HI IT'S FOURTEEN ZERO DO IT IS-
YOUR BILL IS UP ONLY THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- MOVING
ON TO YOUR FINAL ITEM WHICH IS
AB ELEVEN THIRTY TWO DOCTOR
WARD THANK YOU HI THIS IS THE
FOUGHT THIRD AND FINAL CALLIN
BILL IN THE FINAL BILL OF THE
NIGHT- THIS BILL SUNSETS A
PROGRAM THAT WAS ESTABLISHED
AROUND TWENTY THIRTEEN CALLED
CAL MANY CONNECT. WITH THE
STATE AUTHORIZED COMBINED
MEDICARE AND MEDICARE PLANS AND
SEVEN COUNTIES IT REPLACES CAL
MANY CONNECT WITH THE STATE
PRIVATE STATEWIDE PROPOSAL WITH
THAT IS CALLED A LINE
ENROLLMENT OF MEDICARE AND
MEDICARE PLANS ALIGNED
ENROLLMENT MEANS MEDICARE
MANAGED CARE PLAN WILL HAVE TO
ESTABLISH A MEDICARE PLANS FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID I'LL CALL
THE D. SNAP. DUAL ELIGIBLE
SPECIAL NEEDS PLAN THE PERSON
IS ELIGIBLE FOR BOTH MEDICARE
AND MEDICARE WOULD RECEIVE
THEIR BENEFITS THROUGH ONE PLAN
THAT OFFERS BOTH MEDICARE AND
MEDI CAL BENEFITS BUT IN
SEPARATE PRODUCTS THE IDEA OF A
LINE TO RUN ENROLLMENT IS CAE
WOULD BE BETTER INTEGRATED AND
COORDINATED IF YOU HAVE ONE
PLAN COORDINATING THE ENTIRETY
OF THE PERSON'S MEDICARE AND
MEDICAL SERVICES. SECOND THE
BILL WITH A LINE BENEFITS
ACROSS ALL THE DIFFERENT
MEDICARE MANAGED DELIVERY
MODELS RIGHT NOW SOME BENEFITS
ARE CARVED INTO THE PLAN IN
SOME COUNTIES BUT NOT IN OTHERS
THIS CREATES WORK FOR THE STATE
IN SETTING RATES AND MAKING THE
PROGRAM MORE COMPLICATED WHEN
PEOPLE MOVE IN SWITCH COUNTIES
THE BIGGEST CHANGE HERE IS
INSTITUTIONAL LONG TERM CARE
SUCH AS SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES. IN THE AREA I
REPRESENT THESE BENEFITS ARE
CARVED IN BUT IN OTHER AREAS OF
THE STATE THEY ARE NOT THERE
ARE SEVERAL ISSUES THAT REQUIRE
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS IN THIS
BILL INCLUDING THE DETAILS ON
HOW ALIGNMENT WILL WORK RATES
PAID THE LONG TERM CARE
PROVIDERS HOW THE TRANSITIONAL
WORK CONTINUITY OF CARE AND
WHAT ALIGNMENT MEANS AT THE
PROVIDER LEVEL. BUT THAT'S WHY
WE'RE DOING THE BILL THROUGH
THIS POLICY PROCESS I'D LIKE TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT DESCRIBING
COMMENT TEN IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AND TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL LINDA WAY
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. AND EVEN GO FROM SCAN
HEALTH PLAN. MISTER MCCARTY
MOVED IN THIS BILL AS AMENDED
IT TO APPROPRIATIONS I DID NOT
SEE WHO WAS SECONDING THAT WAS
THAT- MISS REAVIS- SECONDED
THAT MOTION WE ARE GOING TO GO
TO A WITNESSES TO THEM- TO MISS
GELB- AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE
NOTE OF THAT- BREVITY IS
REWARDED AT THIS LATE HOUR SO
THE SHORTER THE BETTER. MISCO
OKAY ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU
EVERYBODY ALBEIT SHORT OF I
CAN'T AND I ADMIRE YOU ALL FOUR
OF THE MARATHON THAT YOU HAVE-
HOLDING TODAY. MY NAME IS EVE
GALA I'M THE SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT FOR MEMBER AND
COMMUNITY HEALTH FIRST BEGAN
HEALTH PLAN- I HAVE BEEN
FORTUNATE TO SERVE MANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
ADULT THROUGH THAT
ORGANIZATION. AND OUR MISSION
IS TO KEEP SENIORS HEALTHY AND
INDEPENDENT AND WE ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN THIRTY TWO
AND IN SUPPORT OF THE ENTIRE
CALTRAIN INITIATIVE- IN IN-
SPECIFICALLY WERE SUPPORTIVE
OF- AT ELEVEN THIRTY TWO. AND
THE REMOVAL OF THE CAP FOR THE
FULLY INTEGRATED DUAL ELIGIBLE
SPECIAL NEEDS PLAN AT THE
DOCTOR WOULD TALK ABOUT A DUAL
ELIGIBLE SPECIAL NEEDS PLAN
WILL THERE'S A SPECIFIC KIND.
CALLED BELIEVE INTEGRATED WHICH
REALLY EMBODIES EVERYTHING THAT
CAL AMY IS TRYING TO DO IT
PROVIDES LONG TERM SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS INTEGRATED WITH
MEDICAL SERVICES BOTH MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID SERVICES. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF KEEPING SENIORS
HEALTHY AND INDEPENDENT AND
KEEPING THEM LIVING IN THE
COMMUNITY AND OUT OUT OUT. OF
INSTITUTIONS. I CAN HAS A
UNIQUE ROLE IN THE CALIFORNIA'S
ELDERS PARTY. I FIRST COUNTRY
WITH THEM PURPOSE SENIOR SIR
CAR AND THAT CONTINUES TODAY-
MORE THAN FORTY YEARS THAT
GOING. AND WE GREW BEYOND THAT
WE SERVE NOW TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
HELLO COUNTY. THIRTY THOUSAND
OF THOSE BENEFICIARIES HAVE
BOTH MEDICARE AND MEDI CAL AND
ABOUT 50% OF THEM ARE ENROLLED
IN A FULLY INTEGRATED DUAL
ELIGIBLE SPECIAL NEEDS PLAN.
THIS KIND OF PRODUCT- IS
CONTRACTED WITH BOTH MEDICARE
AND MEDI CAL SO IT IS REGULATED
BY BOTH ENTITIES AND IS
RESPONSIBLE TO BOTH ENTITIES
FOR QUALITY OUTCOMES. AT THE
END OF THE FOURTH HALF START
PLAN UNDER CMS'S- STAR RATING
WE'VE BEEN THAT WAY FOR MANY
YEARS. AND WHAT THIS DOES IS
ENSURES THAT MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES GET THE HIGHEST
POSSIBLE QUALITY OF CARE. BUT
MOST IMPORTANTLY IS THE
INTEGRATION OF THE LONG TERM
SERVICES AND SUPPORT. I'M
INTERESTED LET'S TAKE THAT IT
IS NOT SPENT DENTAL DELEGATED-
AND TRUE THAT WERE ABLE TO
KEEP- 95% OF THE PEOPLE WHO
MEET NURSING FACILITY LEVEL OF
CARE LIVING SAFELY IN THE
COMMUNITY. THROUGH THE
INTEGRATED WHOLE PERSON MODEL-
HE REALLY SUPPORT ADDED BY THE
SENATE AND PASTE WHICH ARE
ABOUT AS INTEGRATED AS YOU
COULD POSSIBLY GET- I'M AND
NEED SUPPORT CALPAIN THAT- HAS
THIS MODEL OF INTEGRATION.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE PACKED. UP
FOR CITING THE SENATE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- THE CAPS
ARE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
RIVERSIDE INTEND BERNIE DINO.
AND THIS BILL ELIMINATES THOSE
CAPS WHICH WOULD ALLOW IRAN AND
OTHER PLANS TO SERVE
BENEFICIARIES WITH BOTH
MEDICARE AND MEDI CAL IN THIS
INTEGRATED WAY. WE APPRECIATE
THE REMOVAL OF THE CAPS AND WE
APPRECIATE- AB ELEVEN THIRTY
TWOS OVERALL SUPPORT FOR
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
TODAY GREAT YOU SO MUCH I KNOW
HAVE MORE A WITNESS AND SO.
AND- JUST AS A REMINDER THAT
BRED WILL BE REWARD- SO WE'LL
GO TO THE SECOND WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. GOOD EVENING WENT AWAY
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON MON
POVERTY WE SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF THE OMBUDSMAN
PROGRAM AND STAKEHOLDER
WORKGROUP THE OMBUDSMAN WILL
HELP. INDIVIDUALS HAVE MUCH
NEEDED SUPPORT DURING
TRANSITION WHICH IMPACT. THREE
TIMES AS MANY SENIORS AND
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
COMPARED TO PASS. COUNT MANY
CONNECT TRANSITION THERE ARE
SOME OUTSTANDING ISSUES LEARN
FROM CAL MANY CONNECT RELATED
TO CONSUMER FRIENDLY
INVOLUNTARY ENROLLMENT PROCESS
EASIER CONTINUITY OF CARE AND
THE LINE NETWORK. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ANYTHING MINISTRATION AS
PART OF THE WORKGROUP AND
THEY'LL PROCESS THE REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT AT THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY-
REGISTER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO
THE PHONE LINES. A MADAME
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY- ADD
ON'S THOSE WHO WISH TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. ON
THIS BILL JUST YOUR NAME. YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
EIGHT YOU YOUR SUPPORT OPPOSITE
OF AB ELEVEN THIRTY TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE OF
THEM ZERO FOR ANY SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. AND WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF SEVEN SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
AGAIN CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
ANDREA HAD STRUM I AM SPEAKING
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO YOUR
PHARMA FASCIST AGENDA USE OLDER
KIDS TO FARM THANK YOU SO MUCH
ABOUT A MODERATE MOVE TO THE
NEXT. CALLER IN. THANK YOU AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THEN WE WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SEEING NONE- THERE
HAS BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
WITH THAT- DOCTOR WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE YEAH AND THIS CLOSE IS
GONNA BE A LITTLE LONGER SO I
APOLOGIZE AND BREVITY WON'T BE
REWARDED LIKE. BUT I WANT TO
SAY A COUPLE THINGS HERE FIRST-
WE WERE- WE REFER WE WERE
TRACKING A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE BILLS. ULTIMATELY THEY HAD
A HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT
REFERRED TO THIS COMMITTEE WE
HEARD WE SET A HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN- THAT CAN'T HAPPEN
WITHOUT AN AMAZING STAFF BEHIND
US. AND THESE ARE THESE ARE
THESE ARE MY COMMITTEE STAFF
OUR COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING TO
HELP OUR MEMBERS MOVE MOVE
ISSUES FORWARD- I WANT TO
SPECIFICALLY CALL OUT- SCOTT.
BAIN FOR HIS WORK ON THESE
THREE CALAIS BILLS- SCOTT IS
PROBABLY THE PREEMINENT EXPERT
ON MEDICARE NOW. IN THE
BUILDING AND WE ARE THRILLED
THAT HE IS OUR OUR CONSULTANT-
ON THIS ON THIS ISSUE. BEHIND
ME IS A RAZA CAMANO OUR CHIEF
CONSULTANT WHO WHO RUNS THE
SHIP AND- SHE'S A GREAT
CAPTAIN. AND KEEPS US ALL
ONLINE- AND RIGHT BESIDE HERS
PADDY RODGERS R. R. R. R.
SECRETARY- OUR LEAD SECRETARY
WE ALSO HAVE A ANOTHER
SECRETARY MARSHALL KIRKLAND. WE
DON'T SEE TODAY ARE- G. BABCOCK
ALSO ONE OF OUR OUR OUR
WONDERFUL CONSULTANTS LARA
FLYNN. ANOTHER WONDERFUL
CONSULTANTS AND CHRISTINE
APPEALING. THESE PEOPLE ALL
WORK REALLY HARD TO MAKE YOUR
BILLS- BETTER BILLS THAT WE CAN
MOVE ON TO THE SENATE NO WE'RE
NOT DONE THIS YEAR BY ANY
MEANS. WE'RE GONNA GET BE
GETTING SENATE BILLS OVER HERE
BUT I JUST WANT TO RECOGNIZE MY
AMAZING STAFF- FOR THE WORK
THEY'VE DONE- UNDER REALLY
REALLY DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES
SO. THANK YOU. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTES.
WELL I THINK- THE STAFF FOR-
FOR HAVING A SUCCESSFUL-
COMMITTEE S. SESSION THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE DO HAVE THE BILL
BEFORE US WHICH IS AB ELEVEN
THIRTY TWO HAS BEEN IN MOTION
AND A SECOND AND IF THE COURT
COULD PLEASE. CALL THE ROLL.
MOTIONS THE PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHAT. I WOULD
AYE MAYES AYE MAYES AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE BURKE
BURKE I. RIO CORREO AYE FLORA
FLORA HIGH MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN HAI MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE
RIVAS RIVAS AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. WALDRON
WALDRON HI CALDERON CALDERON HI
FOURTEEN ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON THIS
GO TO THE TOP OF THE FILE AND-
WE STILL I DO BELIEVE WE HAVE
ONE MEMBER MISSINGI HOPE HE'S
GOING TO. BE IN THE BUILDING
COME DOWN AND JOIN US- I DON'T
KNOW FOR SURE. HE'S HE'S HE'S
STILL IN PUBLIC SAFETY SO OKAY.
OKAY THANK YOU SO WE WILL GO TO
FIRST TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH IS AB ELEVEN SIXTY NINE
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN AB
NINETY EIGHT AND AB TWELVE
EIGHTY SIX- THOSE ARE ITEMS
NUMBER ONE FOUR SEVEN AND
FOURTEEN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FOR A- FLUORIDE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I AM
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. FOURTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER TWO
AB THIRTEEN OH SIX ARAMBULA
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE IN CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FLORA FLORA
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE NAZARIAN
NAZARIAN AYE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I SANTIAGO. FOURTEEN
ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
THREE WAS PULLED BY THE AUTHOR
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB FIVE
SEVENTY PLEASE LIFT THE CALL
AND CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
MAYES MAYES NOT VOTING. BURKE
BURKE I CARILLO CARILLO AYE
FLORA LARA NOT VOTING
MAIENSCHEIN. MAIENSCHEIN ARE
VOTING MCCARTY MCCARTY I RIVAS
RIVERSIDE. SENATOR TENDED TO
TEND TO THE BILL WAS OUT ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
THE CALL AND CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BIGELOW BIGELOW NOT
VOTING. FLORA FLORIDA VOTING
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS.
RIVERSIDE SANTIAGO. TWELVE ZERO
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER EIGHT-
PLEASE LIFT AB EIGHT AB SIXTY
ONE MR GABRIEL PLEASE LIFT OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MAYES ALL RIGHT MAYES
I BURKE. BURKE I CARILLO RUBIO
AYE FLORA LARA AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I RIVAS RIVERSIDE
SANTIAGO. FOURTEEN ZERO
FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER NINE
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AB TEN FIFTY BY
MISTER GRAY. LARA LARA AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY INEZ AREA
NAZARIAN HI SANTIAGO. FOURTEEN
ZERO FOURTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB TWELVE EIGHTY BY MISS
IRWIN- PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE FLORA
FLORA I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I IN THIS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE RIVAS. RIVERSIDE
SANTIAGO. FOURTEEN ZERO THANK
YOU ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT BY MR JONES SAWYER
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MAYES. MAYES NOT
VOTING. CARILLO CARILLO I.
RIVAS RIVERSIDE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI. TWELVE TO ONE
TWELVE ONE- ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
AB THREE TWENTY THREE PLEASE
LIFT THE CALL AND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MAYES. MAYES NOT
VOTING. BURKE BURKE I CARILLO
CARILLO AYE FLORA. FLORIDA
VOTING MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
HI RIVAS. RIVERSIDE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE WALDRON WALDRON
NOT VOTING. CELEB IN A ONE
ELEVEN ONE THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY BY MR LEVINE.
MAYES MAYES NONVOTING. CARILLO
CARILLO AYE FLORA LARA FIVE
REVERSE RIVERSIDE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI FOURTEEN ZERO THANK
YOU ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR BY MISTER
ROBERT RIVAS PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
MATHIS MAYES I. CARILLO CAREER
HIGH FLORA LARA I RIVAS
RIVERSIDE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE
CALDERON CALDERON NINE FIFTEEN
ZERO ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB
EIGHT OH WAIT BY MR STONE
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA. LARA AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAJORING HIGHNESS
AREA NAZARIAN I REVERSED
RIVERSIDE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AB EIGHT AB THIRTY
TWO BY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY PLEASE
LIST THE CALL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MAYES. MAYES MAYES NOT
VOTING. BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE
BURKE BURKE I CARILLO CARILLO
AYE FLORA. FLORIDA VOTING
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
RIVAS RIVAS AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I. THIRTEEN ZERO THANK
YOU ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB
FORTY FIVE I MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS MAYES HI MAYES
AYE BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOW.
CARILLO CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA
I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
RIVAS. RIVERSIDE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
HI. FOURTEEN A ONE THANK YOU
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN AB FORTINO
SEVEN BY MISS BURKE. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT
VOTING CORREO I'M SORRY I HAVE
US NINE FLORA. FLORIDA VOTING
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE REVERSE
REVERSE AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
WALDRON. WALDRON. FIVE THIRTEEN
ZERO THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY AB NINE THIRTY FIVE BY
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAYES. MAYES NOT VOTING
BIGELOW. BIGELOW NOT VOTING
CARILLO. CARILLO I FLORIDA
FLORIDA VOTING. RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ I. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
HI. TWELVE ZERO CLOSE ZERO ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY TWO AB NINETY
SEVEN BY MISTER NAZARIAN PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND SKIPPED ITEM TWENTY
ONE HELLO I'M SORRY I'M SORRY I
DID- MAYBE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
ONE AB FIFTEEN FORTY TWO BY MR
MCCARTY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MAYES
MAYES AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. BIGELOW
BIGELOW NOW CARILLO CARILLO AYE
FLORA. FLORIMO RODRIGUEZ.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. ELEVEN A
TWO LIVE IN THE TO ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO AB NINETY SEVEN BY
MISTER NAZARIAN PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BIGELOW BIGELOW NOW. FLORA.
FLORIDA VOTING MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE SANTIAGO CENTER
HI THIRTEEN A ONE THIRTEEN ONE
THANK YOU ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY THREE
BY MISTER NAZARIAN PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. WHAT I WOULD I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I LARA FLOOR AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN EYES
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI.
FIFTEEN ZERO THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY FOUR
FIFTY FOUR BY MR RODRIGUEZ
PLEASE LIFT THE CALL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MAYES I'M SORRY
WHICH ITEM TWENTY FOUR ABOUT
THE MAYES NOT VOTING. BIGELOW
BIGELOW NOW BURKE. CARILLO
CORREO HI MAIENSCHEIN I'M SORRY
HAVE IS NOT VOTING- MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE RIVAS. RIVAS I
WALDRON. WALDRON NOT VOTING.
TEN ONE TEN ONE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY
TWO BY MR RODRIGUEZ PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I. FIFTEEN ZERO THANK
YOU ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX AB
TWELVE TWENTY NINE MISTER
RODRIGUEZ PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
AGUIAR-CURRY. MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
I. FOURTEEN ZERO THANK YOU ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN AB TWELVE
FOURTEEN BY MISS WALDRON PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HIGH. FOURTEEN ZERO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE I WOULD
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SANTIAGO.
CENTERRA FIVE FOURTEEN ZERO.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
NINE FORTY TWO WOULD PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I
FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
AB ELEVEN THIRTY TWO WOULD
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO. FIVE ZERO FIVE
FIFTEEN ZERO. OKAY THANK YOU- I
THINK WE NEED MR SANTIAGO STILL
HAS SOME SOME ADDITIONAL VOTES
I THINK THAT'S THAT'S IT SO-
CONSENT CALENDAR- ITEM NUMBER
ONE FOUR SEVEN AND FOURTEEN
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN ZERO I
REMEMBER TO AB THIRTEEN OH SIX
ARAMBULA PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. NUMBER OF
ITEM NUMBER FIVE I THINK YOU
MIGHT A VOTED FOR THAT ONE-
THAT'S PASS ITEM NUMBER SIX- AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY EIGHT CUNNINGHAM
OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI
THIRTEEN ZERO. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB SIXTY ONE GABRIEL
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS SOUTH SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN ZERO ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB TEN FIFTY BY
MISTER GRAY PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
pONTARIO. SANTIAGO I FIFTEEN
ZERO A NUMBER TEN AB TWELVE
EIGHTY BY MR WIN PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I
FIFTEEN ZERO AND NUMBER ELEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT BY MR
JONES SAWYER PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THERE ARE NONE ABSENT MEMBERS
THERE NO ARE THERE ARE THERE
ANY. THAT SHOULD THAT SHOULD DO
IT THEN. YEAH AGUIAR-CURRY. I
DON'T EVEN. ONE ITEM ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY SIX AB. TWELVE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL CALL THE APPS AMERICA.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I.
FIFTEEN ZERO. A SINGLE PERSON
THE GOVERNMENT OF COURSE. OKAY
WITH THAT WE WILL CLOSE THE
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.